ASSEMBLYMEMBER FLORA NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER BRING IN THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. AND THE CLERK WILL
CALL THE ROLL. AGUIAR-CURRY
ARAMBULA. BARRICADE HEN BERMAN
BIGELOW BLOOM BOERNER HORVATH
BONTA BRO BURKE CALDERON
CARRILLO CERVANTES CHAU CHEN
DAVID CHIU CHOI KANSEN CHU
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALLY
DALY DEEP. EGGMAN FLORA FONG
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN GABRIEL
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON GLORIA
GONZALEZ GRAY GRAYSON HOLDEN
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KAMLAGER KILEY LACKEY. JEAN
LEóN LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MULLIN
MURATSUCHI THIS AREA OBERNOLTE
O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RAY IS LOOSE REBAJAS
ROBERT RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO
SALAS SANTIAGO SMITH STONE TEAM
VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER WICKS WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT IN THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER. AND IN THE
GALLERY. TO PLEASE STAND FOR
THE PRAYER. TODAY'S PRAYER WILL
BE OFFERED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHAD DOCTOR CHECK. MAYBE THE
WILL THE CREATOR THAT WE ALLOW
OUR EYES TO SEE THE SUFFERING
OF OTHERS USE OUR VOICES TO CRY
OUT AGAINST INJUSTICE AND
COMMIT OUR STRENGTH TO CREATE
MORE TOLERANT COMPACTION WORLD.
A MAN. YES I GUESS VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE MISS
WALDRON. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER PLEASE JOIN ME AS WE
SALUTE OUR FLAG. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG OF THE
UNITED. ISRAEL. YEARS AGO. YEAH
WELL. THANK YOU MAY BE SEATED
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY
JOURNAL ASSEMBLY CHAMBER SO MY
MARCH SIX TWENTY TWENTY SOME
ABOUT AT ONE PM THE ON WILL
COVER MULLIN REPORT TO FOR
THESE PRESIDING CHIEF FOR
SUPPORTER THE DESK FOCUSED MOST.
ALL. FOR CALLING ME MOST HERE
ALL AROUND MOVES MISS. SECONDS
SO THE READING THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS EFFORT. THERE ARE
NO IN. OF TO BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED. REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE. THERE ARE NONE
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THE
ABSENCES FOR THE DAY. FOR
PERSONAL BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MURATSUCHI AND FOR
MEDICAL LEAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BILL QUIRK.
MEMBERS REAR
PROCEDURAL MOTIONS.
MISTER
CALDERON HERE RECOGNIZED YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTION SIR THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE TO ALLOW SPEAKER RENDON TO
SPEAK ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY
TODAY. WITHOUT OBJECTION SHALL
BE THE ORDER. I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FIFTY SIX
ENJOYABLE SIXTY TWO A THE FILE
NOTICE REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE TO
NOTICE SB THREE FIFTY HILL ON
WEDNESDAY JUNE TENTH NINE AM
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER PENDING RE
REFER A FROM THE UTILITY
COMMITTEE. MR FOR. SIR THANK
YOU SPEAKER WE WITHHOLD AS WITH
YOU KNOW CONSENT ASPIRIN CALL
VOTE. MISTER CALDERON AND
MISTER SECOND ON THE RULES
SUSPENSION. MEMBERS THIS IS A
PROCEDURAL VOTE. CLARK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE CALDERON IS
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE. MR
FLORA IS ASKING FOR A NO VOTE
ON THE RULES SUSPENSION. MISTER
CALDERON IS ASKING FOR AN I.
PEOPLE AND MR FLORA NOW.
MISTER
CALDERON US FOR NINE AND MR
FLORA NO THIS IS A PROCEDURAL
VOTE MEMBERS. TAKES FORTY. IN A
SEVENTY NINE MEMBER HOUSE. THE
CLERK WILL. CULTURAL EYES FORTY
NINE KNOWS FIFTEEN THE RULES
ARE SUSPENDED. MISTER CALDERON
YOUR AGAIN RECOGNIZE THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I MOVE TO
SUSPEND THE RULES TO ADOPTED
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ON SB
THREE FIFTY HILL WITHOUT ROOMS
THE FILE UPON RECEIPT OF THE
COMMITTEE REPORT APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE ON WEDNESDAY JUNE
TENTH AS PASSED UTILITIES AND
ENERGY JUNE TWENTY. MR OR FOR
PURPOSE SIR. SPEAKER WE WILL
HOLD ASK NOW CALL. MISTER
CALDERON MOVES MISTER BY SET.
ON THE RULE IS. MEMBERS TO IS A-
VOTE. CARPOOL OPEN THE ROLE. IF
YOUR CALL THE ROLL IS ASKING
AND I VOTE IN FLOOR IS ASK FOR
NO VOTE CALLED. IS ASKING NINE
MISTER FLOOR NOTE IS FOR. WELL
THIS IS A PROCEDURE OF A
MEMBERS ON THE REAL SUSPENSION.
MISTER CALDERON TEST FOR AYE MR
FLORA NO. YEAH THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE A ROLE AS FIFTY ONE.
KNOWS FIFTEEN. RULES ARE
SUSPENDED MINUTES PER CALDERON.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE AGAIN
RECOGNIZE. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND JOINT WILL
SIXTY TWO A THE FILE NOTICE
REQUIREMENT TO ALLOW THE HEALTH
COMMITTEE AND THE AGING AND
LONG TERM CARE COMMITTEE TO
MEET JOINTLY AT NINE AM
TOMORROW IN THE ASSEMBLY
CHAMBER THEY WERE PREVIOUSLY
SCHEDULED TO MEET THEM.
OBJECTION MOVIE TO BUSINESS ON
THE FILE SECOND READING
CORPORATION. ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
THREE TWENTY THREE SOME
CONSTITUTIONAL MEMBER TO FIVE.
SOME OF 1-837-840-5194
792-025-2020. EIGHT TWENTY
THIRTY TWENTY FORTY TWENTY
FORTY THREE TWENTY FIFTY TWO
TWENTY FIFTY FO TWENTY
ONE EIGHTEEN TWENTY. SIX TWENTY
ONE TWO TWIN 418-921-9820 TWO
EIGHTEEN. TWENTY TWO FIFTY
SEVEN 272-280-2220 THREE TWENTY
FORTY ONE TWENTY THREE FORTY
TWO. THREE SEVEN TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY EIGHT OR. FIVE TWENTY
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR FIFTY TWENTY
FORTY THREE TWENTY FIVE BE FIVE.
252-424-3720 FIVE IN ONE. FIVE
NINETY TWO TWENTY TWENTY.
462-020-4420 SIX SIXTY TWENTY
SIX SIXTY THREE. FORTY SEVEN
FORTY SIX TWENTY HUNDRED TWENTY
THIRTY TWENTY EIGHT NINETY ONE
TWENTY NI 603-053-3130 FOUR
THIRTY ONE SIXTY NINE THIRTY
TWO SIXTEEN THIRTY TWO TWENTY
SIX. 322-832-6930 TWO SEVENTY
NINE THIRTY THREE HUNDRED
THIRTY THREE. THIRTY AND SENATE
BILL SIX TWENTY. MINUTES THANK
YOU DAVID ALL BILL RENDON READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
ON RECONSIDERATION ITEM SIXTY
SIX THROUGH SIXTY EIGHT ARE TO
BE CONTINUED. ON THE THIRD
READING FILE FILE ITEMS SIXTY
NINE. THROUGH. ONE TWELVE. PASS
AND RETAIN.
MEMBERS WE WANT TO
TAKE A FILE ITEM ONE THIRTEEN
THIS IS FILE A ONE THIRTEEN A.
B. TWENTY TWO THIRTY FOUR BY.
MR CHOW. THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TO THIRTY
FOUR BY SOME REMEMBER CHAO AN
ACCOLADE A SCHOOL COMMITTEE
COLLEGE EMPLOYEES MR CHOW YOU
MAY OPEN. MAYBE THERE NOW AB
TWENTY TWO THIRTY FOUR IS A
SIMPLE BILL THAT WILL ALLOW THE
PERSONNEL COMMISSIONS OF SCHOOL
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS
TO AVOID BEING REPRESENTED. BY
THEIR DISTRICTS ATTORNEYS WHEN
A CONFLICT OF INTEREST ARISES
AND INSTEAD. RECEIVE
INDEPENDENT LEGAL ASSISTANCE
UPON A MAJORITY VOTE. PERSONNEL
COMMISSIONS ARE CIVIL SERVICE
SYSTEMS THAT ENSURE DISTRICTS
ARE TREATED. THEIR EMPLOYEES
FAIRLY THEY ACT IN A QUIZ OUR
JUDICIAL CAPACITY TO REVIEW THE
DISTRICTS OF DISCIPLINARY
ACTIONS. GENERALLY A
COMMISSIONS RECEIVED. THEIR
COUNSEL FROM THE SAME LAWYERS
THAT WORK FOR THE DISTRICT.
HOWEVER CURRENT LAW ALLOWS
THESE LAWYERS TO CONTINUE
REPRESENTING THE COMMISSION
EVEN WHEN SUCH REPRESENTATION
POSES A CONFLICT OF INTEREST.
AND COMMISSION HAS NO POWER TO
PREVENT THAT. THIS BILL AB
TWENTY TWO THIRTY FOUR WILL PUT
A PROVIDE PERSONNEL COMMISSION
IS THE RIGHT TO RETAIN
INDEPENDENT LEGAL COUNSEL IN A
MAJORITY OF COMMISSIONERS
DETERMINED THAT A CONFLICT IS
EXIST. BETWEEN THE GOVERNING
BOARD AND THE COMMISSION
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR EITHER. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CHOW. SEEING NO MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION ON THIS
ITEM. CLARK LIBERAL ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF A RESERVE
OF.
THE CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT ISIS SIXTY SEVEN. NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES. JUST
A REMINDER IF YOU'RE A MEMBER
CURRENTLY NOT SITTING AT A DESK
YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR BILLS FROM
THE PODIUM IN THE WELL. IF
YOU'RE A MEMBER NOT CURRENTLY
SEATED AT THE DESK AND YOU'D
LIKE TO PARTICIPATE. PLEASE USE
THE. MICROPHONE IN THE REAR OF
THE CHAMBER. MEMBERS WE ARE AT
FILE ITEM ONE FOURTEEN. THIS IS
AB TWENTY ONE AT NINETY THREE
COVERAGE. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
ONE NINETY THREE BY THE
COMMITTEE ON VETERANS AFFAIRS
ACCOLADE TO MILITARY AND
VETERANS MISS IRWIN YOU MAY
OPEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER ASSEMBLY BILL A
TWENTY ONE NINETY THREE SIMPLY
FORMALIZES IN STATE STATUTE THE
CHANGING OF THE NAY MILITARY
STATE RESERVE THE STATE GUARD-
THIS BILL PASSED FROM THE
VETERANS. AFFAIRS COMMITTEE ON
CONSENT I RESPECTFULLY ASK I
HAVE A. THANK YOU MS IRWIN.
YEAH SEEING NO MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION. CLICK LIBERAL ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSER ROLL
TIDE OF A I SAW NO ZERO. THAT
PASSES MEMBERS WE'RE FILE AT A
ONE FITEEN. AB. TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY FOUR BY MISTER
GALLAGHER FOR COREY. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY ONE SEVENTY FOUR BY
SIMPLY MEMBER GALLAGHER AN
ACCOLADE HOMELESSNESS. MR
GALLAGHER YOU MAY OPEN ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTY
FOUR WOULD AUTHORIZE YUBA AND
SUTTER COUNTIES TO FORM A JOINT
HOMELESS MULTI DISCIPLINARY
PERSONNEL TEAM TO FACILITATE
INFORMATION SHARING AND SUPPORT
IDENTIFICATION ASSESSMENT AND
LINKAGE OF HOMELESS INDIVIDUALS
TO HOUSING IN SUPPORT OF
SERVICES. HI THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE- FOR ALL
DISTRICTS BUT I WOULD
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT IN. ON
THE TWENTY ONE SEVENTY FOUR
THANK YOU. TANK YOU MISTER
GALLAGHER. SENIOR MEMBER SEE
RECOGNITION. QUIRK LIBERAL. OUT
OF. ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE IT IS
OUR ABOUT.
CLARK WELL CLOSE
ROLE. CHINA HI SEVEN WERE KNOWS
YOUR- THAT PASSES FILE ITEMS
ONE SIXTEEN THROUGH ONE TWENTY
ONE PASS AND RETAIN THAT BRINGS
US TO FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY TWO
A. B. THIRTY TWO SIXTY. BY MISS
WICKS FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS READ WITH AMENDMENTS.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY TO SIXTY
WITH A MINUTES BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WICKS. THIS
WORKS ON THE AMENDMENTS THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE FOR
PURPOSES OF AMENDMENTS TO AB
THIRTY TO SIXTY THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE LANDLORDS PROVIDE
TENANTS FOR THE CHOICE OF
THREE. ALTERNATIVES WHEN PAYING
THEIR SECURITY DEPOSIT ATTENDED
CAN CHOOSE TO ONE PAINFUL TO
PAY IN INSTALLMENTS OR THREE
PURCHASE SECURITY DEPOSIT
INSURANCE OR SECURITY BONTA.
TODAY PROPOSING AMENDMENTS
ADDRESSING SUGGESTIONS BROUGHT
UP BY MEMBERS ON THE ASSEMBLY
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE THESE
AMENDMENTS WILL FIRST ALLOWED
IN AND LANDLORDS NEGOTIATED.
MONTH TO MONTH AGREEMENTS AND
SECONDLY CLARIFY THAT HANNAH IS
IN VIOLATION OF THEIR LEASE
AGREEMENT IF YOU DO NOT RENEW
THEIR SECURITY DEPOSIT
INSURANCE AND FEEL THE
REMAINDER THEIR SECURITY
DEPOSIT RESPECTFULLY ASK HER I.
BUT- SHE NOTICED. OF A- AND
WITHOUT A- WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE AYES HAVE
IT THE MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED
BILLS OUT TO PRINT IN BACK. ON
FILE FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY THREE
A. B. THIRTY TWO. SIXTY TWO.
THIS IS MISTER STONE. THIS IS
FIVE A ONE TWENTY THREE A. B.
THIRTY TO SIXTY TWO FOR THE
PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS CORKERY
WITH AMENDMENTS ASSUME IT'LL
THIRTY TO SIXTY TWO WITH THE
MINUTES BY WE MEMBER MARK STONE
MR STONE THE MEMONS. THIS BIG.
IT'S NOT SEVEN BABY THIRTY TWO
SIXTY MEMBERS TRY ADDRESS OF
THE OP. CONCERNS IN THE BELL I
ASKED THE YOU WE VOTE I ON THE
THAT A PIECE OUT SPREAD PUT
BACK ON THE FILE. ONE OF. THANK
YOU MISTER SOUNDS SAY NO TO AND
WITH OF WE MADE A V<c.cyan> VOTE ON</c>
THE AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE FAVOR
AYE. AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY YES
HAVE IT THE MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED
THE BILL IS OUT TO AND BY ON
FIVE. PASTOR A BALLOT ONE
TWENTY FOUR AND ONE TWENTY
FIVE. THAT BRINGS US TO FILE
ITEM ONE TWENTY SIX A. B.
TWENTY ONE NINETY BY MR MEDINA
CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
ONE NINETY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEDINA AN ACCOLADE A COMMUNITY
COLLEGES MR MEDINA. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. AB
TWENTY ONE NINETY WOULD ALLOW
BOTH STUDENT MEMBERS OF THE
BOARD OF GOVERNORS. TO BE FULLY
EMPOWER VOTING MEMBERS AT THE
BEGINNING OF THEIR APPOINTMENT.
THERE ARE CURRENTLY TWO STUDENT
MEMBERS OF THE BOARD OF
GOVERNORS BUT ONLY ONE HAS THE
ABILITY TO VOTE. THE VOTING
STUDENT MEMBER EXERCISES A
CRUCIAL ROLE REPRESENTING ALL
TWO MILLION STUDENTS AT THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
AS A STUDENT POPULATION OF OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE IS INCREDIBLY
DIVERSE DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVE
SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO BE
REPRESENTED. THROUGH TO VOTING
STUDENT MEMBERS. AB TWENTY ONE
NINETY IS A SIMPLE AND
REASONABLE STEP THAT SEEKS TO
PREACH THE POP OF THE STUDENT
VOTE. ON THE BOARD OF TRADE.
THIS BILL HAS RECEIVED
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT AND IS AT
ZERO NO VOTES I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MISTER MEDIA SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. QUIRK
LIBERAL MEMBERS OF. IT IS OUR
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
DESIRABLE.
THE CLERK WILL.
CULTURAL TITLE BUT I SIXTY SIX
KNOWS ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES
WROTE A PASS TEMPORARILY ON
FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY SEVEN.
ASCERTAIN ON ONE TWENTY EIGHT
AND ONE TWENTY NINE.
MEMBERS
THAT ARE CURRENTLY WITHOUT A
DESK WE ARE PRESENTING FROM THE
WELL. THE PODIUM IN THE WELL.
THANK YOU MISTER COOPER THIS IS
FILE AT A ONE THIRTY AB TWENTY
THREE HUNDRED. CALGARY ASSEMBLY
RULE TWENTY THREE HUNDRED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER AN
ACOLYTE OF PUBLIC HEALTH MISTER
COOPER. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB ONE FROM
TWENTY NINETEEN CONNECTED
SAFETY STANDARDS FOR YOUTH
TACKLE FOOTBALL CONSISTENT WITH
THE STANDARDS THE HIGH SCHOOL
FOOTBALL LEVEL. AB TWENTY THREE
HUNDRED IS IT CLEAR THAT
MEASURE TO RESOLVE THE ISSUE OF
THE EMPTIES PRACTICES. OUTSIDE
THE SCOPE OF PRACTICE BUT CLEAR
APPLYING THEIR THOR TO BUY OFF
THE CARE OR RESCUE SERVICE
CONSIST. FIRST OR- THIS BILL
ALSO AUTHORIZES THE. HIGHER
LEVEL WAS MEDICAL. TO MOVE IN
YOUR- WHO EXHIBITS AND-
INCLUSIVENESS OF CONCUSSION OR
OTHER HEAD INJURIES ARE AS YOUR
RIVAL. OKAY THANK YOU MISS
COOPER. SEEING NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS I. QUICKLY
CHARITABLE. ALL MEMBERS OTHERS
OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS BETTER
THAT OF A- CLARK WELL CLOSER
ALL. CALVET I SIXTY NINE KNOWS
YOU'RE A THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MISS LAMAR WE'RE GOING BACK TO
THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY
NINE. AB TWENTY SIX FIFTY SIX
CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
SEVEN FIFTY SIX BY SOME
REMEMBER THE MONNING ALKYLATING
TO INSURANCE MISS LAMAR. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB TWENTY
SEVEN FIFTY SIX WILL PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
A DIFFERENT THING CONDITIONS D.
IC POLICY IS ISSUED OR RENEWED
INTRODUCED AB TWENTY SEVEN
FIFTY SIX BECAUSE OF ITS
IMPORTANCE TO COMMUNITIES LIKE
MINE WHO HAVE EXPERIENCE WHILE.
EIGHT TWENTY SEVEN FIFTY SIX
WILL MAKE SURE THAT AND
ELIMINATION OF COVERAGE IS
CLICK HERE TO THE HOMEOWNER I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MS AMOUNTS HE A
RECESSION DEBATE. CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS OF.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
OF THE SARAJEVO. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE THE DESIRE TO VOTE. THE
CLERK. WELL CLOSER ROLE TATTOO
BUT I SEVENTY NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES THIS IS FILE
ITEM ONE THIRTY ONE AB TWENTY
FOUR THIRTY SIX BY MR BLOOM
CORKERY. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FOUR THIRTY SIX BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLOOM AN ACCOLADE TO
INSURANCE MR BLOW ME A MAIL
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS TODAY I'M PRESENTING K.
A. B. TWENTY FOUR THIRTY SIX
WHICH WOULD HELP CONSUMERS
COMPLY WITH APPLICABLE BUILDING
CODES IN PLACE AFTER A MAJOR
PROPERTY LOSS BY PROVIDING.
BUILDING CODE UPGRADE COVERAGE
TO HOME OR TO HELP COVER THE
COST OF BUILDING CODES AT THE
TIME OF LOS. THE BILL REQUIRES
FILE FIRE POLICIES TO INCLUDE A
MINIMUM 10% OF PRIMARY DWELLING
IN- DWELLING LIMITS COVERAGE AS
AN ADDITIONAL AMOUNT. AVAILABLE
FOR REPLACEMENT COSTS OF THE
INSURED STRUCTURE AT THE TIME
OF LOS. THE CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES FIRES OF THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS HAVE LEFT MANY
CALIFORNIANS WITHOUT HOMES AND
MANY OF THE HOMES THAT ARE
DESTROYED BY THESE WILDFIRES
ARE OLD AND NOT UP TO DATE WITH
CURRENT AND STATE AND LOCAL
BUILDING CODES. BUT THESE
BUILDING CODES WILL APPLY TO
THE REBUILD AND ARE LIKELY TO
BE COVERED BY THEIR INSURER.
LEAVING MANY UNSUSPECTING
HOMEOWNERS FORCED TO PAY OUT OF
POCKET TO COVER THE COST OF
COMPLIANCE WITH UPDATED AND
NEWLY OUT ADDED BUILDING CODES.
OR IT MIGHT RISK JEOPARDIZING
THE RESULT ENTIRELY SO IN ORDER
TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE. AB
TWENTY FOUR THIRTY SIX REQUIRES
ALL RESIDENTIAL FIRE POLICIES
TO INCLUDE A MINIMUM OF TEN
PERCENT. BUILDING UPGRADE CODE.
BUILDING CODE UPGRADE COVERAGE
TO HELP REDUCE THE AMOUNT OF
OUT OF POCKET COSTS TO
CONSUMERS ARE FORCED TO PAY.
HAVE ACCEPTED COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS SO WHEN THE BILL WAS
IN THE- ASSEMBLY INSURANCE
COMMITTEE AND I'LL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH INDUSTRY AND OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS. AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD SHOULD PASS OFF THE
FLOOR TODAY. AND THIS BILL
SPONSORED BY INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER RICARDO LARA. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
THE. HE WAS BLOOM. SEEING NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. OR CALL
THE ROLL. YOU DESERVE IT ALL
MEMBERS. VOTERS OUT OF A- ALL
VOTE. THE DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE.
YEAH. CHECK A VALVE MEMBERS ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT AYE SIXTY KNOWS ONE. THAT
MEASURE PASSES. THIS IS FILE AT
ONE THIRTY TWO. AB TWENTY NINE
TWENTY ONE BY MR STILL COVERAGE.
SOME AGO TWENTY NINE TWENTY ONE
BY SOME REMEMBER MARK STONE AN
ACT RELATING TO FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS MR STONE YOU MAY
OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS THIS BILL MERELY
CLARIFY SOME OF THE TERMS IN
THE STUDENT LOAN SERVICING ACT
I ASK FOR YOUR I'VE A. ENGLISH
DOWN SAYING NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE. PARK LIBERAL MEMBERS.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
THE CLERK WILL CLOSE A ROLL
CALL VOTE AYE AYES SIXTY NINE
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES. WE
ARE FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY THREE.
A. B. TWENTY FOUR TWENTY SIX.
IT SO MIDDLE TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
SIX BY SOME MEMORY AS AN ACT
RELATING TO VICTIMS OF CRIME.
IS RACE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS. AB TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY SIX WILL
STRENGTHENED CALIFORNIA'S
POLICY WHEN AND UNDOCUMENTED
VICTIM OF A CRIME SIX
CERTIFICATION OF A UV SO OR
WHEN A VICTIM OF SEX
TRAFFICKING SIX A TV THE
CERTIFICATION. OUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT. ALLOWS FOR VIC OF
CRIMES WHO COOPER WITH LONG TO
PROTECTED. THROUGH YOU VIEWS
THE OR TV'S A FORM. THIS BILL.
THE ROLE OF TO GOV BY. SCHOOL
BOARDS AND PUBLIC UNIVERSITIES
IT ALSO REQUIRES THAT THE
CERTIFYING AGENCY MUST CERTIFY
THE APPROPRIATE FORM IF A
VICTIM MEET ALL ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS. THIS BILL HAS
RECEIVED UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT AND HAS RECEIVED N NO
VOTES. IT WILL ENHANCE. THE
OVERALL PUBLIC SAFETY OF
CALIFORNIANS TO ENSURE THAT
IMMIGRANTS WHO ARE VICTIMS OF
CRIME. HELLO ENFORCEMENT AND
EIGHT RECEIVE THEM THE NEED
DOCUMENT THE PART THEM FROM
DEEP. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. AB REST SEEN
DISCUSSION TODAY. CLERK WILL
OVER THE ROLE. MEMBERS DESERT
ABOUT ALL MEMBERS FOR ARE TO.
ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRABLE.
YEAH THANK CLARK WELL. CLOSE
ROLE. HOW AYE AYES KNOWS THAT
MEASURE PASS. THIS IS FILE ITEM
ONE THIRTY FOUR. AB. TWENTY
FIVE TWELVE FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENT COVERAGE WITH
AMENDMENT ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FIVE TWELVE WITH A MINUTES BY
SOME MEMBERS MARK STONE. MISS
STONE THURMOND. THANK YOU THIS
IS AND MEMBERS THE AMENDMENT IS
MINOR BUT WAS AN ISSUE THAT WAS
BROUGHT UP BY THE DA'S SO
STATION WE WHICH TO MAKE THIS
AMENDMENT I ASK THAT YOU VOTE I
ON THIS AMENDMENT THAT THE BILL
THEN BE SET UP FOR TO PUT BACK
ON THE FILE. THANK YOU MISTER
STYLE WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
YES SEVENTY MEMBERS ARE ADOPTED
THE BILL SOUTH PRINTER BACK ON
FILE. WHAT PASS TEMPORARILY AND
FILE ITEM ONE THIRTY FIVE. THAT
BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTY SIX. AB THIRTY THIRTY
FIVE BY MR PATTERSON CORPORATE
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY THIRTY
FIVE BY SOME REMEMBER PATTERSON
ANOTHER'S INOCULATE ANIMAL
WELFARE MISTER PATTERSON. THANK
YOU MEMBER I AM MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS. AB THREE OH THREE FIVE
WILL A MAN THE PENAL CODE TO
ALLOW LAW ENFORCEMENT TO POST A
PUBLIC NOTICE OF ROOSTERS OR
OTHER ANIMALS USED IN A LEGAL
FIGHTS IN AN ONLINE SOURCE
RATHER THAN SOLELY IN A HARD
COPY NEWSPAPER. ILLEGAL ANIMAL
FIGHTING SUCH AS **** FIGHTING
TAKES PLACE ALL THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA BUT IS A SPECIALLY
PERVASIVE IN CENTRAL CALIFORNIA
CURRENT LAW REQUIRES A PUBLIC
NOTICE OF DESTRUCTION OF THE
ANIMALS TO BE. POSTED IN A HARD
COPY NEWSPAPER. FOR THREE
CONSECUTIVE DAY. AB THREE FIVE
SIX TWO UPDATE THIS CODE. BY
ALLOWING LAWN FOR TO POST THE
SAME CONTENT AS REQUIRED IN A
HARD COPY NEWSPAPER ON A SOCIAL
MEDIA OUTLET WEBSITES BELONGING
TO LAW ENFORCEMENT OR OTHER
AGENCIES LOCAL GOVERNMENT EIGHT
ENTITIES AND NEWSPAPER
WEBSITES. ALLOWING LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES TO PUBLISH
NOTICES ONLINE WOULD ALLOW THEM
TO PUBLISH THEM IN MULTIPLE
LANGUAGES FURTHER INCREASING
PUBLIC ACCESS AND AWARENESS.
CURRENT LAW SETS UP AN OUTDATED
MONOPOLY FOR HARD COPY
NEWSPAPERS SO AS A RESULT THEY
CAN CHARGE MONOPOLY RATES IN
THE 800-021-1000 DOLLAR RANGE
BECAUSE THERE IS NO OTHER
OPTION. THIS BILL PROVIDES
NUMEROUS ALTERNATIVE OPTIONS AB
THREE ZERO THREE FIVE PASSED
OUT OF THE ASSEMBLY PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE SEVEN ZERO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS PATTERSON.
SEEING NO- MEMBER SEE
RECOGNITION ON THE ITEM
CORPORAL PAROLE. AMBER SO.
THESE ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS THERE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE WE DESERVE A.
ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT
I SIXTY SEVEN KNOWS ONE. THAT
MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEM ONE
THIRTY SEVEN PASS RETAIN. FILE
ITEM ONE THIRTY EIGHT IS AB
THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT CORPORATE.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY EIGHTY
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVID
CHIU HER ACCOLADE THE TENNESSEE.
MR CHIU MAIL THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB THIRTY EIGHTY EIGHT
IS TECHNICAL CLEAN UP OF LAST
YEAR'S A. B. FOURTEEN EIGHTY
TWO. THE TOWN OF PROTECTION ACT
WHICH ESTABLISHED A RECAP ON
RENT INCREASES AND JUST BECAUSE
PROTECTIONS. DURING THE FINAL
DAYS OF THE LAST SESSION EVERY
ASPECT OF THIS BILL WAS HEAVILY
NEGOTIATED BUT IN ITS FIRST
YEAR WE'VE SEEN A FEW
PROVISIONS ARE NOT AS CLEAR AS
IT COULD BE. THESE MEMORIES ARE
MEANT TO BE NON CONTROVERSIAL I
APPRECIATE THE ENGAGEMENT BY
ALL STAKEHOLDERS AND WILL
CONTINUE TO FINE TUNE THE
LANGUAGE THE BILL HAS NO
OPPOSITION BY EITHER SIDE OF
THE DEBATE. AND ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHIU. SAME
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
QUIRK LIBERAL. IT IS OUR TO
VOTE OFTEN VOTERS TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBER VOTERS ARE ABOUT. THE
CLERK WELL CLOSER TIDE I SAID
FOUR NOW ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASS PASTORATE ON FOR ITEM ONE
THIRTY NINE AND FOR. THAT
BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM ONE
FORTY ONE A. B. THIRTY THREE OH
EIGHT BY MR GABRIEL CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY THREE OH
EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GABER
ANOTHER'S AN ACCOLADE HOUSING.
MR GABRIEL THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER PLACE TODAY PRESENT A
B. THIRTY THREE OH EIGHT ON THE
OF ME I ON BEHALF OF YOU THIS A
BILL THE WOULD ITS- THE- OF
URGENT NEEDED A- HOUSING. FOR
SOME OF THE MOST IMPORTANT
PUBLIC SERVANTS ARE TEACHERS
AND SCHOOL EMPLOYEES UP TO
CLARIFY THE- TEACHER HOUSING
ACT THERE'S BEEN A LITTLE BIT
OF CONFUSION ABOUT THIS- THAT
THE A HOUSING CRISIS IN
CALIFORNIA'S PARTICULARLY
ACUTE. FOR AYE TEACHERS IN THE
LOS ANGELES AREA. TEACHERS
WOULD BE TO SPEND 85% OF THEIR
INCOME ENTRY LEVEL TEACHERS 5%
OF THEIR INCOME TO AFFORD AN
AVERAGE RENTAL UNIT. THIS WELL-
INSURE THAT THERE IS HOUSING
THAT SCHOOL DISTRICTS CAN USE-
THE LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX
CREDIT TO BUILD AFFORDABLE
HOUSING THAT BECAUSE WORK WITH
LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES TO PROVIDE
HOUSING FOR THEIR PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES. THIS IS A COMMON
SENSE BIPARTISAN MODEST MEASURE
WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST.
DRIVE OUT. MUCH APPRECIATED GET
REAL. SEEING DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. CORPORAL ALL MEMBERS
ARE VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO. ALL MY VOTE. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. THE. YEAH. WORK WELL.
CLOSE ROLE TO ABOUT ICE FOUR NO
YOUR THAT MEASURE. THIS IS FILE
ITEM ONE FOR TWO A TWENTY BY
MISTER MAIN SHOW QUIRK OR-
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR BY
SOME MEMBERS MAIN SHOW AND ACT
WITH TO MEDIC MISS KAHN. THE
SUMMATION THANK MISTER AND
MEMBERS FOR TELL FRAUD A WHEN
DOCTOR THIS SPECIAL IN
ASSISTIVE REPRODUCTIVE KNOWING
AND AT WITH SPERM SAN THAT IS
DE. FROM THE ONE CHOSEN BY
PATIENT. ALARM MINIS HAVE A CAR
ACROSS COUNTRY THE DOC HAS
IMPLANTED A PATIENT WITH HIS
OWN SPERM SAMPLE WITHOUT THE
PATIENT'S KNOWLEDGE OR CONSENT.
THANKFULLY CALIFORNIA'S ENACTED
STRICT LAWS AGAINST THESE
PRACTICES HOWEVER THERE IS A
GLARING DEFICIENCY IN CURRENT
LAWS IN WHICH THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS BEGINS AT THE
COMMISSION OF THE CRIME IN
CASES OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA
VICTIMS DID NOT BECOME AWARE
THAT SAMPLES WERE SWAPPED.
DURING INSEMINATION UNTIL
DECADES LATER AS A RESULT OF
DNA TESTING UNDER CURRENT LAW
THESE VICTIMS WOULD BE UNABLE
TO SEEK RECOURSE AND THE
PERPETRATORS MAY POTENTIALLY A
STATE PROSECUTION. AB TWENTY
FOURTEEN WOULD CHANGE THE
STATUTE OF LIMITED OF LIMITED
STATUE OF LIMITATIONS ON
FERTILITY FRAUD RELATED CRIMES
TO ONE YEAR FROM DISCOVERY OF
THE OFFENSE I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE ON THIS.
TERRIBLE PRACTICE. THEY YOU
MISTER MAIENSCHEIN SAYING NO
MEMBERS SEEKING. ON THE BILL.
CLARK WILL OPEN THE ROLE
MEMBERS. OBSERVER ALL MEMBERS
VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE DESERVE A. YEAH.
THE CLERK WILL. CLOSER ROLL
TIDE I SIX NINE KNOWS THAT
MEASURE PASS. WELL I DON'T WANT
THREE PASS RETAIN. RESIST ITEM
ONE FORTY. A. B. TWENTY FOUR
FORTY FIVE BY MS RAY THE-
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO FOUR FOR FIVE
BY SOME REYES AN ACTOR TO CIVIL.
THIS RACE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB TWENTY FORTY
WILL TO LAY GUARD THE RYE TO
BRING A- ON OF THEIR CHOI. IF
THE CHILD AWAY DUE TO THE
WRONGFUL CONDUCT OF ANOTHER AND
THE CHILD HAS NO LIVING LEGAL
PARENTS. ACCORDING TO CURRENT
LAW FOR MINOR PASSES AWAY DO
THE WRONGFUL CONDUCT OF OTHERS.
AND THE MINERS ON MARRIED AND
DOES NOT HAVE CHILDREN THAT
THOSE WHO CAN BRING FORTH THE
CASE ON THE MINERS BIOLOGICAL
OR- OF PARENTS. BUT EVERY CHILD
IS RAISED BY THEIR PARENTS. IF
THE MINERS REYES BY LEGAL
GUARDIANS WHO HAVE NOT
OFFICIALLY ADOPTED THE MINOR.
THESE LEGAL GUARDIANS DO NOT
HAVE LEGAL STANDING TO BRING A
CLAIM. IN THE IN THE EVENT OF
WRONGFUL DEATH EVEN THOUGH BOTH
OF THE CHILD'S BIOLOGICAL OR
ADOPTIVE PARENTS ARE DECEASED.%
THIS BILL ALLOWS A LEGAL
GUARDIAN TO SEEK JUSTICE FOR
CHILD WHO PASSED AWAY DUE THE
WRONGFUL CONDUCT OF ANOTHER.
WHEN THE CHILD'S PARENTS CANNOT
DO SO BECAUSE THEY ARE DECEASED
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. FAMOUS RACE SENIOR
DISCUSSION TODAY. OR CALL THE
ROLL. ZARA VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. OKAY. WORK
WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE OUT SIXTY
NINE NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES WE'RE GOING TO PASS. IN
RETAIN A FILE ITEM ONE FORTY
FIVE PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE
ITEM ONE FORTY SIX WE ARE FILE
ITEM ONE FORTY SEVEN. AB THIRTY
TWENTY CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY TWENTY BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GLORIA AND OTHERS AN ACT
RELATING TO BUSINESS. MR
LAURIA. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY TWENTY REQUIRES
PENALTIES COLLECTED BY THE CITY
TO CITY ATTORNEY ACTION UNDER
THE STATE'S UNFAIR PROPERTY AT.
TO BE PAID TO CITY OF SANDY HI.
BILL WILL INCREASE THE FOR THE
LOCALS DIEGO SO ATTORNEY TO
PROCESS UNFAIR BUSINESS. IN THE
INTEREST OF CONSUMERS AND
ENVIRONMENT I'M- ASK FOR YOUR
AYE THOSE. THANK YOU MISS
GLORIA. SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE. QUIRK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. ALL MEMBERS OF. THERE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. YEAH. ALL MEMBERS OF OUR
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FIFTY
TWO KNOWS FOURTEEN. THAT
MEASURE PASSES. THIS IS FILE
ITEM ONE FORTY EIGHT. THIS IS
FILE ITEM ONE FORTY EIGHT. AB.
THIRTY ONE THIRTY THREE.
THERE'S MISS AGUIAR-CURRY
CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
ONE THREE BY SOME MEMBER ACT
AND OTHERS ACT RELATING
REFUGEES. THIS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB ONE FOR THREE CODIFY
CAL COMMITMENT TO RESET
REFUGEES WITHOUT DISCRIMINATION
AS PART OF THE UNITED STATES
RECEPTION AND PLACEMENT
PROGRAM. CALIFORNIA HAS A LONG
TRADITION OF OFFERING REFUGEES
HAVING RECEIVED NEWLY ARRIVED
REFUGEES SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY
THESE REFUGEES THEN TURNER
TRIBUTE SICK. ECONOMIC AND
CULTURAL CONTRIBUTIONS TO OUR
STATE INCLUDING SEVENTEEN
BILLION IN SPENT POWER OF
DIVERSITY WILL ARE SO PROUD OF.
THIS BILL SIMPLY CODIFIES OUR
LAW. WE'LL COULD LEAD TO A
COMMITMENT TO THOSE RAY RIFF
RAFF IN OUR COUNTRY IN STATE I
ASK FOR YOUR UP. THANK SEEING
NO DISCUSSION OF ON THE I CLUB
ROLE. IT IS OUR VOTE ON VOTER
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF
DESIRE TO VOTE. THE CLERK WELL
CLOSER ALL TIE VOTE I SIXTY
THREE NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES. THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE
FORTY NINE A. B. THIRTY TO
FIFTY FOUR BY THIS LONG CLERK
WILL READ. SOME PEOPLE THIRTY
TO FIFTY FOUR BY SOME REMEMBER
THE MOMENT ACCOLADE IN THE
CONTRACTS. THIS THE MALL. THANK
YOU MISTER EIGHT THIRTY FOR
WOULD ENSURE THAT NOT ENGLISH
CO SIGNERS THE SAME PROTECTIONS
AS NON ENGLISH SPEAKING PRIMARY
SIGNER AB THIRTY TO FIFTY FOUR
HAS NOT POSITION AND PASTEL
UNANIMOUSLY THROUGH THE
COMMITTEE WITH BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. SEEING NO MEMBERS
SEEKING RECOGNITION. CLARK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS OF.
DESERVE VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
AT ABOVE. ALL THE CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY
FOUR NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES. WE'RE GOING TO PASS
RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS ONE FIFTY
AND ONE FIFTY ONE. THAT BRINGS
US TO FILE ITEM ONE FIFTY TWO
AB TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT
CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GLORIA AN ACT RELATING
TO THE PUBLIC UTILITIES MISTER
WHAT. THANK MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
EIGHTY EIGHT WILL FURTHER
PROTECT THE ENERGY AND GAS
CONSUMPTION OF DATA OF
CALIFORNIANS WHO NOW MORE THAN
EVER DESERVE TO FEEL SAFE AT
HOME WHEN USING A SENSE ENERGY
SERVICES PROVIDED BY CALIFORNIA
UTILITIES. THIS BILL WILL
REQUIRE UTILITIES- INSIDE THIS
BILL WILL REQUIRE IMMIGRATION
AND CUSTOMS ENFORCEMENT TO
OBTAIN A COURT ORDER SUBPOENA.
OR JUDICIAL WARRANT AS A PART
OF THEIR DATA REQUEST TO
UTILITIES. INVESTIGATIONS BY
THE AMERICAN CIVIL LIBERTIES
UNION FOUND THAT ICE THE
ADMINISTRATIVE SUBPOENAS I
SUCCESSFULLY. IN A SCENE OF
FOURTH WRECKED ITSELF. THIS
DATA AND THE REQUESTED THE
MINUTE FULFILL WITH ANY IT
REVIEW. AB TWENTY SEVEN SIMPLY
WE ARE AS A- THESE DATA REQUIRE
AND THE TOP WHETHER IT RELATES.
TO IMMIGRATION AND. ALL MEMBERS.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OF OUR DESIRE VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS ARE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICD FOR
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
PASS A RETAINER FILE ITEM ONE
FIFTY THREE THIS IS NOW FILE
ITEM ONE FIFTY FOUR AB NINETEEN
FORTY FIVE CORPORATE ASSUME AGO
NINETEEN FORTY FIVE BY SOME
REMEMBER SALAS AND OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE TO EMERGENCY SERVICES
MR SALAS YOU MAY OPEN. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I
PRESENT I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN FORTY
FIVE THIS BILL RECOGNIZE A
BRAVE PUBLIC SAFETY DISPATCHER
FOR THE LIFESAVING THE BURKE
FROM EVERY SNGLE DAY. BY
RECLASSIFYING THEM AS FIRST
RESPONDERS CURRENTLY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT MISS COUGH
FIVE MISCLASSIFIED OUR
DISPATCHERS OF THE STRAIT OF IN
CLERICAL RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE. THANK YOU MISTER SALAS
SENIOR DISCUSSION DEBATE. OR
CALL THE ROLL. ALL MEMBERS. IT
IS THERE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. THE CLERK
WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT I
SIXTY FIVE. NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEMS ONE
FIFTY FIVE AND ONE FIFTY SIX
PASS RETAIN. FILE ITEM ONE
FIFTY SEVEN AB TWO THOUSAND
FOUR FOR FREE ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
THOUSAND FOUR BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CALDERON ANOTHER'S AN
ACT RELATING TO PRIVACY MISTER
CALDERON. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB TWENTY
THOUSAND FOUR WOULD AUTHORIZE
THE USE A VERIFIABLE HEALTH
CREDENTIALS FOR THE PURPOSE OF
VERIFYING THE RESULTS OF THE
CODE NINETEEN TESTS IN WOULD
PROVIDE A PATH TO THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS
TECHNOLOGY. VERIFIABLE HEALTH
CREDENTIALS ARE PORTABLE
ELECTRONIC HEALTH RECORDS THAT
CAN BE VERIFIED CRYPTO
GRAPHICALLY THUS PROTECTING THE
PRIVACY OF THE INDIVIDUAL LIGHT
WHILE OFFERING A TRUSTED WAY TO
CONFIRM THE RESULTS OF A COVER
NINETEEN TEST AS HE RECOVER
FROM THE RESULT TO COVER
NINETEEN IN CALIFORNIA. WE NEED
ALL AVAILABLE TOOLS AT OUR
DISPOSAL VERIFIABLE HEALTH
CREDENTIALS PROVIDE AN OPTION
FOR INDIVIDUALS TO RECEIVE
THEIR TEST RESULTS IN A SECURE
AND PRIVATE WAY TO BE CLEAR
THIS BILL DOES NOT N ANY WAY
REQUIRE. OF THESE CREDENTIALS
IT AUTHORIZES THEM AS AN OPTION
AND WILL GUIDE THEIR
IMPLEMENTATION TO A PILOT
PROGRAM THAT ALLOWS FOR
FLEXIBILITY IN DETERMINING THE
BEST PRACTICES AND GUIDELINES
FOR USING. RESPECT WITH
FERNANDO. THANK YOU MISTER. THE
ROLE. IS THERE A VITAL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A- ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE.
WORK WELL CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE AYES FIFTY
NINE. KNOWS ONE. THAT MEASURE
PASSES THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE
FIFTY EIGHT. AB TWENTY FIFTEEN
BY DOCTOR EGGMAN THE CORPORATE
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIFTEEN BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN AN ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC SOCIAL
SERVICES. DOCTOR EGGMAN. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TODAY
TO PRESENT AB TWENTY FIFTEEN
THAT IS A NARROWLY FOCUSED BILL
THAT HOPEFULLY WILL IMPROVE OUR
MENTAL HEALTH SYSTEM. HAVING TO
DO WITH THE WHOLE BETWEEN THE
SEVENTY TWO HOUR HOLD AND THE
TWO WE CALLED TO ALSO ADD INTO
THAT CRITERIA THE ABILITY TO
CARE FOR ONE'S MEDICAL
CONDITION BEFORE YOUR RELEASED.
WE THINK THIS WILL BE A
SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENT AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU DOCTOR EGGMAN.
SAY NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CARPOOL OF THE ROLE.
MEMBERS OF. RESERVE A VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. YEAH. THE CLERK WILL.
CULTURAL TIED ABOUT AYE SIXTY
EIGHT NO ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS WE'RE FILE ITEM
ONE FIFTY NINE AB TWENTY THIRTY
SEVEN CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY THIRTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WORKS AND OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE HEALTH FACILITIES THIS
WICKS YOU MAY OPEN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER CURRENTLY
CALIFORNIA HOSPITALS PLAN AND
CLOSING OR DOWNGRADING SERVICES
ARE ONLY REQUIRED TO GIVE
NINETY DAYS NOTICE PRIOR TO
CLOSER. THREE MONTHS IS NOT
ENOUGH TIME FOR COMMUNITIES TO
VOICE THEIR CONCERNS TO THE
LOCAL BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
FINAL TERMS OF LOCATIONS FOR
CRITICAL HEALTH CARE AND MAKE
PLANS TO ACCOMMODATE THEIR
HEALTHCARE NEEDS. WITH THE
CURRENCY OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
COMBINED WITH THE ONGOING
DEVASTATION COVERED NINETEEN
COMMUNITIES NEED MORE TIME TO
ADVOCATE FOR THEMSELVES. IN MY
DISTRICT I'VE SEEN THIS
FIRSTHAND WITH MULTIPLE
HOSPITAL'S CLOSURE CLOSING OR
THREADED THREADING TO BE
CLOSED. LOSS OF ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE AND THE CLOSURES OF
A HALL HELLO OF THE HOSPITAL.
PO SIGNIFICANT HEALTH CARE IS
FOR LOW INCOME. FAMILIES THE
ELDERLY- AND OTHER FOLKS THERE
SUBJECT THE PANDEMIC. THE
COMMITTEE SHOULD NOT BE ABLE
ABLE THE COMMITTEE SHOULD BE
ABLE TO VOICE THEIR CONCERNS.
AND ADVOCATE FOR THEMSELVES
THROUGH THEIR ELECTED
OFFICIALS. BEGIN THEIR SEARCH
FOR ALTERNATIVE CARE AND FOR
HOSPITAL STAFF AND PERSONAL TO
FIND ADDITIONAL EMPLOYMENT.
CURRENT LAW OF NINETY DAYS OR
THREE MONTHS OF NOTIFICATIONS
NOT NEARLY ENOUGH TIME TO FIND
THESE OPTIONS. AB TWENTY THIRTY
SEVEN EXTENSIVE PUBLIC
NOTIFICATION PERIOD PROSPROUS
AND HEALTH FACILITIES THE
PLANET OPERATE SERVICES CHANGE
THEIR SERVICES OR CLOSE A
FACILITY TO HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS
OR SIX MONTHS. COMMUNITIES NEED
MORE NOTICE AND TIME WHEN
HOSPITAL CLOSURES. EGGS HAPPEN
AND NEED ACCESS TO THE CENTRAL
CARE I BELIEVE AB. TWENTY
THIRTY SEVEN WILL GIVE
COMMUNITIES IS THE PRECIOUS
TIME THAT THEY NEED.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MS WORKS SEEN
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
THE DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. CLICK WELL.
CLOSER ROLLTIDE ABOUT ICE FORTY
FOUR KNOWS FOURTEEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES WE'RE GOING TO
PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM
ONE. SIXTY. THAT BRINGS US TO.
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY ONE. THIS
RODRIGUEZ IF YOU COULD COME TO
THE PODIUM IN THE WELL. SO WE
MAY ALL SEE YOU ON YOUR
PRESENTATION. THANK YOU SIR
THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY ONE
AB TWENTY NINETY TWO. CORPORATE
SOME REAL TWENTY NINETY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER RODRIGUEZ AND
ACCOLADES FOR EMERGENCY
AMBULANCE EMPLOYEES MISTER
RODRIGUEZ. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS ARISE PRESENT
AB TWENTY NINETY TWO. CURRENTLY
IN CALIFORNIA 80% OF ALL EMTS
AND PARAMEDICS ARE EMPLOYED BY
THE PRIVATE SECTOR ALL OF WHOM
WORK IN THE FIELD WITH HIGH
RATES OF MORTALITY INJURY AND
TRAUMA. UNFORTUNATELY TOO MANY
OF THESE FIRST RESPONDERS
FREQUENTLY EXPERIENCE VIOLENCE
AND ASSAULT OR RESPONDING TO
EMERGENCY CALLS. OFTEN BY THE
VERY PEOPLE THEY'RE TRYING TO
HELP. SPEAKING FROM MY PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE AS A CAREER EMT I
WANT TO HEAR FROM MY COLLEAGUES
IN THE FIELD. PRIVATE SECTOR
EMPLOYERS WORKERS NEED BETTER
WORKING CONDITIONS. PART OF
THAT IS HAVE AN ADEQUATE
IMPROPER PROTECTIVE GEAR
AVAILABLE. AB TWENTY NINETY TWO
IS A STEP IN THAT DIRECTION AND
REQUIRE EMPLOYERS EMPLOYERS TO
INFORM. THEIR EMPLOYEES ABOUT
THE RIGHT TO REQUEST SAFETY
DEVICES AND PROTECTIVE GEAR.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN ASSURING
SAFER CONDITION FOR WORKFORCE
THAT HAS BEEN NEGLECTED AND
OVERLOOKED FOR FAR TOO LONG-
STRUCK WE OFFER ARE GOING.
THANK YOU MISS RODRIGUEZ SEEING
NO DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL
CLOSE ROLE. TALLY THE VOTE. AS
FIFTY TWO KNOWS THIRTEEN THAT
MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WERE OF
ONE OF GO BACK IN THE FILE. TO
ALLOW MISTER CALDERON TO TAKE
UP FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY. SEVEN
THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE TWENTY
SEVEN AB TWENTY NINE FIFTY NINE
THE CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY NINE FIFTY NINE BY
SIMPLY RIVER CALDERON ACCOLADE
A SOLID WASTE MISTER CALDERON
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER IN THE
LAST TEN YEARS CALIFORNIA'S
ADOPTED SEVERAL NEW RECYCLING
LAWS TO INCREASE THE RECOVERY
OF MATERIALS IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
LEGISLATIVE PASSED ME TO SIGN
YOU THIRTY THIRTY SIX. THIRTY
THIRTY SIX ENABLE AMHERST
REDUCE PROVIDE LIKE TO TRANSFER
THESE MATERIALS DIRECTLY TO THE
OTHER TO OTHER FARMERS TO BE
USED AS ANIMAL WITHOUT
UTILIZING THE HAULING SERVICES
OF SOLID WASTE FRANCHISE THESE
PROVISIONS CAN ONLY BE UTILIZED
UNDER NARROWLY PRESCRIBED
CONDITIONS UNFORTUNATELY OVER
THE PAST TWO YEARS THE PHRASE
INDUSTRIAL SOURCES WITHIN AB
THIRTY THIRTY SIX HAS BEEN
MISINTERPRETED AN INCORRECT
LOSE. RESTAURANTS AND GROW
STORES THE REGIONAL INTENT OF
AB THIRTY THIRTY SIX WAS ONLY
MEANT TO APPLY TO CERTAIN BY
PRODUCTS FROM AGRICULTURAL
SOURCES. THAT HAVE HISTORICALLY
NOT ENTERED THE WAY STREET. THE
BASIC PURPOSE OF THIS BILL AND
AB THIRTY THIRTY SIX OR TO
ENABLE FARM TO FARM TRANSFERS
OF AGRICULTURAL BY PRODUCTS
FROM A GROWER. TO ANOTHER
FARMER FOR USE AS ANIMAL FEED
AB TWENTY NINE FIFTY NINE
CLARIFIES THE PROVISIONS WITHIN
AB THIRTY THIRTY SIX AND OFFERS
A LEGISLATIVE FIX FOR WHICH
INDUSTRIAL GENERATORS OF FOOD
SCRAPS. MAY SEND THEIR FOOD BY
PRODUCTS TO SERVE AS ANIMAL
FEED I'VE BEEN WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH THE FARM BUREAU
AND OTHER OPPOSITIONS. BELIEVE
WE CAN ADDRESS THE CONCERNS
ABOUT CONSIDERING WINERIES AND
BEER BREWERS. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE IT'S
IMPORTANT MEASURE. THANK YOU
MISTER MISTER PATTON. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. YES MISTER SPEAKER
IN AND MEMBERS THANK YOU. THIS
IS NOT A CLEAN UP BILL. THIS IS
A DIRTY UP BILL. AB TWENTY NINE
FIFTY NINE WILL DISALLOW
RENDERERS FROM HANDLING MUCH OF
THE STATE'S ORGANIC WASTE
RESULTING IN MORE ORGANIC WASTE
ENDING UP IN LANDFILLS. I
THOUGHT WE WERE TRYING TO
REDUCE ORGANIC LANDFILLS
CURRENTLY AGRICULTURE AND OTHER
ORGANIC WASTE IS EFFECTIVELY
TURNED INTO NUTRITIONAL
AFFORDABLE FEEDSTOCK FOR
LIVESTOCK. THIS BILL WOULD
RESTRICT WHICH FACILITIES COULD
DIVERT BY PRODUCTS FOR THE USE
OF ANIMAL FEED AND
SIGNIFICANTLY DISRUPT THE
CURRENT MARKET. INHIBITING
FEEDSTOCK OPTIONS CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE TO CALIFORNIA'S
RANCHES AND DAIRIES. THIS BILL
COULD VERY WELL PUT RENDERS IN
CALIFORNIA OUT OF BUSINESS
WHICH WOULD CREATE AN EMERGENCY
SITUATION FOR RANCHERS DERRY'S
ANOTHER ANIMAL PRODUCERS. MANY
AG GROUPS SPONSORED AND
SUPPORTED LEGISLATION IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN AB THREE ZERO THREE
SIX. TO DEFINE ALLOWABLE BY
PRODUCTS THAT CAN BE TURNED
INTO ANIMAL FEED. THIS BILL ON
DOES MUCH OF THAT LEGISLATION
AND CAUSES ON NECESSARY
CONFUSION. THIS BILL WILL TAKE
AWAY THE AVAILABILITY OF
DOMESTICALLY SOURCED ORGANIC
ANIMAL FEED WITHOUT THIS LOCAL
SOURCE FEED COSTS WILL RISE
WHICH MEANS THE COST OF MEAT
AND DAIRY PRODUCTS WILL RISE AS
WELL. MEMBERS THIS IS NOT A
CLEAN UP BILL THIS IS A DIRTY
UP BILL AND I ASK FOR YOUR
RESPECTFULLY FOR YOUR NO VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER PATTERSON
MISTER COOLEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. COLLEAGUES I AM
PLEASED TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY NINE FIFTY NINE I WAS
YOU AUTHOR OF AB THIRTY THIRTY
SIX OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN. THAT
BILL WAS ENACTED TO PROTECT A
LIMITED WAY STREAM OF
AGRICULTURAL SOURCES. THAT
INCLUDE WINERY FRUIT AND
VEGETABLE GROWERS DOT FORMER
SELECT INDUSTRIAL SOURCES TO
LIVESTOCK FARMS. THOUGH SOME
INDUSTRIAL SOURCES WERE
ENVISIONED FOR THE STREAM
RESTAURANTS AND GROCERY STORES
WERE NOT. MISTER CALDERON HIS
STAFF HAVE WORKED VERY HARD
THIS YEAR MAINTAINING CLOSE
CONTACT WITH ME ON THIS ISSUE.
AND I AM STRONGLY OF THE VIEW
THAT THIS BILL IS A TERROR FOR
CATION THAT ALIGNS WITH THE
PURPOSES OF MY AB THIRTY THIRTY
SIX. AND. TO CONCLUDE I WOULD
JUST OFFER A COMMENT IN
RESPONSE TO MY COLLEAGUE FROM
FRESNO. HERE IN SACRAMENTO
COUNTY. THE PRINCIPAL RENDERING
PLANT AND THE PRINCIPAL SOLID
WASTE FACILITY. ARE ABOUT FOUR
MILES APART ON KEY FOR
BOULEVARD. IN THE COUNTY OF
SACRAMENTO AND RANCHO CORDOVA.
SO I AM VERY FAMILIAR WITH WHAT
GOES IN THAT RENDERING PLANT
WHICH SITS ON THE WESTERN
BORDER OF MY CITY RANCHO
CORDOVA. A MILE FROM
NEIGHBORHOODS WHERE WE ARE
GROWING NEW NEW NEIGHBORHOODS.
AND I'M WELL ACQUAINTED WHAT
GOES AND THAT'S ALWAYS PLAN I
DO NOT BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL.
MATERIALLY ALTER WHAT ENDS UP
AT THE RENDERING PLANT. THE
SERVICE SECTOR ACCOUNTING AND
SHIFTED TO THAT LANDFILLS. I
BELIEVE THIS IS A GOOD BILL.
AND I HAVE. AS I SAY
FAMILIARITY WITH THE RENDERING
SIDE AND THE SOLID WASTE SITE I
SUPPORT THIS BILL OUR REGION I
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER COOLEY
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION MISTER. CALDERON
YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU AND I
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
RENTS CORDOVA FIRST- YOU KNOW
TALKING WITH LITTLE BIT ABOUT
HIS BILL NAY ORIGINAL INTENT OF
THE BILL HOW THIS BILL IS MEANT
TO CLARIFY AGAIN WE ARE PUTTING
A LOT OF TIME AND EFFORT
WORKING WITH A FARM BILL BURR
OAK AND WE ARE VERY CONFIDENT
THAT WE WILL BE PUTTING. THEIR
OPPOSITION ONCE WE GET TO THE
SENATE THAT A RESPECTFULLY ASK
RUN I'VE OF. CALDERON AYE WITH
THAT COUPLE OF THE ROLE. IS
THAT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE
DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS ARE TO VOTE. MISTER
CALDERON MOVES CALL.
THERE WAS
BACK IN FILE ORDER. WE'RE GOING
TO PASS. PARMI WE'RE FILE ITEM
ONE SIXTY TWO. IN FOLLOW ORDER
THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY TWO
AB TWENTY ONE NINETY SIX
CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
ONE NINETY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALEZ AND
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE TO FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS. MS GONZALEZ EMAIL
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE NINETY
SIX EXTEND THE SUNSET OF THE
PILOT PROGRAM OR INCREASED
ACCESS TO RESPONSIBLE SMALL
DOLLAR LOANS TO JANUARY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT. THE PILOT
PROGRAM IS SAID TO CURRENTLY
SUNSET AT THE END OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO IN THE PILOT PROGRAM
HIS DEMONSTRATE CAN PRODUCE A
GOOD SAFETY ALONE. EXCEPT THAT
WILL PROVIDE THE DB O. WITH THE
ADDITIONAL TIME TO COLLECT DATA
TO MAKE PROPER RECOMMENDATIONS
ON WHETHER TO MAKE THE PROGRAM
PERMANENT. IT SO FAR THIS BILLS
RECEIVE UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NINE. THANK YOU MISS GONZALEZ
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CORPORAL MEMBERS. WHAT IS THAT
ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE DESIRE
TO VOTE. CLICK WELL. CLOSER ALL.
HELLO I SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS
THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY
THREE AB TWENTY ONE NINETY NINE
CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
ONE NINETY NINE BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DESIRING AN ACCOLADE
CLINICAL LABORATORIES. MISTER
NAZARIAN YOU MAY OPEN. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
TODAY AND PRESENTING AB TWENTY
ONE NINETY NINE WHICH WILL
EXTEND THE SUNSET ON A PILOT
PROGRAM WHICH WILL ALLOW CD PH
TO ASSESS SAFETY DATE A DATA
RELATED TO EXEMPTION. THE GOAL
OF THE PROGRAM WAS TO CREATE A
PILOT PROGRAM TO DEMONSTRATE
THAT PROPERLY TRAINED AND%
SUPERVISED INDIVIDUALS CAN
PERFORM A TOTAL PROTEIN TEST
USING A DIGITAL REFER REFRACTOR
METER. AT PLASMA DONATION
CENTERS CALIFORNIA LAGS BEHIND
OTHER LARGE STATES IN SITUATING
PLASMA CENTERS IT IS OUR
INTENTION TO INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF PLASMA DONATION
CENTERS IN CALIFORNIA TO HELP
MEET THE INCREASED. GLOBAL
DEMAND FOR PLASMA- THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH BEGIN
RECEIVING DATA OF IN AUGUST OF
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN HOWEVER
SINCE THE COVERT CRISIS BEGAN.
DPH HAS NOT BEEN ABLE TO REVIEW
THE DATA. THEY HAVE RECEIVED
THEREFORE WE ARE AMENDING THE
BILL TO MERELY EXTEND THE
SUNSET OF THE SUCCESSFUL
PROGRAM AND CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH ALL THE STAKEHOLDERS UNTIL
A FUTURE TIME WHEN WE TAKE OUT.
OF THE EXEMPTION ENTIRELY AND
FOR THAT I ALSO WANT TO TAKE AN
OPPORTUNITY AND THANK THE CHAIR
OF A BUSINESS AND PROFESSIONS
AND HIS- WONDERFUL STAFF FOR
HELPING WORK WITH THIS BILL. WE
ASK FOR NAY VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER ZERO. SEE NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
QUIRK OF THE ROLE. THESE ARE TO
VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE. THE CLERK WELL CLOSE
THE ROLE AND TELL YOU ABOUT AYE
SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE GOING TO
PASS TEMPORARILY. ON FILE ITEM
ONE SIXTY FOUR. THE BRING THIS
FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY FIVE AB
TWENTY TWO FORTY SEVEN. BY MS
BURKE CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY TWO FORTY SEVEN BY SOME
MEMBER BURKE AN ACCOLADE TO
TAXATION. MS BURKE THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT AB TWENTY TWO
FORTY SEVEN AS SIMPLE AND
TAXPAYER FROM THE PROPOSAL
SPONSORED BY THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD. THE FTP RECENTLY LEARNED
THAT THE I. R. S. HAS STOPPED
ISSUING OR RENEWING INDIVIDUAL
TAXPAYER IDENTIFICATION NUMBER
ITIN FOR NON RESIDENTIAL
DEPENDENTS LIVING IN CANADA OR
MEXICO. THIS IS PREVENTED
CERTAIN CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS
FROM CLAIMING THE EXISTING
DEPENDENT EXEMPTION CREDIT FOR
THEIR OTHERWISE QUALIFYING NON
RESIDENT DEPENDENCE THIS IS
BECAUSE THE CURRENT STATE LAW
REQUIRES A TAX RETURN TO
INCLUDE EITHER A SOCIAL
SECURITY NUMBER ON I TEN FOR
EACH DEPENDENT FOR THE CREDIT
TO BE ALLOWED. AB TWENTY FOUR
SEVEN WHICH IS SPONSORED BY THE
F. T. VIEW IT'S VERY SIMPLY
GIVE THE TAXPAYERS THE OPTION
OF PROVIDING ALTERNATIVE
JENNIFER IN INFORMATION FOR THE
PURPOSES OF CLAIMING THE
DEPENDENT EXEMPTION CREDIT. BUT
THAT I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN
IBM. THANK YOU MISTER. SEE NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM. CARPOOL OPEN. IS THERE A
VOTE ALL MEMBERS PHONES ARE TO
GO. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLL
TIDE OF A I SHOULD BE FIVE
KNOWS TEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
PASS RETAIN ON FILE ITEMS ONE
SIXTY SIX AND ONE SIXTY SEVEN.
THIS BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM ONE
SIXTY EIGHT AB. TWENTY THREE
THIRTY THREE. KERKORIAN
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
THIRTY THREE BY SOME REMEMBER
QUIRK ACCOLADE A HAZARDOUS
SUBSTANCES MS BAUER QUE HANNAH
BEHALF OF DOCTOR QUIRK YOU
ALREADY THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I'M
PRESENTING AB TWENTY THREE
THIRTY THREE ON BEHALF OF
DOCTOR QUIRK. AB TWENTY THREE
THIRTY THREE ADDRESSES THE
VOLUNTARY CLEANUP PROGRAM WHICH
LOCAL HEALTH OFFICERS OVERSEE
THE REMEDIATION AND HAZARDOUS
WASTE SITES THE BILL WILL HELP
ENSURE THE LOCAL HEALTH
OFFICERS WHO OVERSEE THE
CLEANUP OF THE SITES HAVE THE
NECESSARY EXPERTISE KNOWLEDGE
AND RESOURCES TO CARRY OUT
REMEDIATION RESPONSIBILITIES IN
A MANNER THAT IS PROTECTIVE OF
PUBLIC HEALTH AND THE
ENVIRONMENT. AB TWENTY THREE
THIRTY PRIESTS HAD- OPPOSITION
HAS HAD BIPARTISAN SUPPORT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU IS BARRICADE HERE
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. THESE ARE TO VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTE THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF. ZERO CLERK WILL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FIFTY
NINE KNOWS FIVE THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
THERE IS WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE BACK TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM
ONE SIXTY FOUR. THIS IS FILE
ITEM ONE SIX FOUR AB TWENTY TO
THIRTY ONE BY MISTER KALRA THAT
CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
TO THIRTY ONE BY SOME REMEMBER
KALRA ACCOLADE IN THE PUBLIC
WORKS SHE KALRA. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER A PRODUCT IS AN
AB TWENTY TO THIRTY ONE. WAS TO
FIND ONE A PUBLIC SUBSIDY IS TO
MINIMIZE FOR THE PURPOSE OF
DETERMINING THE PREVAILING WAGE
APPLIES PRIOR PROJECT USING
PUBLIC FUNDS. THIS BILL
PROVIDES THE PUBLIC SUBSIDY ON
A PRIVATE PROJECT IS DIMINISHED
AS LONG AS IT IS LESS THAN FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS AND-
LESS THAN 2% OF THE TOTAL
PROJECT COST. AB TWENTY TWO TO
THIRTY ONE EXEMPTS THE
CONSTRUCTION OF SINGLE FAMILY
DWELLINGS FROM THE FIVE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLAR CAP. UNDER
CURRENT LAW PROJECT IS NOT
SUBJECT THE PREVAILING WAGE LAW
EVEN IF IT RECEIVES A PUBLIC
SUBSIDY. THAT THAT SUBSIDIES TO
MINIMUS IN THE CONTEXT OF THE
PROJECT. SINCE THE TURN TO
MINIMIZES NOT DEFINED IN
STATUTE. THERE IS NO GUIDANCE
AS TO THE APPROPRIATE LEVEL
PUBLIC SUBSIDY THAT SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED A MINIMUS. THIS IS
LED TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS TO MAKE
INCONSISTENT RULINGS AS TO WHAT
IS DE MINIMUS LEADING TO
CONFUSION A LITIGATION. A
PUBLIC SUBSIDY FOR PRIOR
PROJECT THAT IS MORE THAN A
HALF MILLION DOLLARS OR 2% OF
THE TOTAL PROJECT COST. IS A
NOTABLE TAXPAYERS INVESTMENT
AND IT'S REASON WATER
ACCOMMODATING WAGES THE ROBBER
WANTS A PUBLIC SUBSIDY OVER
THAT AMOUNT. AS OUR STATE AND
HAS A SIGNIFICANT ECONOMIC
RECESSION WE MUST BE
RESPONSIBLE WITHOUT TAXPAYER
DOLLARS ARE SPENT. IN ADDITION
TO THE CARPET A NINETEEN
PANDEMIC BUT HAS PUT GREAT
FINANCIAL STRAIN OUR WORKFORCE.
MANY WORKERS HAVE BEEN LAID
OFF. AND HAD HAD THEIR HOURS
REDUCED OR OF TAKEN ON PAID
LEAVE TO CARE FOR THEIR FAMILY
IT IS MORE CRITICAL THAN EVER.
BUT OUR WORKERS IN THE TRADES
EARNED DECENT WAGES AND WRIST
WE RECEIVE QUALITY TRAINING. ON
THESE PROJECTS AB TWENTY TO
THIRTY ONE WILL CLEARLY DEFINED
ONE OF PUBLIC SUBSIDIES THE
MINISTERS OF A THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
NAME IS KALRA. SEEING NO
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION ON
THE ITEM. OR CALL THE ROLL. IS
THAT A VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE FOR QUILL. CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FORTY SEVEN
KNOWS THIRTEEN THAT MEASURE
PASSES.
MEMBERS BACK IN FOLLOW
ORDER WE'RE FILE ITEM ONE SIXTY
NINE. AB TWENTY FIVE SEVENTEEN
FOR THE PURPOSE OF AMENDMENTS
QUIRK OR READ WITH AMENDMENTS
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTEEN WITH A MINUTES BY
SOME REMEMBER GLORIA. MR GLORIA
ON THE AMENDMENTS BAKER SPEAKER
THE AMENDMENTS TO ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FIVE SEVENTEEN ENSURE
THAT THE PRIORITY OF A LEAN
REMAINS INTACT THESE AMENDMENTS
OF A MOVE. ALSO MOVED THE
OPPOSITION TO A NEUTRAL
POSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR ITEM. THANK YOU MISS
GLORIA WITHOUT OBJECTION WE MAY
TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. AYE OPPOSED SAY NAY.
YES HAVE ANY MEMBERS ARE
ADOPTED BILLS OUT TO PRINT TO
BACK ON FILE. THIS IS FILE ITEM
ONE SEVENTY AB TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTY SIX FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS CARPOOL READ WITH
AMENDMENTS ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FIVE SEVENTY SIX WITH A MINUTES
BY SOME REMEMBER GLORIA. MISTER
GLORIA THE AMENDMENTS THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. THEM PURPOSES
OF I RISE TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
FIVE SEVENTY SIX FOR THE
PURPOSES OF AMENDMENT. THESE
AMENDMENTS WILL BE CIVIL
SUBJECT REVERTED MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES ACT FUNDS TO LOCAL
COMMUNITY PLANNING PROCESS
SEES. A LOT STILL REQUIRING
THESE FUNDS BE USED. TO
CONSIDER TO BE USED FOR PROVIDE
SERVICES FOR THOSE CURRENTLY
EXPERIENCING HOMELESSNESS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE THE-
THANK YOU MISS GLORIA WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THESE AMENDMENTS ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE. AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE AYES HAVE
IT MEMBERS ARE DOTTED BILLS UP
TO PRINT. AND BACK ON FILE FILE
A ONE SEVENTY ONE THROUGH ONE
SEVENTY FOUR. PASS RETAIN THIS
IS FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY FIVE
EIGHT AB TWENTY NINE TWENTY SIX
BY MISTER CALDERON BROKERAGE
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE
TWENTY SIX BY SOME REMEMBER
CALDERON ACCOLADE REFERRAL
AGENCIES THIS CALL THE ROLL.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS REFERRAL SOURCES OR
ENTITIES THAT ASSIST FAMILIES
LOOKING FOR PEOPLE LOOKING TO
PLACE A SENIOR LOVED ONE AN
ASSISTED LIVING FACILITY.
CURRENT LAW LACKS SUFFICIENT
REGULATIONS ON REFERRAL SOURCES
AND REQUIRES MINIMAL
DISCLOSURES TO BE PROVIDED TO
THE SENIOR AND THEIR FAMILY
THIS BILL SEEKS TO CODIFY
GENERAL COMMONSENSE REGULATIONS
FOR ALL REFERRALS SOURCES AND
BECAUSE REFERRALS TO ASSISTED
LIVING FACILITIES MAY BE MADE
BY ANTI SUCH AS A- COUNTIES
MENTAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT OR
HOSPITAL THIS CHARGER.
DISCHARGE PLANNER THIS BILL
ADDS A SECOND BUT FAIR LAYER OF
REGULATIONS ON FINANCIALLY
COMPENSATED REFERRAL SORT REAP
THE REFERRAL SOURCES NOTABLY
THIS BILL REQUIRES A SET OF
DISCLOSURES BE GIVEN TO SEEN AS
BEFORE OR SIMULTANEOUS WITH
EIGHT COMPENSATE REFERRAL THERE
HAVE BEEN MULTIPLE BILLS OVER
THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS TO
SEEKING. TO REGULATE REFERRAL
SOURCES HAVING EITHER BEEN VOTE
VETOED OR HELD IN
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE THIS
BILL IS THE FIRST TO HAVE BEEN
CRAFTED COLLECTIVELY BY
INDUSTRY LEADERS AND CONSUMER
ADVOCATES AND RESULTS- TO VERY
MINIMAL COST TO THE STATE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK BROUGH THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISTER CADERON.
SEEING NO MEMBER SECURE
RECOGNITION ON THE BILL. OUR
CLUB THE ROLE MEMBERS. RESERVE
ON ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. QUIRK WELL
CLOSE ROLE TITLE BUT I SIXTY
FIVE NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES. IS FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY SIX AB. TWENTY NINE
FIFTY FOUR. CORKERY ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY NINE FIFTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ROBERT RIVAS
ANOTHER SNACK LATER GREENHOUSE
GASES MYSTERY THIS THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I AM- PLEASED TO
BE HERE TODAY TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL TWO NINE FIVE FOR
A SIMPLE STRAIGHTFORWARD BUT AN
IMPORTANT BILL. SO THIS
LEGISLATION WOULD REQUIRE THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
TO WORK IN COLLABORATION WITH
OTHER RELEVANT STATE AGENCIES
HERE CALIFORNIA AND SOME
DEPARTMENTS. TO IDENTIFY IN
OVERALL CLIMATE GOAL FOR
CALIFORNIA'S NATURAL AND
WORKING LANDS. ACCORDING TO THE
BILL LANGUAGE THIS OVERALL
CLIMATE GOAL WILL IDENTIFY
ACTIONS TO SUPPORT FOR CARBON
REDUCE ATMOSPHERIC GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS IDENTIFY
PRACTICES POLICY INCENTIVES AND
POTENTIAL REDUCTIONS IN
BARRIERS THAT WOULD HELP
ACHIEVE THIS CLIMATE GOAL FOR
CALIFORNIA NATURAL WORKING
LANDS. AS WE ALL KNOW HERE
CALIFORNIA THE LANDMARK
ENVIRONMENTAL LOSS IN THE BILL-
THREE TO ESTABLISH A
COMPREHENSIVE PROGRAM TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS FROM
ALL FROM ALL SOURCES IN OUR
STATE. UNDER THE STATE LAW THE
CALIFORNIA RESOURCES BOARD IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR DEVELOPING A
SCOPING PLAN THAT IS UPDATED
EVERY FIVE YEARS. IT'S A PLAN
THAT. IT DESCRIBES THE APPROACH
OUR STATE WILL TAKE TO REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GASES. AND IN
PREPARATION FOR THE NEXT COPING
PLAN IN TWENTY THOUSAND IN TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY TWO. THIS BILL
IS CONSISTENT WITH THE INTENT
OF THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD TO ESTABLISH AN OVERALL
CLIMB AGO FOR THE STATE'S
NATURAL AND WORKING LANCE. THIS
EFFORT WILL ENSURE THIS THIS
NEXT PLAN UPDATE FULLY THAT IT
CONSIDERS AND LEVERAGES THE
HUGE POWER OF OUR STATE'S
NATURAL WORKING LANDS IN
ACHIEVING. CALIFORNIA'S
AMBITIOUS GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSION GOALS SO WHY NOT
ESTABLISH AN OVERALL NATURAL
AND WORKING LANDS CLIMB GOAL
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WHY NOT. THE
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN SCOPING
PLAN INCLUDES SECTIONS ON
CALIFORNIA'S NATURAL WORKING
LANDS AND AGRICULTURE. THE
RESULT WAS THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA FORCE CLIMATE
PLAN. TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
SCOPING PLAN FURTHER EMPHASIZE
THE IMPORTANCE OF CALIFORNIA'S
NATURAL WORKING LANDS
SPECIFICALLY STATING THAT
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE OBJECTIVE
FOR NATURAL AND WORKING LANDS
IS TO MAINTAIN THEM AS A CARBON
SINK. THE PLAN ALSO DIRECTED
THE STATE TO QUANTIFY CARBON
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE INTERVENTION
ACTIVITIES ON CALIFORNIA'S
NATURAL AND WORKING LANCE. AS A
STATE MAKE NO MISTAKE AS A
STATE WE MUST REMAIN STEADFAST
IN OUR COMMITMENT AND EFFORTS
TO REDUCE NEW EMISSIONS OF
CARBON. BUT WE ALSO NEED TO
ENSURE THAT WE'RE DEVELOPING
THE PATHWAYS. PATHWAYS TO
REMOVE CARBON FROM THE
ATMOSPHERE. LEADING RESEARCHERS
FROM THROUGHOUT THE WORLD AGREE
THAT IF WE'RE GOING TO FEND OFF
THE WORST IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE. WE MUST MAXIMIZE
METHODS TO SEQUESTER OR CAPTURE
CARBON. NATURAL WORKING LANDS
COMPRISE OVER 90% 90% OF
CALIFORNIA'S DIVERSE INCREDIBLE
LANDSCAPE. THIS INCLUDES
FORESTS RANGELANDS FARMS URBAN
GREEN SPACES WETLANDS AND OUR
SOILS. THESE LANDS HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO SEQUESTER
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNTS OF CARBON.
CLEARLY THERE'S NO SILVER
BULLET WHEN IT COMES TO
REMOVING CO TWO FROM THE
ATMOSPHERE THERE'S NO SINGLE
TECHNOLOGY OR METHOD THAT
EXISTS TO PROVIDE THAT ALL THE
CO TWO REMOVAL OTHERS REQUIRE.
BUT WHAT WE DO KNOW IS THAT ONE
THERE ARE NATURAL WAY TO
CAPTURE IT'S A QUESTION CARBON.
TWO THERE ARE WAYS TO CAPTURE
CARBON DATING INVOLVE COMPLEX
ENGINEERING. AND QUITE HONESTLY
WILL REQUIRE A TECHNOLOGICAL
BREAKTHROUGH. A BREAKTHROUGH
THAT WILL REQUIRE INVESTMENT IN
INFRASTRUCTURE. AND INVOLVED
NUMEROUS LOGISTICAL AND
REGULATORY HURDLES. ALL OF
WHICH IS POSSIBLE CAN BE
POSSIBLE ONE DAY WILL BE
POSSIBLE BUT IT'S GONNA TAKE
TIME AND MONEY. AND THE SECOND
POINT UNDERSCORES OUR NEED TO
FULLY LEVERAGE. THE POTENTIAL
OF OUR NATURAL WORKING LANDS IN
OUR CLIMATE CONVERSATION HERE
IN CALIFORNIA. NATURAL
SOLUTIONS FOR ACOSTA QUESTRADE
OR CAPTURING CARBON A
RELATIVELY INEXPENSIVE. CAN BE
IMPLEMENTED WITH LITTLE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND ARE
AVAILABLE TO US RIGHT NOW.
THESE NATURAL SOLUTIONS INCLUDE
LAND MANAGEMENT RESTORATION OF
WOODLANDS AND WETLANDS AND
OTHER PRACTICES THAT INCREASE
THE AMOUNT OF CARBON STORED
TREASON SOILS THIRTY SECOND IN
ADDITION TO AYE ENSURING THAT
WOULD PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
BENEFITS SUCH AS APPROVED WATER
AND AIR QUALITY FOOD PRODUCTION
LACK CONSERVATION. AND WILDFIRE
PREVENTION AGAIN PASSAGE OF
THIS BILL IS CONSISTENT WITH
THE INTENT OF CARP IN
ESTABLISHING AN OVERALL CLIMATE
CHANGE GOAL FOR THE CALIFORNIA
NATIONAL WORKING LANDS IN THIS
WAY THE BILL WILL ENSURE THAT.
NATIONAL LANDS ARE A VITAL
COMPONENT OF OUR CLIMATE PLAN
HERE IN CALIFORNIA THERE'S A
HUGE OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD ON
AVAILABLE DATA RESEARCH BY
ADVANCING NATURAL SOLUTIONS TOP
CALIFORNIA CHEAP EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS NOT TO MENTION
CONTRIBUTE TO OUR ECOSYSTEMS
OVERALL HEALTH. THE VALUE OF
OUR NATURAL WORKING LANCE HERE
IN CALIFORNIA TO OUR
ENVIRONMENT TO OUR ECONOMY IN
OUR COMMUNITIES CANNOT BE
OVERSTATED ESPECIALLY IN RURAL
CALIFORNIA. AND FOR THAT THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE BOTH. THANK
YOU MISS RIVAS SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE. ON THE ITEM.
QUIRK LIBERAL. IS THERE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OTHERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF A RESERVE
OF.
MR REVISTAS THE CALL.
MEMBERS THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY SEVEN. AB TWENTY NINE
FIFTY SEVEN. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY NINE FIFTY SEVEN BY SOME
REMEMBER ROBERT RIVAS AND
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES MYSTERY THIS YOU MAY
AGAIN OPEN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER- PLEASED PRESENTS OF
THE BILL TWO NINE FIVE SEVEN
THIS IS A BILL THAT WOULD ALLOW
LICENSE WINERIES TO FILL
CONSUMER PROVIDED BOTTLES.
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS A GROWLERS.
NOW THIS OCTOBER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC IS GREAT NEW
CHALLENGES FOR OUR STATE- NEW
CHARGES FOR CONSTITUENCIES BACK
HOME IN THIS THREAD AND MANY
MANY INDUSTRIES. ONE SUCH
INDUSTRY IS AN INDUSTRY THAT I
AM PROUD TO REPRESENT. BACK
HOME AND THAT. GOOD IT'S AN
ISSUE WHICH WHICH HAS A GROWING
FOOTPRINT NOT ONLY IN THE
DISTRICT I REPRESENT BUT
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA THAT'S
THE WINE INDUSTRY. NOW DO TO
THIS PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS WERE
IN IT'S ESTIMATED THAT
CALIFORNIA'S WINERIES WILL
SUFFER AN 80% LOSS A TWO POINT
FIVE FOUR- A BILLION LOSS AN ON
SITE SALES AMONG OTHER NET
LOSSES. AS A FORM OF RELIEF THE
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE CONTROL
DIRECTOR HAS ALLOWED WINERIES
TO REFILL CONSUMER PROVIDE
BALLS. I'M MONTHS OR AT. I'M
THIS PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS. THIS
BILL SEEKS TO CODIFY THIS FORM
OF RELIEF- AND FURTHER. BECAUSE
THIS BILL SIMPLY LIPS A
RESTRICTION ON WINERIES- IT
WILL NOT ADD X. ACOSTA
RESPONSIBILITIES TO THE
CALIFORNIA PART OF ALCOHOLIC.
BEVERAGE CONTROL THANK YOU AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IBM
THANK YOU MISTER. THANK YOU
MISS RIVAS. SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
RESERVE A VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OF A RESERVE VOTE. CLICK WELL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE SIXTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE BACK IN THE FILE TO TAKE
UP MISTER TINGS MEASURE THIS IS
FILE ITEM. ONE SIXTY FILE ITEM
ONE SIXTY AB TWENTY SEVENTY
SEVEN. COVERAGE ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SEVENTY SEVEN BY SIMPLY
REVERTING ACCOLADE HEALING ARTS
MR TING. THANK YOU MISTERSPEAKER MY BILL AB TWENTY
SEVENTY SEVEN EXTENDS THE
SUNSET ALLOWING PHARMACISTS TO
SELL SYRINGES WITHOUT A
PRESCRIPTION FOR FIVE YEARS
THAT'S BUILT ON MY A. B.
SEVENTEEN FORTY THREE WHICH WAS
PASSED A FIVE YEARS AGO. THIS
IS A BILL THAT UNIVERSALLY
SUPPORTED BY ALL PUBLIC HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS TO HELP SLOW THE
SPREAD OF VIRUSES AND ALSO
PHARMACISTS ARE ENCOURAGED TO
EDUCATE EDUCATE. EVERYBODY WHO
BUYS SYRINGES ABOUT DRUG
TREATMENT TESTING FOR HIV
HEPATITIS C. AS WELL AS SAFE
DISPOSAL SHARPS WASTE WITHOUT
RESPECTFULLY ASK DRIVER. THANK
YOU MISTER CHANG. SENIOR
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM.
CORPS CORPORAL. RESERVE AT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLE. TIED
ABOUT ICE FORTY SEVEN KNOWS
THIRTEEN THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS I AM PREPARED TO LIFT
THE CALL. ON FILE ITEM ONE
TWENTY SEVEN THAT'S MISTER
CALDERON IS AB TWENTY NINE
FIFTY NINE. LOCAL POST. VOTERS
ARE VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE THE ROLL TIDE ABOUT EYES
FORTY THREE KNOWS ELEVEN. THAT
MEASURE PASSES. BACK END
REGULAR FILE ORDER. THIS IS
FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY EIGHT. AB
TWENTY NINE SEVENTY TWO BY MISS
LEMOND THE CLERK WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINE
SEVENTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LIMON ACCOLADE POLITICAL
SECONDARY EDUCATION THIS
TOMORROW THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB TWENTY NINE SEVENTY
TWO AND FOR ITS CONSISTENCY
ACROSS ALL PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEMS FOR THE
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENT COMMUNITY
AT THE UNIVERSITY AND PROVIDES
AND THE SAME LEVEL OF SUPPORT
TO ALL STUDENTS IN UNIVERSITIES
TO THE CREATION OF AN ONLINE
TRAINING FOR CAMPUS
ADMINISTRATOR. THIS BILL FILLED
THE GAP THAT OFTEN REMOVED
CAMPUS ADMINISTRATORS HAVE WHEN
UNDERSTANDING THE DIFFERENCES
IN POLICY THE OVERLAP BETWEEN
UNDOCUMENTED AB FIVE FORTY AND
DOCTOR STUDENTS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MS EMMA. SAYING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE I'M CORPORAL
OVER THE ROLE. MEMBERS DESIRE
TO VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
VOTE. YEAH CLARK WELL. CLOSE
ROLE TIED UP AS FIFTY TWO KNOWS
A. THAT MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE
GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY ON
FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY TWO. AND
PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM
ONE EIGHTY THREE. PASS RETAIN A
FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY FOUR. WE
ARE NOW FILE ITEM ONE EIGHTY
FIVE THIS IS AB. THIRTY THREE
SIXTY SIX. FOR THE PURPOSE OF
AMENDMENTS COURT AGREED WITH
AMENDMENTS. ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY THREE SIXTY SIX WITH A
MEMBERS BY SOME MEMBER MARK
STONE MR STONE ON THE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER THE AMENDMENTS IS THAT
AND URGENCY CLAUSE I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE AND THAT THE BILL
BE. BUT BACK IN BRITAIN SAID
AND PUT BACK ON FILE. THANK
MICHELLE WITH OUT OBJECTION WE
MAY TAKE A VOICE VOTE ON THESE
AMENDMENTS ALL THOSE IN FAVOR
SAY AYE. OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE
AYES HAVE IT. THE EVENTS ARE
ADOPTED BILLS UP TO PRINT ABOUT
COME FILE. THIS IS.
MEMBERS WE
REMOVE ACTED TAKE A FILE ITEM
ONE EIGHTY THREE. FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTY THREE. THIS IS MISTER
CELIS IS AB THIRTY ONE SIXTY
THREE CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY ONE SIXTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS AND
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE TO ENERGY AS
YOURSELVES THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMERS I RISE TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
ONE SIXTY THREE I WHICH WILL
HELP CALIFORNIA MEET IT'S CLEAN
ENERGY GOALS BY UTILIZING
ORGANIC WASTE AND CREATING MORE
RENEWABLE ENERGY FOR GRID. AB
THIRTY ONE SIXTY THREE WILL
EXPAND THE DEFINITION OF BIO
METHANE TO INCLUDE CELLULOSIC
MATERIAL LIKE DEAD TREES AN
AGRICULTURAL WASTE WHICH CAN BE
USED TO CREATE RENEWABLE ENERGY
IF YOU EVER DRIVEN THROUGH THE
NINETY NINE OR THE FIVE UP AND
DOWN THE ENTIRE STATE SOMETIMES
YOU SEE THESE LARGE AMOUNTS OF
AGRICULTURAL WASTE IS BEING
BIRD. IN THE OPEN AIR THIS WILL
HELP CREATE CLEAN ENERGY FROM
THAT OF PREVENT US FROM HAVING
ALL OF THOSE HEALTH ISSUES THAT
WE HAVE FOR DOING THOSE THINGS
YOU GUYS KNOW THE ASTHMA RATES
IN THE ENTIRE STATE THIS IS A
BILL THAT WILL HELP I THINK
THAT'S WHY YOU SEE BROAD.
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL YOU SEE
EVERYBODY FROM CLEAN ENERGY
COMPANIES THE AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICTS THE WASTE
MANAGEMENT GROUPS. AND THE
BIOENERGY GROUP ALL IN SUPPORT
OF THIS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AND I HAVE A. FAMOUS SALAS
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM. CORPORAL THE DESIRE
TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
VOTE YOUR- ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. CLERK WILL CLOSE
ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE FORTY SIX
NO SEVEN. THAT MEASURE PASSES.
IN FILE ORDER THIS IS FILE ITEM
ONE EIGHTY SIX A. B. NINETEEN
FIFTY EIGHT BY MISTER COOPER
THE CLERK WILL READ SOME PEOPLE
NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT BY SOME
REMEMBER COOPER AND OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE OF FLOOD CONTROL AND
CLEARLY YEARS YOU'RE OFTEN TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY. MISTER
COOPER THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBER THERE SIXTY HER MILES OF
FLOOD CONTROL LEVEES IN THE
SACRAMENTO SAN JOAQUIN RIVER
SYSTEM WHICH SERVES PROTECT THE
LIVES AND PROPERTY OF THOUSANDS
OF RESIDENTS IS ENGINEERED
STRUCTURES THE CENTER VENT
FLOODING LEVEES REQUIRE REGULAR
OPERATION MAINTENANCE AND
PROTECTION AGAINST EROSION AND
THREATS OVER THE PAST TEN YEARS
CAN BY FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL
INVESTMENTS THE FLOOD SYSTEM OF
EXCEEDED THREE BILLION DOLLARS
JUST IN THE URBAN AREAS. RECENT
MEDIA REPORTS HOW ABOUT A NEW
THREAT DELIVERY SYSTEM
INCREASING ISSUE OF
UNAUTHORIZED LEVY EXCAVATIONS
WHICH IN SOME CASES RESULT IN
SIGNIFICANT DAMAGE YET
AUTHORIZED ACTIVATIONS ARE A
GROWING THREAT TO INTEGRITY
INSTABILITY OF THE LEVEE SYSTEM
THAT PROTECT LARGE AREAS OF
SACRAMENTO FROM FLOODING. AB
NINETY FIFTY EIGHT STREET THE
PROTECTIONS AGAINST
UNAUTHORIZED EXCAVATIONS CUTS
ALTERATIONS OR DESTRUCTION OF
THE LEVEE SYSTEM IN ORDER TO
PROTECT AGAINST PREMATURE LEVY
FAILURE WHICH COULD RESULT IN
FLOODING DISPLACEMENT OF
RESIDENTSTHOUSANDS OF DOLLARS
IN DAMAGE TO HOMES OF PROPERTY
AS WELL THINK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SACRAMENTO FOR- BEING A JOINT
AUTHORED ON THIS BILL. THANK
YOU MISTER COOPER NEW. MR
MCCARTY YOUR RECORD AS THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I I'M A
JOINT AUTHOR OF THIS MEASURE
AS- MY COLLEGE NOT GROW DONATE
AT THIS IS THE ISSUE THAT PUTS
SACRAMENTO MOST AT RISK
CERTAINLY WE HAVE- WILDFIRE
RISK SOME PARTS OF THE
CALIFORNIA SACRAMENTO ARE RISK
IS FLOODING WE ARE THE SECOND
MOST A RISK CITY IN AMERICA
ONLY BEHIND NEW ORLEANS WE SAW
WHAT HAPPENED THERE WITH
KATRINA A LITTLE OVER A DECADE
AGO. THIS IS A CRITICAL ISSUE
WE NEED TO ADDRESS I DO WANT TO
KNOW THAT IT WAS RAISED BY
OPPOSITION RELATED TO OUR
HOMELESS CRISIS IN CALIFORNIA
SOME OVER HOMELESS WE KNOW OUR
SLEEPING A CAMPING OUT OF THE
LEVEES WE DON'T WANT TO- BUT
NOT NECESSARILY JUST CRACKED
DOWN TO PUSH PEOPLE OFF WHERE
THEIR SHELTERING ALL RIGHT NOW
SO I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
MISTER COOPER IS WORKING WITH
THE OPPOSITION WE DO THINK THIS
IS A REASONABLE COMPROMISE I'M
IN FULL SUPPORT OF IT- IT
BALANCES THESE COMPETING
INTERESTED MORE IMPORTANTLY FOR
TAX. SACRAMENTO IN OUR REGION
FROM FLOODING THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISS REGARDING. SEE NO
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
THIS COOPER YOU MAY CLOSE WE
WISH AS FOR THE FULL PHONE
THING MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SACRAMENTO SAID THIS IS NOT
THIS BILL IS NOT ANTI HOMELESS
YOUTH CAN'T DIG IN THE LEVEES
UP PEOPLE ARE CREATING STEPS IN
HOLES IN THE ACTUAL LEVY AND WE
KNOW OF FOR THE LEVEE BREAKS IT
FLOODS DOWNTOWN SACRAMENTO ARE
STRICTLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THEY WISH COOPER WITH THAT
COUPLE OF THE ROLE. OBSERVER
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE A ROLL TIDE
ABOUT AYE AYES SIXTY FOUR NO
ZERO ON THEIR URGENCY AYE AYES
SIXTY FOUR NO ZERO ON THE
MEASURE. THE BILL PASSES. WE'RE
GOING TO PASS AND RETAIN A
PROBLEMS ONE EIGHTY SEVEN ONE
EIGHTY EIGHT. FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTY NINE IS AB TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY THREE BY MISTER COOPER
CORPORATE. SOME LEGAL TWENTY
FOUR SEVENTY THREE BY SOME
REMEMBER COOPER AN ACOLYTE OF
PUBLIC RECORDS MISTER COOPER
YOU MAY GET OPEN THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS THIS IS
ACTUALLY A TAMI BILL WITH ALL
THE UNCERTAINTY IN THE
FINANCIAL MARKETS. ARE PENSION
SYSTEMS ARE WORKING TO DO THEIR
PART TO PROTECT THE PENSIONS OF
ALL OF OUR PUBLIC EMPLOYEES. AB
TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY THREE WILL
GIVE A PUBLIC PENSIONS THE
ABILITY TO ACCESS EVERY TOLL
POSSIBLE TO INVEST AMENITIES
CALIFORNIA'S PENSION FUNDS. THE
BILL CREATE A PUBLIC RECORDS
DISCLOSURE STRUCTURE FELL OUT
PUBLIC PENSION SYSTEMS LIKE
CALPERS TO GUESS WE PURSUE
INVESTMENT IN THE PRIVATE LOAN
MARKET. AB TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY
THREE HAS STRONG BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT IS RECEIVED ZERO NOVO.
THANKS GERBER SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE. CORPS CORPORAL.
OBSERVER ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
VOTE. WORK WELL. CLOSER ALL
TELL YOU VOTE. I SIXTY NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES. THIS IS
FILE ITEM ONE NINETY. SAYS AB.
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY EIGHT.
CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DEEP IN OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE A TAXATION. THIS YOUR
DATE. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
OF MEMBERS TODAY I PRESENT AB
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY EIGHT A
WHICH WOULD REQUIRE THAT OUR
STATE ATTACKS DEPARTMENTS THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD. THE
DEPARTMENT OF TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION TO PROVIDE
BINDING WRITTEN TAX ADVICE IN A
TIMELY MANNER A CURRENT STATUES
ALLOW FOR ANY. CIVIC TO THEIR
INCOME OR SALES AND USE TAX
SITUATION HOWEVER THERE HAVE
BEEN INSTANCES WHERE RECEIVING
WRITTEN TAX ADVICE WOULD TAKE
YEARS OR WHERE STATE TAX
DEPARTMENT WOULDN'T HAVE NO
RECORD OF WRITTEN ADVICE BEING
REQUESTED. A THIS CAUSES AN
UNDUE HARDSHIP ON TAXPAYER
TRYING TO COMPLY WITH THE LAW
IN GOOD FAITH AB TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY PROVIDE CERTAINTY AND
BETTER CUSTOMER SERVICE FOR THE
TAXPAYERS THAT WE REPRESENT-
EFFECTIVE JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. STATE TAX
DEPARTMENT WILL BE REQUIRED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THE RECEIPT WITH A
REQUEST WITHIN THIRTY DAYS AND
PROVIDE THE BINDING WRITTEN
ADVICE WITHIN A HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY DAYS FROM THE DATE THE
REQUEST WAS RECEIVED- AB TWENTY
FIVE TWENTY EIGHT HAS
UNANIMOUSLY PASSED. BOTH THE
COMMITTEES ON REVENUE AND
TAXATION IN THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS A LASTLY I ALSO
WANT TO. THANK MY COLLEAGUE
FROM- THE CITY OF CARSON FOR
BEING A JOINT AUTHORS AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO YOUR SUPPORT
AND WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
STEVE. SAY NO DISCUSSION DEBATE
ON THE ADAM LIBERAL. IT IS OUT
OF IT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. QUIRK WELL CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT AYE SIXTY NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES. WE ARE
GOING TO PASS TEMPORARILY ON
FILE ITEM ONE NINETY ONE. THAT
BRINGS US TO FILE ITEM. ONE
NINETY TWO. AB. EIGHTEEN THIRTY
FIVE BY DOCTOR WEBER THE CLERK
WILL READ ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHTEEN THIRTY FIVE BY SOME
REMEMBER WEBER AND OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE EDUCATION FINANCE.
DOCTOR WEBER CAN YOU MAY OPEN
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS- I
PRESENT TO YOU THE TODAY AB-
EIGHTEEN THIRTY FIVE THE
SUPPLEMENTAL CONCENTRATION
GRANT REPORTING BILL. AB ONE
EIGHTEEN THIRTY FIVE WILL
REQUIRE LOCAL EDUCATION
AGENCIES TO IDENTIFY UNSPENT
SUPPLEMENTAL CONCENTRATION
GRANT FUNDS FROM THE PREVIOUS
YEAR AND USE THOSE ISLANDS AND
FUNDS TO SUPPORT THE
EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES OF THE
INTENDED STUDENT GROUPS. UNDER
LC FF CONCENTRATION
SUPPLEMENTAL GRANTS ARE AIMED
AT PROVIDING ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES FOR SCHOOL DISTRICT
TO HELP ENGLISH LANGUAGE
LEARNERS LOW INCOME STUDENTS
AND FOSTER YOU. THESE FUNDS
WERE NEVER MEANT TO BE
GENERALLY ALLOCATED THIS
ADDITIONAL FUNDING CAME FROM
THE PROMISE WITH THE PROMISE OF
ACCOUNTABILITY AND OVERSIGHT IN
ORDER TO CLOSE THE ACHIEVEMENT
GAP. SINCE THE ENACTMENT OF
BILL C. F. F. THESE GRANT
PROGRAMS TO PAY BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS TO ADDITIONAL DOLLARS
TO SCHOOL BUT THE PROMISE OF
ACCOUNTABILITY NEVER
MATERIALIZED. LAST YEAR I
REQUESTED AUDIT OF LOW OF HOW
LOCAL FUNDING FOR SO AND
CONCENTRATE GRANTS ARE BEING
SPENT AND THEIR EFFECTIVENESS.
THE CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR'S
REVIEW CHOSE TO AUDIT THREE
CALIFORNIAN THAT UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT'S CLOTHES OPEN IN SAN
DIEGO. UNFORTUNATELY THE
AUDITOR'S AND THEIR TEAM OF
INVESTIGATORS CONFIRMED WHAT WE
FEARED. THE AUDIT FOUND THAT
SOME SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND USE
THEIR UNSPENT SUPPLEMENTAL AND
A CONCENTRATION GRANT AS PART
OF THE DISHES GENERAL FUND FOR
THE FOLLOWING YEAR. THE REASON
WHY WE HAVE THIS BILL IS TO
ENSURE THAT THESE FUNDS ARE
PROPERLY ALLOCATED DUE TO. PASS
IMPROPER USE OF SOME BY SOME
DISTRICTS. SINCE TWENTY
FOURTEEN THE SAN DIEGO CLOTHES
IN OAKLAND UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT. ALL HAVE A LOAN
ROLLED OVER TO THREE HUNDRED
TWENTY POINT SIX MILLION
DOLLARS IN SUPPLEMENTAL
CONCENTRATION FOR FUNDING INTO
THE BASE FUNDS. IT'S
INTERESTING TO NOTE THAT THE
ONLY FUNDS THAT THEY WERE RE
DIRECTED BY THESE DISTRICTS
WITH THESE FUNDS MEANT TO SERVE
THE LOWEST PERFORMING STUDENTS.
THERE WERE SEVERAL OTHER
PROGRAMS THAT MAY SAID THE
SPECIAL IT FUNDING ON THE EAST
AB SIX OH TWO AND THE COUNCIL
PROGRAM THAT COULD PROVIDE
SUPPLEMENTAL FUNDING TO
DISTRICTS. BUT THESE RESOURCES
ENJOY THE NECESSARY SAFEGUARDS
IN PLACE TO PROTECT THEIR PER
THEIR PURPOSE. THIS IS THE
PURPOSE OF AB THIRTY EIGHT
EIGHTEEN THIRTY FIVE. BECAUSE
WE HAVE FAILED TO ACT WE HAVE
GIVEN SCHOOL DISTRICTS A
PERVERSE INCENTIVE. TO IGNORE
THE NEEDS OF OUR MOST
DISADVANTAGED STUDENTS AND
APPROPRIATE. THOSE FUNDS FOR
THE PURPOSE. THIS LACK OF
ACCOUNTABILITY. IT'S A SYSTEM
THAT ALLOWS BLOW. BROWN LOW
INCOME LANE LEARNERS AND SHE-
FOR CARE TO BEHIND THE REST OF
CLASS. IN THE AFTERMATH MATH OF
COVERT NINETEEN CALIFORNIA
STUDENTS WE FACING A LEARNING
LOS UNLIKE ANYTHING THEY HAVE
SEEN IN OUR STATE. FUND ALEX
FUNDS ALLOCATED TO LOW
PERFORMING STUDENTS SHOULD
RETAIN THE DESIGNATION IN GOOD
AND BAD TIMES. THIS WILL EVEN
BE MORE IMPORTANT AS I SAID AS
THE POINT OF DOING POST-
COLBERT NINETEEN. IN THE STATE
WERE ONLY 31% OF BLACK STUDENTS
AND 37% OF LATINO STUDENTS MEET
STANDARDS IN ENGLISH. IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT THE
SUPPLEMENTAL AND CONCENTRATION
FUNDS MEANT TO ASSIST THE
STUDENTS RETAIN THE
DESIGNATION. AB EIGHTEEN THIRTY
FIVE WILL PROVIDE THE
ACCOUNTABILITY NECESSARY TO
PROTECT THE CRITICAL
EDUCATIONAL SUPPORT. THAT THESE
FUNDS PROVIDE. A COW OF THAT
MATCH. THE THOUGHT OF CHILDREN
IN THE STATE WOULD NOT GETTING.
THAT THEY NEED OR DESERVE.
STATE OF COULD NOT. TO
CALIFORNIA'S. TO EVEN IN LIGHT
OF THE PANDEMIC. ESPECIALLY
ALIVE IT CASE PLEASE WITH POST
PANDEMIC. JUST BECAUSE THEY
HAVE A DOWN. N THE MEAN THAT
THESE FUN THIS THIS FUNDING
THIS. SHOULD BE SPLIT BY THIS
IT'S MEDIA. THE BILL HAS
ENJOYED BUT PART OF UNANIMOUS
SUPPORT IMPALA COMMITTEE AND I
RESPECTFULLY. FOR YOUR BOAT.
THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER MISTER.
YOUR IN THE REAR OF. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL I ASKED
ELSE AT THAT PASS ITS- GUN LARA
ON. WE'VE MAY A STARTLING
LITTLE ON CLOSING GAPS IN PART
OF THE REASON FOR THAT IS THAT
WE FOCUS MUCH MORE ON INPUTS
THAN WE DO ON OUTPUTS AND EVEN
WHEN IT COMES TO INPUTS I AS
THE AUTHOR HAS EXPLAINED- WE'VE
HAD- FAR TOO LITTLE- ASSURANCE
THAT THE ADDED FUNDS THAT WE'RE
PROVIDING TO DISTRICTS. ARE
BEING USED IN THE WAY THAT
THEIR INTENDED TO HELP STUDENTS
WHO ARE MOST IN NEED THIS BILL
IS A VERY GOOD STEP IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION AND ALIGNS
RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE STATE
AUDITOR I AND I ENCOURAGE AND
I'VE- THANK YOU MISTER CAP BAY
N. MISS QUIRK SILVA FROM YOUR
DESK YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK
YOU MEMBERS I TO RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AS A
FORMER CLASSROOM TEACHER AND A
JOINT AUTHOR ON THIS NOT ONLY
AUDIT. BUT THIS BILL I SEE A
MAJOR KNEE NOW ESPECIALLY
THROUGH OUR COVERT NINETEEN AS
WE SEE CLEARLY. THAT OUR
STUDENTS THAT ARE. UP AT RISK
OR EVEN MORE AT RISK. IF THAT
COULD BE POSSIBLE WHICH MEANS
THAT MANY MANY OF OUR STUDENTS
OF COLOR. HAVE NOT EVEN LOGGED
ON ONE TIME- THROUGH THEIR
EDUCATION- SOME BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE A BROADBAND AND SO
FORTH BUT ALSO BECAUSE WE KNOW
THEY DON'T HAVE THE SYSTEM THAT
THEY NEED TO PUSH THEM OUT
WHERE THEY NEED TO EXCEL IN.
OVER TEN YEARS AGO I STARTED AN
ACHIEVEMENT GAP GROUP AN ORANGE
COUNTY THAT WAS FOCUSING ON THE
CHIEF MEANT GAP AND WE DIDN'T
HAVE. SOME OF OUR BOARD MEMBERS
THAT COULD EVEN USE THE WORD
ACHIEVEMENT GAP BECAUSE THEY
DID NOT BELIEVE TEN YEARS AGO
THAT THE CHIEF MEANT GAP.
EXISTED NOW NOT ONLY DO WE SEE
T WE SEE THAT IT ALSO PERSISTS
AND WE MUST WE MUST USE THAT
FUNDING FROM THE LOCAL CONTROL
FUNDING FORMULA TO GO EXACTLY
WHERE THOSE STUDENTS THAT THOSE
FUNDS ARE MEANT TO BE. AND IN
ADDITION NOT TO ROLL THAT FUNDS
OVER INTO THE GENERAL FUND
WHERE MANY OF THOSE STUDENTS
WILL NOT SEE THAT SUPPORT SO I
STAND HERE IN SUPPORT. OF THIS
LEGISLATION. THANK NETWORK
SILVA MISS PATTERSON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THE SPEAKER MEMBERS.
I'M GONNA RESPECTFULLY YEAH LAY
OFF THE BILL. BUT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO EXPLAIN WHY. WE
TALK ABOUT INPUTS AND OUTPUTS
AND SUCCESS AND ACHIEVEMENT. I
HAVE THE PRIVILEGE OF
REPRESENTING CLOVIS UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT THEY WERE ONE
OF THE SCHOOLS THAT OUT WERE IN
FACT WHAT IT'D- I HAVE HIGH
RESPECT. FOR OUR AUDITOR. WHAT
I THINK WE FAIL TO REALIZE IN
THIS IS THAT THE USE OF FUNDS
BY CLOVIS UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT HAS IN FACT CREATED.
ONE OF THE MOST SINGULAR
SUCCESSFUL APPROACHES TOWARD
MOVING ENGLISH LANGUAGE
LEARNERS OP. AND THOSE WHO ARE
IN POVERTY IN FACT CLOVIS
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT HAS.
LOTS OF FAMILIES AND STUDENTS
WHO ARE MOVING FROM OTHER
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN TO CLOVIS
AT IF YOU LOOK AT THE
STATISTICS AND IF YOU LOOK AT
THE SUCCESS. CLOVIS UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT DOES A
REMARKABLE JOB. THEY USE SOME
OF THOSE DISCRETION FUNDS FOR
APPROPRIATE USES THAT HELP. THE
STUDENTS ALTHOUGH IT MAY NOT BE
CATEGORICALLY PERFECT IT DOES
RESULT IN HUGE IMPROVEMENTS
WHAT I MEAN BY THAT. CLOVIS
UNIFIED HAS A PROGRAM THAT PUTS
OUR MENTORS SIDE BY SIDE WITH
ENGLISH LANGUAGE LEARNERS AND
WITH CHILDREN WHO ARE. IT IN
UNFORTUNATELY POVERTY
SITUATIONS THE OUTCOMES ARE
REMARKABLE THEY IN FACT ACHIEVE
AS MUCH OR GREATER THAN ALL OF
THE OTHER STUDENTS IN CLOVIS
UNIFIED THEY ARE TURNING INTO
VALEDICTORIANS THEY ARE TURNING
INTO LEADERS. NOW THEY MAY NOT
THE FORMULA SUGGESTS. BUT I
SUGGEST TO YOU THEY IN FACT DO
IT. AND THE ACCOUNTABILITY
FACTOR HERE. IS WHAT HAPPENS
WITH THE STUDENTS ARE THEY IN
FACT LAUNCHING THEMSELVES INTO
SUCCESS THE ANSWER TO THAT IS A
REMAIN A RESOUNDING YES.
SOMETIMES THE COMPLAINT ABOUT
CLOVIS UNIFIED IS THAT THERE
ARE A- SCHOOL DISTRICT- THAT IS
AFFLUENT. THAT JUST DOES NOT
SUGGEST THAT THOSE WHO
CRITICIZE IT UNDERSTAND. THE
REALITY THAT THERE ARE
SIGNIFICANT KIDS IN PROPERTY
AND SIGNIFICANT ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS THAT ARE IN
CLOVIS UNIFIED AND THEIR
ACHIEVEMENTS ARE REMARKABLE.
AND I WANT TO ALSO SUGGEST WHEN
STUDENTS. FAMILIES DECIDE TO
MOVE FROM ONE. SCHOOL DISTRICT
TO ANOTHER. BUT BECAUSE THE
COMMUNITY HAS TALKED TO ONE
ANOTHER ABOUT HOW WELL THEIR
KIDS PERFORM. I UNDERSTAND THE
BASIC NUMBERS ANALYSIS HERE AND
I DO UNDERSTAND THE INTENT OF
THE MEMBER OF SPONSORING THIS.
I DO WANT TO JUST REMIND US
THAT THERE ARE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
AND CLOVIS IS ONE OF THEM. THAT
HAS TAKEN THOSE FARMS AND HAS
ACHIEVED REMARKABLE ADVANCE.
PER CAPITA BETTER ADVANCEMENTS
THAN ANY OTHER SCHOOL DISTRICT
IN THE AREA AND IN FACT MOST
SCHOOL DISTRICTS. IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA YES THEY DO IT
DIFFERENTLY YES THEY DO IT WITH
MENTORS AND WITH- OF FAMILIES
AND WITH THE STUDENT HELD BY A-
AND SO I'M GONNA LAY OFF. BUT
WE MAKE A MISTAKE IF ALL WE DO
IS LOOK AT NUMBERS AND WE DON'T
LOOK AT ACHIEVEMENT I'M HERE TO
SUGGEST THAT ACHIEVEMENT CLOVIS
IS WORTHY OF A THUMBS UP EVEN
THOUGH THEY WERE ONE OF THOSE
IN THE AUDIT APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPRESS WHAT WE
BELIEVE IS WHAT IS REAL IN THE
CLOVIS UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
I'M PROUD TO REPRESENT THEM.
AND PROUD TO KNOW SO MANY
FAMILIES WHO HAVE ENGLISH
LANGUAGE LEARNERS AND WHO HAVE
FINANCIAL CHALLENGES THAT ARE
DOING EXCEEDINGLY WELL IN
CLOVIS AND ARE IN FACT MOVING
TO THE DISTRICT ON PURPOSE.
THANK YOU FOR THE TIME. THERE'S
PATTERSON SEEING NO OTHER
MEMBERS SEEKING RECOGNITION.
DOCTOR EVERY MY CLOTHES RIGHT
ARM MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
I APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS OF MY
COLLEAGUES HERE- AND KEEP IN
MIND THAT THIS IS NOT OF THIS
IS NOT AN ATTACK ON ANY
PARTICULAR DISTRICT THIS WAS
RESEARCH THAT WAS DONE AND THEY
BRANDON LEE CHOSE CERTAIN
DISTRICTS TO LOOK AT OF THEIR
KNOWLEDGE IN THE REPORT THAT
THERE WERE SEVERAL. DISTRICTS
WOULD DO USING THE A MONEY
APPROPRIATELY NICOLE WAS MAY
HAVE BEEN ONE OF THOSE SO IT'S
NOT REALLY AN ATTACK ON CALL
WAS THEY WERE JUST THE ONES
THAT WOULD CHOSEN TO LOOK AT
THEY LOOK AT MY DISTRICT SAN
DIEGO AND- THEY SAW SOME GOOD
THINGS HAPPENING I SAW SOME
THINGS THAT WERE CHALLENGING
THAT WERE HAPPENING THE KEY IS
THAT WE HAVE AS A LEGISLATURE
WE OKAY MONEY PACIFIC. AND WILL
WE SAY WHAT IS MY TO FOR. THAT
BUT- PERSON IS NOT FORCE. NOT A
PENSION FOR. NOT FOR ANY OF
OTHER THING BUT IT SHOULD FOR
THAT. THEN WE LOOK TO SEE
WHETHER NOW AS AN OVERALL.
STATE ARE WE DOING THAT AND
THEY LOOK AT SPECIFIC. TO SEE
HOW THEY MANAGING THE MONEY.
AND WHAT WE SAW WAS THAT THERE
WAS NO REAL INTENT TO BASICALLY
IN SOME CASES TO FOCUS ON THE
MONEY ON THE KIDS THAT WERE
MOST IN NEED- AND THEN MONEY
WAS BEING HELD OVER FOR THE
NEXT YEAR AND THEN ROLLED INTO
THE GENERAL BUDGET FOR WHATEVER
THEY NEEDED IT. AND THAT
DOESN'T MEAN THE DISTRICTS
DON'T NEED DOLLARS THAT THEY
DON'T NEED THE RESOURCES THAT
ARE THERE. I THINK WHAT IT DOES
SAY IS THAT WHEN WE'RE
ALLOCATING MONEY FOR SPECIFIC
PURPOSES WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT MY GOES THERE. THAT IT
DOESN'T GET SHIFTED AROUND. AND
WHAT HAPPENED IS EVEN. UNDER
CLOVIS PEOPLE SAYING WELL WE
KNOW WE'RE GONNA HAVE A CRISIS
WE MIGHT NEED THAT MONEY. AND
MY ARGUMENT CONTINUE TO SAY
WHAT WOULD IN THAT PARTICULAR
VEIN. AND WHEN WE HAD LOTS OF
MONEY WE DIDN'T USE IT ON THOSE
KIDS. I HAVE NO FAITH THAT YOU
WILL USE IT NOW THAT WE'RE IN
A- SAYS SO WE HAVE TO PUT SOME
GUARD RAILS ON IS. SAY THIS IS
MY THAT SHOULD GO TO CLOSE IT.
GAP AND MANY DISTRICTS WILL DO
GRAY THINGS WITH IT- BUT SOME
ARE NOT AND AS A RESULT WE HAVE
TO MAKE SURE THE MONEY GOES
WORDS AND- AND IT. WE ASK FOR
ACCOUNTABILITY HOUSE. AS FOR
WITH. WE MAY. THIS WHICH-
ISSUE. WE GOT. CFF BUS BEEN
HERE FOR TWELVE YEARS. NO THE-
WAS A PART. THE DEAL. THERE
WOULD BE SO. ABILITY THAT WE
WOULD. THEM THE A FOUR. TO YOU.
IT AS A TWO. IF THEY- TO CHOOSE.
IF THEY WANT TO. BASE PROGRAMS.
THIS IS NOW. A SAFE I WHAT I
SAY. THAT THAT ONE ONE. BUT
PROGRAM. THE BEST. IN AND THOSE.
OF THINGS BECAUSE- WE GAVE THEM.
CAN TO BE ABLE TO YOU. THE MY-
AND HOW. THEY FELT IT WAS NO.
TO IMPROVE THE- ACHIEVEMENT OF
KßT. A CLOTHES MAYBE DOING
THAT. RIGHT WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE. THAT BECAUSE WE HAVE PUT
THAT MONEY. IN THE BUDGET FOR
THOSE CHILDREN. THAT WE- SURE
THE- DEVELOPER. AND HOLDING.
FOR THOSE DOLLARS. MAKE A-
DIFFERENCE. TO NOT DO THAT.
WOULD BE UNFAIR TO ALL OF THE
OTHER DISTRICTS WHO DON'T GET
CONSTANT. GRANTS WHEN I SIT ON
THIS. EIGHT AGO AND TALKED.
THIS PARTICULAR BILL. AND
PUSHED IT WITH OTHERS. AND
ALONG WITH MY- REPUBLICAN
COLLEAGUES AT THE TIME WHO WAS
THE- OF. WHO IS A- MINORITY. WE
PUSH THIS BILL. BECAUSE AND WE
SAID THAT WILL BE
ACCOUNTABILITY AND AS A RESULT
OF. GIVING EXTRA 20% TO BE
CERTAIN DISTRICTS. THAT MEANS
OTHER DISHES WON'T. THAT
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS. AND THAT'S-
YOUR TO THE- SISTERS BECAUSE
THEY WERE. A COME. TO HELP US.
IT GAP WITH A NOT. THAT IT IT'S
A LITTLE BIT MORE. TO SAY.
ANOTHER HELP. IT'S WHAT. WE
AGREE. ALL OF US AT THAT TIME.
ON FLOOR. THIS DISTRICTS WOULD.
THE TWENTY. CENT AND IF. THAT'S
GET THAT. AND WITH THE. THAT
EFFORT AND SOME OF YOU WHO WERE
HERE REMEMBER THAT. WE MADE
THAT COMMITMENT AND WE WORK AND
WE WERE TOLD. THAT THERE WOULD
BE ACCOUNTABILITY FOR WHAT
THOSE DOLLARS WENT. AND WENT
FROM YEAR TO YEAR TO YEAR AND
WE COULD NOT GET THE
ACCOUNTABILITY. THIS IS AN
EFFORT TO GET THE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE DOLLARS-THAT WE PUT IN PLACE. IT IS NOT
ATTACK ON ANY ONE OF THOSE
DISTRICTS BECAUSE THEY COULD
RUN ANYWHERE. AND PROBABLY
FOUND THE SAME RESULTS. SO WE
HAVE TO. IF WE MADE THE
COMMITMENT. TO CLOSE THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP IN OUR OTHER
DISTRICTS ARE NOT GETTING THOSE
EXTRA DOLLARS. WE SHOULD BEEN
LIVE UP TO OUR COMMITMENT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THOSE DISTRICTS
ALSO KNOW. THAT WE'RE SERIOUS
ABOUT BEING ACCOUNTABLE. AND
RESPONSIBLE AND GOOD CARE
TAKERS OF THOSE DOLLARS. ITH
THAT IN MIND AFTER EIGHT YEARS
OF STRUGGLING FOR ABILITY. I
RESPECTFULLY FOR I BILL. BIGGER
WERE WITH THAT. WILL OPEN RAW.
OUR VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARVO. ALL MEMBERS OF DESIRE TO
VOTE. CLICK WELL. CLOSER ROLE
TYLER BUT I SIXTY SEVEN THOSE
ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES. WHAT
A PASS TEMPORARILY ON FILE ITEM
ONE NINETY THREE. FILE ITEM ONE
NINETY FOUR IS A. B. NINETEEN
OH SIX. CORKERY SO IDDLE
NINETEEN OH SIX BY SOME
REMEMBER SALAS AND ACTUALLY THE
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS MR CELLS
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS I RISE RISEN ASSEMBLY
BILL NINETEEN OH SIX WHICH
WOULD PROVIDE GRATER WORKPLACE
EQUITY AND SAFETY FOR PREGNANT
CORRECTION OFFICERS MEMBERS YOU
MAY REMEMBER THE MEDIA ACCOUNTS
ON THIS WHERE THERE WAS SOME
CORRECTIONAL OFFICERS THAT LOST
OTHER CHILDREN BECAUSE OF THE
WORK THAT WAS REQUIRED OF THEM
THIS WILL REQUIRE CDC ARE. TO
IMPLEMENT PROCEDURES A
GUIDELINE FACTUALLY ADDRESS
THAT AND FIX THAT PROBLEM
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY VOTE.
THERE WAS SALAS SEE NO
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
ITEM LOCAL OF THE ROLE. MEMBERS
SARAH VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. CLARK WELL CLOSE
WRONG TIED UP I SIXTY EIGHT.
MEMBERS THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE
NINETY FIVE. AB NINETEEN TWENTY
THREE CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY BILL
NINETEEN TWENTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SALAS
INOCULATED BUILDING STANDARDS
MR SALAS YOU MAY GET OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN TWENTY
THREE WILL IMPROVE THE SAFETY
OF RESIDENTS DURING AN
EARTHQUAKE BY REQUIRING EACH CD
TO STUDY PROPOSING THE
INSTALLATION OF SCIENTIFIC
GAFFER ABOUT THE VICES AND IF
THE APPROPRIATE PROPOSED
BUILDING STANDARDS REQUIRING
THE INSTALLATION OF SEISMIC
GAPS SHUT OFF DEVICES ON NEWER
RENOVATED HOMES RESPECTFULLY
ASK PRIVATE. THANK YOU MISS
SHALL SEE NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
QUIRK LIBERAL MEMBERS. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OTHERS AT ABOUT. WHAT HAPPENED
WITH THE. WORK WELL CLOSE ROLE
TELL YOU ABOUT AYE SIXTY SEVEN
NO ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO PASS A
RETAIN ON. FILE ITEMS ONE
NINETY SIX THROUGH
. TWO
HUNDRED. MEMBERS WE ARE AT FILE
ITEM TO A ONE. THIS IS FILE
ITEM TO A ONE. AB NINETEEN
NINETY THREE BY MS KAMLAGER
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL
NINETEEN NINETY THREE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KAMLAGER AND
OTHERS AND ACCOLADES FROM
UNEMPLOYMENT COMPENSATION
MAKING OF OPERATION- FOR. THIS
KAMLAGER THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I'M HERE TO ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON AB NINETEEN
NINETY THREE THE FAMILY CARE
GIVER ECONOMIC SECURITY ACT.
MOST AND HOME SUPPORTERS
SERVICE PROVIDERS ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE YET
CALIFORNIA LAW EXCLUDES PARENT
AND SPOUSE AYE HSS PROVIDERS
FROM RECEIVING UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE PAYMENT. ABOUT 22% OF
OUR HSS PROVIDERS ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN THOUSAND
MOSTLY FEMALES FALL INTO THIS
CATEGORY. THESE PROVIDERS WHO
MAY BECOME UNEMPLOYED DUE TO
THE DEATH OF THEIR LOVED ONE
ARE WITHOUT A PAYCHECK OR ANY
TYPE OF FINANCIAL SUPPORT. AB
NINETEEN NINETY THREE EXTEND
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
ELIGIBILITY TO PARENT AND
SPOUSE I HSS PROVIDERS. BECAUSE
OF THESE CARE GIVERS MORE THAN
SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND SENIORS
AND PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
STATEWIDE RECEIVE THEIR CARE AT
HOME INSTEAD OF IN A NURSING
HOME. HOME CARE PROTECTS THE
VULNERABLE POPULATION FROM
COVERT NINETEEN AND OTHER
ILLNESSES AND PREVENT
FACILITIES FROM BECOMING
OVERCROWDED UNFORTUNATELY
STAGNANT WAGES AND INSUFFICIENT
BENEFITS HAVE CREATED A
DANGEROUS SHORTAGE OF CARE
GIVERS. AS A RESULT MANY CARE
GIVERS ARE PARENTS AND SPOUSES
WHO HAVE SACRIFICED THEIR
CAREERS TO DO THE WORK
THEMSELVES. THE COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC HAS SHINED A LIGHT ON
THE PROBLEMS THAT CALIFORNIA
WORKERS FACE. UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE IS A BASELINE
PROTECTION THAT MOST WORKERS
RELY UPON EVEN IN NON CRISIS
TIMES WE NEED A PERMANENT
SOLUTION SO THAT FAMILY CARE
GIVERS HAVE BEEN PIC EMPLOYMENT
PROTECTIONS ALL OF THE TIME. AB
NINETY NINETY THREE HAS
RECEIVED YOU. BY SUPPORT AND IN
THE SPIRIT OF MAINTAINING A
HEALTHY SOCIETY THAT TAKES CARE
OF ITS WORKERS I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. FAMOUS
KAMLAGER MR LACKEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. GET JUST REAL
QUICKLY I THINK AT THIS IS
TRULY A- SHOULD BE A
NONPARTISAN PIECE WHERE- WE
SHOULD NOT PUNISH FAMILY
MEMBERS WHO COMMIT THEIR LIVES
TO CARE FOR THE FAMILY. AND
THAT'S REALLY WHAT THIS IS
TRYING TO CORRECT SO I WOULD
HOPE THAT EVERYONE WOULD
SUPPORT IT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MAY THANK YOU MISS LACKEY. SEE
NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION DEBATE.
THIS KAMLAGER YOU MAY CLOSE IF
YOU WISH THANK YOU NINE ONE I
THINK BY CALLING FOR THOSE
WORDS AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. WITH THAT THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE.
DESIRE TO VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. THE DESIRE TO VOTE. WORK
WELL. CLOSER ALL TIED UP I
SIXTY SIX NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO
MOVE BACK IN THE FILE. THIS IS
FILE ITEM ONE SEVENTY ONE. MR
SANTIAGO. THIS IS FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY ONE. IT IS A. B. TWENTY
SIX NINETY NINE COOKERY
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SIX NINETY
NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER SANTIAGO
AND ACCOLADES FIREARMS MR
SANTIAGO YOU MAY OPEN I THINK
IT WAS A SPEAKER. BILL SIMPLY
EXEMPTS CERTAIN ENTITIES FROM
PROHIBITION AGAINST THE SALE OR
PURCHASE OF NOT REGISTER
HANDGUNS BUT HAS NO OPPOSITION
CHOICE BY PART SUPPORT AND
RESPECT LAST ARRIVAL. THANK YOU
SANTIAGO SEEING NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM. OR CALL THE
ROLL ALL MEMBERS. IT IS OUR TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. QUIRK WELL CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT AYE SIXTY ONE NO
ZERO. THAT MEASURE PASSES. BACK
IN REGULAR FILE ORDER WE ARE AT
FILE ITEM TO A TWO. AB EIGHT
NINETEEN NINETY FOUR BY MR
HOLDEN THE CLERK READ THE SOME
AGO NINETEEN NINETY FOUR BY
SOME REMEMBER HOLDEN OTHERS AN
ACCOLADE AMERICA MR HOLDEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN NINETY
FOUR. AB NINETEEN NINETY FOUR
HAS ENJOYED UNANIMOUS SUPPORT
THROUGH THE ASSEMBLY HEALTH AND
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE THIS
BILL WILL ALIGN STATE LAW TO
FEDERAL STATUTES BY PROHIBITING
THE TERMINATION OF MEDI CAL
BENEFITS FOR YOUNG PEOPLE UNDER
THE AGE OF TWENTY ONE AND
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH UNDER THE
AGE OF TWENTY SIX. AB NINETEEN
NINETY FOUR RELIGIOUSLY EXTEND
THE MEDI CAL SUSPENSION PERIOD
FOR ONE YEAR TO THREE YEARS FOR
ALL INMATES REGARDLESS OF AGE
SUSPENSIONS WILL ENSURE THAT
PEOPLE WHO HAD MEDI CAL BEFORE
ENTERING JAIL HAVE ACCESS TO
THE BENEFITS IMMEDIATELY UPON
REDUCE. EVEN WITH CDC OUR APP
REALLOCATION ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS IT CAN STILL TAKE
WEEKS AFTER RELEASE BEFORE THEY
HAVE ACT TO THEIR BENEFITS.
EVEN WITH THIS CODE NINETEEN.
RECENTLY RELEASE INMATES WERE
TWELVE POINT SEVEN TIMES MORE
LIKELY TO DIE OR PREVENTIVE
CALL. THIS ENSURE THAT ALL CAL
ARE PROTECTED DURING A GLOBAL
PANDEMIC. THANK THANK YOU AND
WE. THANK YOU MISTER HOLDEN
SEEING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE.
CLERK WILL OPEN THE ROLE. THIS
ARTICLE ON MEMBERS FUNDS AREN'T
ABOUT. ALL MEMBERS OF THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLICK WELL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF AND I
SEVENTY NO ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES THIS IS FILE ITEM TWO OH
THREE. AB TWENTY THIRTEEN
CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
THIRTEEN BY SOME REMEMBER IRWIN
ACKLEY THE TAXATION MISS IRWIN
IN THE REAR THE CHAMBER YOU MAY
OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
AB TWENTY THIRTEEN WILL HELP
VICTIMS OF RECENT CALIFORNIA
WILDFIRES AND OTHER NATURAL
DISASTERS GET BACK ON THEIR
FEET. BY PROVIDING MUCH NEEDED
PROPERTY TAX RELIEF THE BILL
SPONSORED BY THE CALIFORNIA
ASSESSORS ASSOCIATION AND IT
ENCOURAGES RESIDENTS TO STAY
AND REBUILD IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES AFTER A NATURAL
DISASTER. BY PROVIDING THE SAME
TAX RELIEF TO DISASTER VICTIMS
THAT RELOCATE ELSEWHERE IN THE
COUNTY THIS BILL SIMPLY CREATES
CONFORMITY WITH EXISTING LAW. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER ONE
SAYING NO. DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
OUR CLUB THE ROLE OF ALL
MEMBERS OF. RESERVE ON ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. WE
ARE OUR OUR WELL CLOSE ROLE.
TYLER I SIXTY SIX NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES. ONE THIS IS
FILE ITEM TO A FOUR AB TWENTY
NINETEEN. QUICK READ ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY NINETEEN BY
ASSEMBLY EMBER HOLDEN AN
ACCOLADE PEOPLE INSTRUCTION. MR
HOLDEN YOU MAY GET OPEN THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE TODAY
PERCENT ASSEMBLY BILL TWO
NINETEEN TWENTY NINETEEN AB
TWENTY NINETEEN HAS NO
OPPOSITION TO AS RECEIPT
RECEIVED ZERO NO VOTES STUDENTS
IN JUVENILE COURT SCHOOLS LIKE
FOSTER AND HOMELESS YOUTH
EXPERIENCE HIGH RATES OF
EDUCATIONAL INSTABILITY. AND
ARE LIKELY TO BE BEHIND IN
CREDITS BECAUSE OF THE QUALITY
OF COURTS SCHOOL EDUCATION
VARIES WIDELY MANY STUDENTS
EXPRESS THAT THEY FEEL
DISENGAGE FROM SCHOOL OR THAT
THEY ARE CONSTANTLY REPEATING
MATERIAL THAT THEY HAVE ALREADY
COVERED. DUAL ENROLLMENT AS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THIS UNIQUELY
VULNERABLE POPULATION TO MAKE
ACADEMIC PROGRESS AND JUMPSTART
THEIR COLLEGE EDUCATION THIS
BILL ENABLES COUNTY OFFICES OF
EDUCATION. TO PARTICIPATE IN
COLLEGE AREER ACCESS PATHWAYS
PARTNERSHIP WHICH ALLOW
STUDENTS IN JUVENILE COURT
SCHOOLS TO ACCESS THE BENEFITS
OF DUAL ENROLLMENT PROGRAM I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
ON AB TWENTY NINETEEN. THANK
YOU AS HOLDEN. SEEING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ADAM
CAR CLUB THE ROLE. THE DESIRE
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE WHO
DESIRE TO VOTE. CLICK WELL
CLOSE ROLLTIDE ABOUT I SIXTY
NINE NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES. MOVING BRIEFLY BACK TO
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS MISTER
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER PLEASE
REMOVE ITEM NUMBER TWO OH NINE
AB SEVEN NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX
EGGMAN AND ITEM THREE SIXTEEN
AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY SIX
FOUR FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
WITHOUT OBJECTION. I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
THE RULES TO ALLOW MEMBERS TO
TAKE UP THE FOLLOWING BILLS ON
SECOND READING WITHOUT
EFERENCE THE FILE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF THIRD READING WHILE
I'M NUMBER ONE AB TWENTY THREE
TWENTY THREE FRIEDMAN NUMBER
SIX A. B. NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE
FRIEDMAN NUMBER EIGHT AB TWENTY
TWENTY EIGHT AGUIAR-CURRY
NUMBER TWELVE AB TWENTY FIFTY
TWO O'DONNELL NUMBER FOURTEEN
AB TWENTY TO SIXTY HOLDEN
NUMBER FIFTEEN AB TWENTY SEVEN
SIX BIGELOW NUMBER NINE. AB
TWENTY SIX ON NUMBER TWENTY
THREE AB TWENTY ONE NINETY
EIGHTEEN NUMBER TWENTY SIX AB
TWENTY TO SEVENTY ONE GABRIEL
NUMBER TWENTY SEVEN AB TWENTY
TWO A TWO PARTY. I'M THIRTY ONE
AB TWENTY THREE SEVEN ONE
FRIEDMAN NUMBER THIRTY TWO AB
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY EIGHT
BERMAN. AND FORTY AB TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN FRONT RIGAS.
FORTY TWO AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY
TO SEE GARCIA NUMBER FIFTY
THREE AB TWENTY NINE NINETY
SPEAKER SCEA. ARE FIFTY FOUR A.
B. THIRTY THIRTY KALRA FIFTY
NINE AB TWENTY THIRTY TWO
TWENTY SIX A PARTY. NUMBER
SIXTY TWO A. B. THIRTY TWO
SEVENTY NINE FRIEDMAN. AND MR
FLOOR FOR PURPOSE SIR THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER WE WITHHOLDING
ASK CONSENT NATURAL CALL VOTE.
MISTER CALDERON MOVES AND MISS
HER BONTA SECONDS THAT THE
RULES BE SUSPENDED. MEMBERS
THIS IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE.
CARPOOL OF THE ROLE. CALDERON
IS ASKING FOR AN I. AND MISTER
FLORA NO. MISTER CALDERON IS
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE. AND MR
FLORA NO VOTE THIS IS
PROCEDURAL.
QUIRK WELL CLOSE
ROLE. ICE FIFTY EIGHT NO
SEVENTEEN THE RULES ARE
SUSPENDED. MISTER CALDERON YOU
GET RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER TO THOSE MEMBERS WHOSE
NAMES I JUST READ BE PREPARED
TO GO IN ABOUT TEN MINUTES. AT
THE REQUEST OF THE AUTHOR
PLEASE REMOVE ITEM NUMBER THREE
FORTY SEVEN AB THIRTY TWO
THIRTY FOUR GLORIA ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR AND MOVE THE
BILL TO THE IMAC TO FILE.
WITHOUT OBJECTION. MEMBERS I
WOULD ASK THAT YOU CONTINUE TO
OBSERVE PHYSICAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS. ON THE FLOOR
PLEASE CONTINUE TO OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING
REQUIREMENTS. AS BEST AS YOU
CAN.
MEMBERS WE ARE AT FILE
ITEM TO A FIVE. AB TWENTY FORTY
SEVEN MISS AGUIAR-CURRY CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FORTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY ANOTHER'S
MEDICALLY TO EMERGENCY SERVICES.
MS ACCURATE THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB TWENTY FORTY SEVEN
RESPONSE OF THE COPA NINETEEN
PANDEMIC BY ENSURING THAT
COUNTIES ADDRESS THE UNIQUE
NEEDS OF END OF VISUALS WITH
ALZHEIMER'S DISEASE AND
DEMENTIA IN THEIR EMERGENCY
RESPONSE PLANS DURING THE NEXT
UPDATE. PEOPLE LIVING WITH
ALZHEIMER'S AND DEMENTIA DEPEND
ON A NETWORK OF CARE GIVING
SERVICES THAT HAVE BEEN
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED BY THE
STATE HOME ORDER. MOREOVER
INDIVIDUALS WHO LIVE ALONE ARE
PARTICULARLY AT RISK IN
APPROXIMATELY ONE IN FOR
INDIVIDUALS WITH COGNITIVE
IMPAIRMENT LIVES ALONE. LEAVING
MANY WITHOUT RESOURCES THEY CAN
DEPEND ON AB TWENTY FORTY SEVEN
WILL ENSURE THAT OUR STATE
ACCOUNTS FOR THIS VULNERABLE
POPULATION AND MAKES
CONSIDERATIONS FOR SHELTERING
IN PLACE ORDERS. I ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MS SAGER
OCCURRING SEEING NO DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. QUIRK LIBERAL ALL
MEMBERS. THIS ADVERT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. NO.
WELL CLOSE ROLE TITLE BUT I
SEVENTY TWO NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS WE ARE
GOING TO MOVE BACK TO FILE ITEM
WHEN EIGHTY TWO. FILE ITEM ONE
EIGHTY TWO THIS IS MISTER
REVERSES A. B. THIRTY ONE OF
FIFTY THREE CORRECT ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTY ONE FIFTY THREE BY
SOME REMEMBER ROBERT RIVAS AN
ACCOLADE OF PLANNING AND ZONING
THIS RIVAS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER POLICE TO PRESENT THIS
BILL ASSEMBLY BILL THREE ONE
FIVE THREE INCENTIVIZE HIS BIKE
AND CAR SURE PARKING IN NEW
HOUSING. DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS
THIS BILL IS NOT VERY BROAD
SCOPE BUT CHECK US AT VERY
CREATIVELY ABOUT PARKING- THE
PARKING AT MID MID MID EXCUSE
ME MINIMUMS THAT ARE ARE ARE
SET IN- NEW CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS SPECIFICALLY THIS BILL
WOULD PROVIDE FLEXIBILITY TO
HOUSING. THE MOMENT PRIDE IN
REDUCING THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
VEHICLE PARKING SPACES. THEY
ARE REQUIRED- THEY ARE REQUIRED
TO PROVIDE IF. IF THEY PROVIDE
LONG TERM BIKE PARKING SPACES
OR CARSHARING SPACES OR BOTH.
AND SO POTENTIAL VEHICLE
PARKING SPACE REDUCTIONS ARE
TIERED AND PRIORITIZE ACTED
TRANSPORTATION AND AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WITH THE MAXIMUM
REDUCTION FOR EACH TIER CAPPED
A TOTAL THIRTY PERCENT. BUT
AGAIN IT'S TIERED AT THE 50%
THRESHOLD BUT CERTAINLY NOTHING
IN THIS BILL WOULD PROHIBIT
MORE GENEROUS STANDARDS BEING
OFFERED OR ESTABLISHED AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. WELL AS I
MENTIONED HIS BILL IS NOT VERY
BROAD IN SCOPE BUT THIS ISSUE
OF PARKING- IS AN IMPORTANT
ONE. IT'S IMPORTANT BECAUSE
THESE. THE MINIMUMS THAT THAT
THAT ARE ATTACHED WITH PARKING
HAVE UNINTENDED IMPACTS YOU
KNOW THEY CAN DRIVE UP THE COST
OF HOUSING THEY CAN REDUCE THE
NUMBER OF UNITS PRODUCED- AND
IN SOME INSTANCES HAVING THIS
FLEXIBILITY AS THIS BILL AS IT
IT PROPOSES TO STRATEGICALLY
REDUCE VEHICLE PARKING SPACES
WILL PROMOTE THE DIFFERENT
TYPES OF MOBILITY IN OUR STATE
IT COULD BOOST TRANSIT
RIDERSHIP WERE ASSESSABLE IN A
MOBILE. I ENCOURAGE MORE
CYCLING AND PUT TO USE
CALIFORNIA'S EXPANDING NETWORK
OF BIKE LANES IN GREEN WAYS
THIS BILL COULD SERIOUSLY
INCREASE THE AMOUNT OF BIKING
CARSHARE PARKING A NEW HOUSING
PROJECTS CERTAINLY WHAT WE NEED
TO STATE AND WELL ALSO. HELP IN
IN MANAGE SOME OF THESE
UNINTENDED IMPACTS OF. THESE
PARKING REQUIREMENTS. I KNOW
THAT WE SERVE A WHOLE BUNCH OF
DIFFERENT. CONSTITUENCIES IN
THIS STATE AND WE ALL DO OUR
BEST TO BRING STATE GOVERNMENT
TO THEM. WE DO OUR BEST TO MAKE
SURE STATE GOVERNMENT MORE
RESPONSIVE TO THEIR CONCERNS
AND I MENTION THIS BECAUSE THIS
BILL OF THIS INNOVATIVE
APPROACH IN FINDING A WAY TO
INCREASE BY PARKING IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND OUR DISTRICTS.
WAS AN IDEA FROM A LOCAL
CONSTITUENT IN OUR FIRST EVER
THERE OUGHT TO BE A LAW
PROGRAM. AND SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
THANK YOU MISS RIVAS. SAY NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE ON THE ITEM
OR CALL THE ROLL. MEMBERS
OBSERVER ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
ABOUT.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT
OF CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLE TELL
YOU ABOUT AYE AYES FIFTY TWO.
KNOWS ELEVEN. THE MEASURE
PASSES. MEMBERS THIS IS FILE
ITEM. TWO OH SIX. AB TWENTY
SIXTY ONE. KERKORIAN ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY SIXTY ONE BY SOME
REMEMBER LIMON ANOTHER SNACK
LATER FIREARMS. MS MARK THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY SIXTY ONE ENSURE
THAT ALL VENDORS THAT
CALIFORNIA AGAIN SHOWS ARE
SUBJECT TO THE INSPECTION
AUTHORITY OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE CURRENT LAW ALLOWS
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO
INSPECT THE RECORDS OF SOME
FIREARM DEALERS AND AMMUNITION
VENDORS AGAIN SHOWS BUT NOT ALL
FOR EXAMPLE THE DOJ LACKS
INSPECTION AUTHORITY OVER
VENDORS WHO HOLDS FEDERAL
FIREARM LICENSES BUT ARE NOT
REQUIRED TO OBTAIN CALIFORNIA
LICENSES CLOSING THIS LOOPHOLE
IS IMPORTANT TO ENSURE THAT ALL
FIREARMS. AND AMMUNITION
VENDORS CONDUCTING BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE ABIDING BY THE
SAME RULES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK GOODNESS
AMONG. SEEING NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE WILL OPEN. DESIRE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF. THE
DESIRE TO VOTE. WELL CLOSE ROLL
TIDE OF A- AS FOR THE FOR KNOWS
THREE THAT MEASURE PASSES. THIS
IS FILE ITEM TWO OH SEVEN AB
TWENTY ONE OH SIX BY MISS
AGUIAR-CURRY CORP WILL READ
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE OH SIX
BY SOME REMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY
ANOTHER'S MEDICALLY AND AN
ACCOLADE WILDLIFE HABITAT. THIS
AGUIAR-CURRY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB TWENTY ONE OH SIX
GENERATES FUNDING FOR THE NEST
TO HABITAT INSTEAD OF PROGRAM
THIS PROGRAM ENCOURAGES FARMERS
AND LANDOWNERS TO GROW COVER
CROPS OR NATIONAL VEGETATION.
ON IDOL LANCE TO PROVIDE WATER
FELL AND UPLAND GAME BIRDS WITH
WHILE FILE WILDLIFE HABITAT.
THE BILL ALSO REQUIRES
INCREASED ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
THE SPENDING OF FUNDS COLLECTED
VIA THE UPLAND GAME BIRD STAMPS
TO ALIGN WITH CURRENT
TRANSPARENCY PRACTICES FOR THE
OF THE STATE DUCK STAMP. AB
TWENTY ONE OH SIX COMPLIMENTS
ARE STATEWIDE GOALS FOR PROPER
CARBON SEQUESTRATION IMPROVING
AIR QUALITY IN PROTECTING WATER
FELL SPACES THIS BILL HAS HAD
MORE OPPOSITION IRIS. DRIVER
NOTED. CORPORAL OPEN THE ROLE.
RESERVE IT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS OF.
DESIRE TO VOTE. QUIRK WELL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT AYE SIXTY
SEVEN NO ZERO. THAT MEASURE
PASSES HAS RETAIN ON FILE ITEM
TO AWAIT. FILE ITEM TWO OH NINE.
THAT IS A. B. TWENTY ONE
EIGHTEEN. OPERATE ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY ONE EIGHTEEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA OTHERS NATURALLY
THE HEALTH CARE COVERAGE.
MISTER KALRA YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER IN
ORDER TRACK MARKET TRENDS ON
HEALTH INSURANCE PREMIUMS AND
COST SHARING AB TWENTY ONE
EIGHTEEN REQUIRES HEALTH
INSURERS TO SUBMIT AGGREGATOR
REPORTING FOR PLANS OFFERED IN
THE INDIVIDUAL AND SMALL GROUP
HEALTH INSURANCE MARKETS SOME
ARE REPORTING IS ALREADY
REQUIRED IN THE LARGE GROUP
MARKET. GIVEN SOME PREDICTIONS
THAT COVER NINETEEN MAY CAUSE
PREMIUMS TO SKYROCKET SUCH
TRANSPARENCY IS EVEN MORE
URGENT PROVIDE A CLEAR PICTURE
ON THE AFFORDABILITY OF HEALTH
PLANS THEY CAN ALSO SHED LIGHT
ON HOW CALIFORNIA HEALTH
INSURANCE PURCHASERS AND
INDIVIDUAL AND SMALL GROUP
MARKETS ARE RESPONDING TO THESE
CHANGES IN BROWN'S. WE GET A
TAKE A MINUTE TO LOOK THE
REPORTING A CAR OF THE BILL I
WILL BE TO WORK WITH HOW
INSURANCE AND SENATE. MY SMALL
BUSINESSES AND ENDED. PURCHASE
HEALTH AND NEED A SHOW. THERE
VALUE FOR THEIR PRE. DOES SMALL
BUSINESS MCGEORGE SUPPORT AB
TWENTY ONE A- THAT UNDERSTANDS
THE HEALTH INSURANCE
TRANSPARENCY IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT. TO COMBAT AGAINST
GUY ROCKETING INSURANCE RATES.
BUT THAT I SPOKE WE ASK FOR AN
IDOL. THANK YOU MISTER KALRA.
SEEING NO MEMBERS SEE
RECOGNITION ON THE BILL. COUPLE
OF THE ROLE. RESERVE AT ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBER SERVICE OUT OF A. YEAH.
CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLE CALVET
EYES FIFTY TWO DOES SEVENTEEN.
THAT MEASURE PASSES PASS RETAIN
ON FILE ITEMS TO TEN AM TO
TO TWELVE AB TWENTY ONE FIFTY
CORPORATION. SO MY BILL TWENTY
ONE FIFTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON ACCOLADE THE CORPORATE
SECURITIES MISTER CALDERON.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS BAY. MEMBERS AB TWENTY
ONE FIFTIES REALLY AN EASY BILL
TO CLARIFYING BILL WHEN IT
COMES TO HOW TO DETERMINE.
WHETHER OR NOT A CRYPTO
CURRENCY SHOULD BE QUALIFIED AS
A SECURITY OR NOT RIGHT NOW
UNDER EXISTING LAW IT'S
CONFUSING AND IT ISN'T CLEAR
WHICH IS A PROBLEM RIGHT NOW
THE REGULATOR WHICH IS THE BO
YOU GO TO D. B. O. ANYWAY AND
YOUR- CRYPTOCURRENCY COMPANY
YOU ASK THEM HEY. WHAT AYE
QUALIFIES TO SECURITY UNDER
EXISTING LAW WELL TO SAY IS IN
OUR OPINION WE DON'T BELIEVE
THAT YOU DO HOWEVER IT IS
UNCLEAR UNDER EXISTING LAW SO
THEREFORE WE DON'T KNOW AND IF
YOU DO HAVE ANSWER. HAPPEN I'M
GOING TO COURT THAT'S THE ONLY
WAY TO A JEW THIS IS BY BEING
PLACED- ARE UNDER SCRUTINY OF
THE HOW WE TEST WHICH IS WHAT
THE SEC USE NINETEEN FORTY SIX
HOW WE TESTED DETERMINE WHETHER
OR NOT AN ASSET IS A SECURITY.
OR NOT THAT IS AN EXHAUSTIVE
PROCESS IF YOU'RE A BUSINESS
THINKING ABOUT DOING BUSINESS
IN CALIFORNIA CRYPTOCURRENCY
BUSINESS YOU'RE GONNA TAKE A
LOOK AT THAT RISK OF COMING IN
DOING THIS THIS IS IN
CALIFORNIA WHERE YOU COULD. BE
TAKEN COURT ORDERED AT INSECURE
ISSUE OR YOU CAN GO TO COLORADO
OR WYOMING WHERE THEY HAVE
ALREADY QUALIFIED. WE'RE LYRICS
FIVE THEIR LAW OF THIS BIZ. AND
FOR CAL. AND THIS INDUSTRY SO
THAT WE CAN CONTINUE TO BE A
LEADER. WHEN WE LOOK AHEAD ARE
AT THE CHALLENGING TIMES THAT
WE FACE. OUR ECONOMY WE WANT
THAT ECONOMIC INVESTMENT IN
CALIFORNIA WE WANT. THOSE JOBS
BUT IF WE DON'T HAVE CLARITY
UNDER OUR LAW WE'RE NOT GOING
TO GET THESE JOBS. AND SO IT'S
A REAL OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO
CLARIFY THIS LAW AND THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT DVL WHO IS THE
REGULATOR. ONCE WHEN I SAT DOWN
TO TALK TO THEM ABOUT THIS
ISSUE THEY WERE THERE TO HELP
ME CRAFT. THE DIRECTION THAT WE
WERE GOING BECAUSE THIS IS WHAT
IS GOING TO BE MOST. USEFUL FOR
THEM SPECIFICALLY IN REGULATING
THESE DIGITAL ASSETS- I WANT TO
THANK. OUR THE CHAIR OF THE
ASSEMBLY BANKING COMMITTEE WE
WORKED REALLY HARD. ON A LOT OF
DEFINITIONS AND STRUCTURAL
ISSUES WITHIN THE BILL- ALT
AMENDMENTS WE'RE GONNA BE
TAKING. A CAKE TAKING IN THE
SENATE BUT THIS IS A GREAT
OPPORTUNITY FOR CALIFORNIA THIS
BILL IS STRICTLY THERE TO
PROVIDE CLARITY. ON THE FACT
THAT. CRYPTO CURRENCIES THESE
DIGITAL ASSETS DO NOT QUALIFY
SECURITIES AND BY THE WAY THE
SEC HAS ALREADY MADE THIS
DETERMINATION ON THEIR OWN AND
A FOURTEEN PAGE REPORT. SAYING
THAT THEY DO NOT QUALIFY AS
SECURITIES- BUT THEY HAVEN'T
CODIFIED AND LAW. SO FOR US TO
PROVIDE THAT CLARITY TO PROVIDE
DOWNTURN TO THESE BUSINESS IS
BUSINESS IS SO THAT WE CAN HAVE
THEM HERE. START HERE THAT AND
GET THE JOB. THE SIX. PORT AT
SO. A FOR AN AYE VOTE. THE BAY.
SEVERAL OF THE ALL. ZERO ALL
MEMBERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MY
VOTE. IT IS OUR VOTE. CLICK
WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT EYES
FIFTY NINE. NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES. THIS IS FILE
ITEM TO THIRTEEN. AB TWENTY ONE
SIXTY SEVEN BY MISTER DALY
CORKERY SO MIDDLE TWENTY ONE
SIXTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
DALY AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE TO
INSURANCE MR DAILY. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
THIS IS AN INNOVATIVE
BIPARTISAN APPROACH TO
INCENTIVIZE INSURERS TO WRITE
MORE HOMEOWNERS INSURANCE
POLICIES. IN OUR STATES HI FIRE
RISK REGION'S. THE APPROACH IS
ENTITLED THE INSURANCE MARKET
ACTION PLAN. EXISTING LAW
LIMITS THE OPTIONS FOR INSURERS
DEFINE REASONABLE WAYS TO ISSUE
POLICIES IN OUR HIGH FIRE RISK
REGION'S. THIS BILL AUTHORIZES
AN INSURER TO FILE A PLAN WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF INSURANCE
THAT ADDRESSES THAT INSURERS
PRACTICAL NEEDS. THE BILL DOES
NOT IN ANY WAY TO CHANGE OR
LIMIT THE AUTHORITY THE
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER TO
APPROVE OR REJECT AMERICAN
MARKET ACTION PLAN FILING. IF
THE PLAN IS APPROVED BY THE
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER. THE
INSURER WOULD BE SUBJECT TO A
LEGAL MANDATE TO INCREASE THE
VOLUME OF POLICIES IT OFFERS TO
HOMEOWNERS IN HIGH FIRE RISK
REGION'S. THE BILL ALSO
ADDRESSES HOW TO MEASURE THE
INSURERS COMPLIANCE WITH THE
REQUIREMENTS THE ISSUE MORE
POLICIES AND AGAIN. THIS WILL
NOT HAPPEN UNLESS. THE
INSURANCE COMMISSIONER APPROVED
THE PLAN AND THE INSURERS WILL
HAVE TO ISSUE MORE POLICIES IN
THOSE REGIONS. IT PASSED
UNANIMOUSLY IN THE INSURANCE
COMMITTEE A COMMITTEE
BIPARTISAN VOTE I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MISS DALY. MR COOLEY YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED. COLLEAGUES I AM
PLEASED TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL IT IS DEFINITELY
INNOVATIVE AS TO CALIFORNIA BUT
IS NOT INNOVATIVE AS THE
INSURANCE MARKET PLACE THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION WAS FIRST
COMMISSIONERS HAS RECOGNIZE
THIS TYPE OF PLAN IN OTHER
STATES FOR MANY MANY YEARS. IT
IS DEFINITELY A NEED WE ARE
SEEING THIS CHANGE OR GLOBAL
WARMING WARMING THE ESSENCE OF
FIRES ARE REMARKABLY JUST THIS
PAST WEEKEND I MET A GENTLEMAN
FROM OF THE DISTRICT OF MY
COLLEAGUE FROM O'NEILL'S
CALIFORNIA AND MADERA COUNTY.
THE GENTLEMAN WHO LIVES IN
PIONEER AND AMADOR COUNTY LIVED
THERE FOR THIRTY YEARS HAD HAD
THE HOPE IN RETIREMENT TO MOVE
ELSEWHERE FOUND HE COULD NOT
MOVE BECAUSE OF THE INSURANCE
MARKET PLACE THE LACK BEEN ABLE
SELL HIS HOME TO SOMEONE WHO
WOULD HAVE DEPENDABLE INSURANCE
COVERAGE SO I THINKTHAT THE
GLOBAL WARMING THE- PROSPECT OF
INCREASE FIRES. IS HAVING A
MIRROR MATERIAL EFFECT ON THE
WELL BEING OF CALIFORNIANS NOT
JUST INSURANCE MARKET PLACE BUT
IN OTHER FUNDAMENTAL ASPECTS OF
THE PERSONAL FAIRS IS
ILLUSTRATED BY THIS GENTLEMAN
AND OF. IRISH AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS COOLEY. SEEING
NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE ITEM FOR CLUB-
ALL. ALL MEMBERS OF THE DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. THIS TAKES FIFTY FOUR.
ALL MEMBERS HER RESERVE VOTE.
CLARK WELL. CLOSE ROLL CALL
VOTE EYES FIFTY SIX KNOWS THREE.
THAT MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEM
TO FOURTEEN IS AB TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY EIGHT OPERATE ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY ONE SEVENTY EIGHT
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEVINE
ACCOLADE TO EMERGENCY SERVICES
MR LEVINE YOU MAY OPEN THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTY EIGHT
WOULD EXPAND THE CONDITIONS
CONSTITUTING A STATE OF
EMERGENCY OR LOCAL EMERGENCY TO
INCLUDE A PLAN TO DE ENERGIES
ATION EVENTS CALIFORNIA IS NO
STRANGER TO THE THREAT OF
WILDFIRES AND THE DEVASTATING
IMPACT IMPOSE ON RESIDENTS AND
BUSINESSES. THROUGHOUT OCTOBER
TWENTY NINETEEN P. GINNY
EXECUTED SEVERAL PUBLIC POWER
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT OFFS
THROUGHOUT THEIR SERVICE AREA
THESE PLANNED THE ENERGY IS
ATION EVENT EVENTS SHUT OFF
POWER TO MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS CLOSE SCHOOLS AND
HURT BUSINESSES ACROSS THE
STATE ALTHOUGH THE GOVERNOR WAS
ULTIMATELY ABLE TO DECLARE AN
EMERGENCY DUE TO RELATED
IMPACTS OF THE PS PSP BECAUSE
OF THE PLAN NATURE OF THESE
EVENTS AND EMERGENCY
DECLARATION COULD NOT BE MADE
TO PROVIDE NEEDED SUPPORT FOR
THOSE IMPACTED BY THESE EVENTS
WILD FIRES WILL CONTINUE TO
IMPACT OUR STATE INTO THE
FORESEEABLE FUTURE. AS
CALIFORNIA WORKS TO PREPARE FOR
THE NEXT DISASTER AB TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY EIGHT IS AN IMPORTANT
TOOL FOR ANY LOCAL GOVERNMENT
OR GOVERNOR TO BE ABLE TO RE
QUICKLY RESPOND IN SUPPORT
THOSE IMPACTED I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR- VOTE. THANK YOU
MISS LIVING SAYING NO
DISCUSSION DEBATE. QUIRK WELL
OF THE ROLE. IT IS OUR VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT
I SIXTY EIGHT NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES IRELAND TO
FIFTEEN IS AB TWENTY TWO OR
THREE BY MISTER NAZARIAN.
CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
TWO OR THREE BY SOME LIMóN IS
ERIN AND OTHERS AN ACCOLADE TO
HEALTH INSURANCE. MR HYSTERIA.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES I RISE TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY TWO OR THREE. THIS BILL
WOULD- CAP COPAYS FOR INSULIN
AT FIFTY DOLLARS PER THIRTY DAY
SUPPLY AND NO MORE THAN A TOTAL
OF A HUNDRED DOLLARS TOTAL. PER
MONTH REGARDLESS OF THE AMOUNT
OR TYPE. THIS BILL ALSO
AUTHORIZES THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
TO INVESTIGATE PRICING OF
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS MADE
AVAILABLE TO CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS CONSIDERING THE ROLE
OF EACH ENTITY IN THE ENTIRE
SUPPLY CHAIN. TO ENSURE THE
ADEQUATE CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
WITH PRICING. OVER FOUR MILLION
CALIFORNIANS SUFFER FROM
DIABETES. FOR MANY CALIFORNIANS
WITH DIABETES INSULIN IS AN
ESSENTIAL PART OF A HEALTHY
LIFE. IF YOU HAVE DIABETES YOU
MOST LIKELY REQUIRE INSULIN TO
SURVIVE. BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND
SEVEN AND TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
THE PRICE OF INSULIN HAS
INCREASED OVER TWO HUNDRED AND
62% THE AVERAGE LIST PRICE
INCREASED FIFTY FIVE PERCENT.
THIS GUY ROCKETING PRICE IS
UNTENABLE OFTEN CAUSING UNDUE
BURDEN ON OUR HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
AND FORCING MANY WHO CAN'T
AFFORD THEIR MEDICINE THE SELF
RATION. LET'S NOT FORGET THAT
THE- MANUFACTURING OF THE
MEDICATION HAS NOT CHANGED IN
THIRTY YEARS WHILE THE PRICE
HAS GONE UP TWO HUNDRED AND 62%
ACCORDING TO A STUDY PUBLISHED
IN THE JOURNAL OF AMERICAN
MEDICINE IN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN NEARLY 26% OF DIABETES
PRESCRIBED INSULIN REPORTED
COST RELATED UNDER USE LEADING
TO POOR GLYCEMIC CONTROL AND
POTENTIAL HEALTH PROBLEMS. THAT
ARE EVEN MORE COSTLY AND
POTENTIALLY DEADLY. AWESOME
POLLUTION FOR THE PRICE OF
INSULIN HAS HAD A
DISPROPORTIONATE EFFECT ON
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR
PARTICULARLY AFRICAN AMERICANS
LATINOS AND CERTAIN NATIVE
AMERICAN POPULATIONS AND WHILE
DIABETES IMPACTS MEN AND WOMEN
EQUALLY. WOMEN ARE MORE LIKELY
TO RATION THEIR INSULIN DUE TO
ECONOMIC IMPACT. COVERED
NINETEEN HAS ONLY EXACERBATED
THE NEED TO INCREASE ACCESS TO
INSULIN STUDIES HAVE SHOWN THAT
DIABETES DIABETICS ARE AT
HIGHER RISK OF CONTRACTING
CORBETT NINETEEN AND ARE FOUR
TIMES MORE LIKELY. TO DIE. AB
TWENTY TWO OR THREE. WILL MAKE
INSULIN MORE AFFORDABLE FOR ONE
THIRD OF THE USERS OF INSULIN.
DECREASE OUT OF POCKET EXPENSES
BY AN AVERAGE OF 50% DECREASE
HOSPITAL VISITS THAT CAN
INCREASE UNNECESSARY EXPOSURE
TO COVERED TO THE CURRENT A
VIRUS AND DECREASE. IN
EMERGENCY HOSPITAL VISITS WHICH
IS ESTIMATED. CONCERT ABILITY
CONSERVATIVELY AT ABOUT ONE
POINT ONE MILLION. AND WILL NOT
RAISE PREMIUMS FOR CALIFORNIANS.
ACCORDING TO THE CHIU PURPOSE
STUDY THAT CAME OUT TWO MONTHS
AGO. FURTHERMORE DOZENS OF
OTHER STATES HAVE INTRODUCED OR
PASSED SIMILAR LEGISLATION.
CALIFORNIA CAN AND SHOULD
CONTINUE TO TAKE THE LEAD ON
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE WITH THAT
I ENCOURAGE AN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MISTER IS THERE IN THIS
MESS. YOUR REQUEST THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE AND I
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FOR ITS
AUTHORSHIP MY MOTHER WAS IN
FACT ONE OF THOSE WOMEN WHO
RATIONED HER OWN INSULIN-
WITHOUT ACCESS TO HEALTH
INSURANCE FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS
AND THEN ONCE YOU BECAME
QUALIFIED FOR MEDICAID. SHE
DIDN'T HAVE A SINGLE MONTH OF
HER LIFE THAT WAS CUT FAR TOO
SHORT YOU CAN ACTUALLY AFFORD
HER DILLON SHE ALSO DID NOT
SHARE THAT WITH MY BROTHERS AND
WITH ME SO THAT WE COULD CHIP
IN TO HELP. THIS MEASURE IS
ESSENTIAL IT IS HUMANITARIAN
AND I URGE YOUR SUPPORT. THANK
YOU MISS WITH. DOCTOR WOULD
YOUR ADDRESS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS
ANGELES. IT'S A SHAME THAT WE
HERE WE ARE. LITERALLY ALMOST A
HUNDRED YEARS SINCE INSULIN WAS
PATENTED. AND YET THE PRICE
CONTINUES TO SKYROCKET THERE IS
NO GENERIC FORM OF INSULIN YET
AND THAT IS THAT IS A SHAME.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE COP WITH
THE DISEASE PATTERN OF THIS OF
THIS HORRIBLE DISEASE IS AT
LEAST A HEART DISEASE. GUM
DISEASE- WOUND PROBLEMS AND
FEELING THAT GOES ALONG WITH
THAT LEADING TO POTENTIALLY
APPLICATIONS AT LEAST A VISUAL
IMPAIRMENT THIS IS AN
ABSOLUTELY HORRIBLE DISEASE AND
IN CALIFORNIA NEARLY 50% OF THE
POPULATION IS EITHER DIABETIC
OR PRE DIABETIC. SO THE
FINANCIAL IMPACTS TO OUR
SOCIETY TO OUR OUR HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM ARE ARE HUGELY DRAMATIC
AS I SAID IN A WEEK OR SO AGO.
JUSTIN JUSTIN THE MEDI CAL
PROGRAM ALONE WE SPEND THREE
POINT SIX BILLION DOLLARS A
YEAR WITH THE BE- TO TREAT OUR
RECIPIENTS THEIR MEDICARE
RECIPIENTS WHO HAVE DIABETES
FOR ALL OF THE TREATMENT
INCLUDING THEIR ASSOCIATED
HEALTH CONDITIONS THIS IS A
CRITICAL BILL I WANT TO THANK
MY COLLEAGUE FOR THIS. THE COST
TO THE INSURERS IS MINIMAL I
BELIEVE IT'S ABOUT ELEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS TOTAL IN
POTENTIAL IN FOR A PREMIUM
INCREASE. VERSUS ABOUT A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY BILLION
DOLLARS ARE MADE IN IN PREMIUMS
THAT THEY COLLECT THE YEAR TO
REALLY MINIMAL REALLY MINIMAL
COST FOR REALLY BIG IMPACT AND
I THINK MY COLLEAGUE RINGS FOR
TO ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK
YOU DOCTOR WOULD MR BLOWN IN
THE REAR CHAMBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I WANT TO SPEAK OUT
ALSO IN FAVOR OF- AB TWO TWO
ZERO THREE AND- THANK GOD MY
FRIEND AND COLLEAGUE FROM THE
SAN FERNANDO VALLEY FOR OFFER
BRINGING IT AT A TIME WHEN WE
ARE ENGAGED IN A NATIONAL
DISCUSSION AROUND- RACIAL
DISPARITIES- THIS IS ONE ISSUE
THAT WE SHOULD TAKE NOTE OF AND
THAT IS THAT AFRICAN AMERICANS
AND LATINOS ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED. BY
DIABY THIS AND THEREFORE THIS
ISSUE THIS BILL IS OF CRITICAL
IMPORTANCE OF THOSE POPULATIONS.
THANK YOU MITCHELL I'M MISTER
JONES SAWYER FOR ME DESK. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER OF I JUST
WANT TO. TAKE IT FROM A
PERSONAL STANDPOINT AS SOMEONE
THAT HAS DIABETES. THAT WORK
REAL HARD TO LOSE THE WEIGHT TO
BE OFF OF INSULIN. ON THE WHOLE
FOR THE OFFENSE AND FOREVER I
HAVE NO IDEA WHEN I WAS ON MY
INSULIN HOW MUCH IT WOULD HAVE
COST BECAUSE I'M OE OF THOSE
FORTUNATE ONE. THAT ACTUALLY
HAS MEDICAL CARE HAS TO ASK
MEDICAL INSURANCE. MY SISTER ON
THE OTHER HAND DOES NOT. AND IS
A LITTLE OVERWEIGHT. AND I HAVE
NO IDEA WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
TO HER SHE GOES DAY BY DAY WITH
BLECHER GOING UP AND DOWN AND-
AND I'VE SEEN SOME OF THE BILLS
THAT SHE'S HAD TO CONTEND WITH.
AND FOR SOMEONE THIS HASN'T
BEEN EMPLOYED FOR ALMOST FIVE
YEARS NOW- ITIS- BROUGH UP FOR
ME AS HER BROTHER- IT IS REALLY
HEART WRENCHING TO KNOW THAT I.
THERE'S NOT A LOT I CAN DO TO
HELP OUR- THIS IS SOMETHING I
CAN DO TO HELP. THIS IS
SOMETHING I CAN DO TO NOT ONLY
SAVE MEMBERS OF MY FAMILY
MEMBERS IN MY COMMUNITY. BUT
HOPEFULLY. HELP EVERYONE
BECAUSE THE PRICE OF INSULIN-
AND THE PRICE OF INSULIN
RELATED DISEASES ARE
ASTRONOMICAL. AND UP IN KNOWING
THAT THAT PEOPLE IN MY
COMMUNITY COULD NOT ONLY LOSE
PARTS OF THE BODY. OF THE HIGH
BLOOD PRESSURE TO STROKES
KIDNEY PROBLEMS- ARE TREMENDOUS
AND SO THIS IS DEFINITELY A
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
AND HOPEFULLY IT'S A STEP WHERE
I CAN SEE MY BABY SISTER. I'LL
BE AROUND FOR A LOT LONGER THAN
IS. IS ANTICIPATED RIGHT NOW
AND SO I DEFINITELY AM IN FAVOR
OF AB TWENTY TWO OH THREE.
THANK YOU MISTER JONES SAWYER.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEEKING
RECOGNITION MISTER NECESSARY
AND YOU MAY CLOSE WE WISH.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER THANK
YOU TO ALL THE ALL MY
COLLEAGUES WHO SPOKE IN
SUPPORT- I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MISTER NAZARIAN WITH THE
CLERK WILL CALL THE ROLL. THESE
ARE VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
VOTE. THE CLERK WILL CLOSE
ROTANA BUT I SIXTY ONE KNOWS TO.
THE MEASURE PASSES MEMBERS WE
ARE NOW GOING TO TAKE UP THE
WHARF ITEMS. THERE WERE ON
SECOND READING NOW ON THIRD
READING. WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN
WITH. MS FREEMAN'S ITEMS. YEAH
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER ONE.
AB. TWENTY THREE TWENTY THREE.
FILE ITEM ONE TWO AB TWENTY
THREE TWENTY THREE MS FRIEDMAN
CORPORATION ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY THREE TWENTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN AND
OTHERS AN ACCOLADE TO
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY THIS
FRIEDMAN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I'M FIRST
PRESENTING AB TWENTY THREE
TWENTY THREE ON BEHALF OF
MYSELF AND MY JOINT AUTHORED
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FROM SAN
FRANCISCO CHAIR OF THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE. CALIFORNIA CONTINUES
TO FACE UNPRECEDENTED HOUSING
UNPRECEDENTED HOUSING CRISIS
AND THE STATE. CLEARLY NEEDS TO
PRODUCE NEW HOUSING UNITS. OVER
THE YEARS THE STATE HAS CREATED
MANY TYPES OF SEQUEL EXEMPTIONS
FOR HOUSING PROJECTS. EACH WITH
DIFFERENT CONDITIONS AND
REQUIREMENTS AND THESE
INCONSISTENCIES HAVE CREATED
BARRIERS AS THERE IS A
PATCHWORK OF DIFFERENT
REGULATIONS AND DEVELOPERS AND
MUNICIPALITIES HAVE TO TRY TO
SORT THROUGH WHAT OFTEN SEEM
CONFUSING AND ALL EVEN.
INCOMPATIBLE AB TWENTY THREE
TWENTY THREE MAKES EXISTING
HOUSING EXCEPTIONS MORE
CONSISTENT OBJECTIVE AND ALIGN
WITH THE STATE'S CLIMATE AND
HOUSING GOALS. PREVIOUS THERE
BEEN PREVIOUS OUR CONCERNS
ABOUT THIS BILL DEALING WITH
HOUSING AND FORMER TOXIC SITES
EVEN THOUGH THE SITES HAVE BEEN
CLEANED UP FOR RESIDENTIAL USE
WE RESOLVED THAT IN THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE BY
WERE COMPLETELY REMOVING THOSE
PROVISIONS THEY ARE NO LONGER
PART OF THIS LEGISLATION. WE
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS TO ASSURE THAT
EXEMPTIONS ARE USED TO MEET
HOUSING NEEDS IN A WAY THAT
COMPLIMENTS CURRENT CLIMATE AND
OTHER ENVIRONMENTAL GOALS AND
ONLY ON SITES THAT ARE CLEARLY
SAFE BOTH FOR WORKERS AND FOR
RESIDENTS. THIS BILL WILL
ENSURE THAT WELL PLAN HOUSING
EFFORTS YOUR TRANSIT IN JOBS
WILL NOT BE UNNECESSARILY
DELAYED. AB TWENTY THREE TWENTY
THREE IS SUPPORTED BY A VERY
DIVERSE GROUP OF HOUSING
ADVOCATES DEVELOPERS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS PLANNERS AND
ENVIRONMENTAL ADVOCATES. THERE
IS NO KNOWN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL AT THIS POINT AND THE
BUILDING TRADES HAVE MOVED FROM
AN OPPOSE POSITION TO A SUPPORT
IF AMENDED POSITION. REQUESTING
ONLY THE ADDITION OF A SINGLE
COMMA THAT WAS AN IMPORTANT LEE
DELETED IN THE LEGISLATION.
THOMAS TO ABBA COMMA TO THE
BILL- IT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE-
DO A SUPPORT THE LEGISLATION
WITHOUT I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MS
FREEMAN. SEE NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM CARPOOL OVER
THE ROLE. ZARA VOTE. ALL MEMBER
SERVICE OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE ZARA VOTE. THE CLERK WILL
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY
THREE THOSE ZERO THAT MEASURE
PASSES. THIS IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX. AB NINETEEN SEVENTY
NINE CORKERY. SOME OF YOUR
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN AN
ACCOLADE THE FOSTER YOUTH IS
FREE MANY MAKE IT ALL BUT THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THE FIRST-STATES TO OPT INTO THE FEDERAL
OPPORTUNITY TO CREATE AN
EXTENDED FOSTER YOUTH PROGRAM
IN TWO THOUSAND TEN. THE
EXPANSION OF SERVICES HAS SHOWN
NUMEROUS BENEFITS OVER PAST
DECADES FROM IMPROVEMENTS IN
EDUCATION AND EMPLOYMENT TO
REDUCTIONS IN PREGNANCY AND
INCARCERATION HOWEVER THE DATA
STILL SHOWS AND UNFORTUNATELY
TRANSITION TRANSITION AGE
FOSTER YOUTH ARE STILL FACING
TREMENDOUS BARRIERS WHEN IT
COMES TO HOUSING PARTICULARLY
IN OUR HIGH RENT AREAS. 35% OF
OSTER YOUTH WHO BY THE WAY OUR
OUR CHILDREN WE HAVE US AS A
STATE ASSUMED RESPONSIBILITY
FOR THESE CHILDREN 35% OF THEM
REPORT EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS WHILE THEY'RE
ACTIVELY ENROLLED IN EXTENDED
FOSTER CARE THAT IS
UNACCEPTABLE AB NINETEEN
SEVENTY NINE WILL HELP OUR
TRANSITION AGE YOUTH ACCESS THE
HOUSING THE NEED BY
STREAMLINING THE APPROVAL
PROCESS REPLACEMENTS INCREASING
HOUSING OPTIONS IMPROVING
PLACEMENTS ABILITY FOR YOUTH.
AND REQUIRING COUNTIES TO
REGULARLY EVALUATE THEIR
AVAILABLE HOUSING RESOURCES THE
BILL HAS A PRO A BROAD
COALITION IN SUPPORT AND
THERE'S NO OPPOSITION AND I
WILL JUST SAY THAT ONCE THESE
YOUNG PEOPLE BECOME HOMELESS
THEY HAVE A MUCH HIGHER CHANCE
OF COURSE OF MOVING INTO
ADDICTION ARE INTO OUR PRISON
SYSTEM WHICH ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY MADE UP OF
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH THE
INVESTMENTS THAT WE MAKE NOW
PAGE EVIDENT WITHIN AND- IF YOU
DON'T CARE ABOUT THE HUMAN
CAPITAL THINK ABOUT THE
ECONOMIC CAPITAL OF HAVING TO
SPEND A LOT FOR THE HOUSE.
THESE PEOPLE IN PRISON AND DEAL
WITH DRUG ADDICTION AND OTHER
ISSUES WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THERE IS
FOR. C. NOTICED DEBATE ON THE
AT CARPOOL OPEN THE- ESERVER-
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT AYE SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSES THIS IS
FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHT. AB
TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT BY MS I
GEAR CURRY. COVERAGE ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AGUIAR-CURRY AN
ACCOLADE THE PUBLIC MEETINGS IS
AGUIAR-CURRY THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB TWENTY TWENTY EIGHT
IS A TRANSPARENCY AND
ACCOUNTABILITY MEASURE THE
CLOSES LOOPHOLES IN THE BIG
BECAME OPEN MEETING ACT. THIS
BILL REINFORCES EXISTING LAW BY
REQUIRING THAT BACKGROUND
DOCUMENTS FOR PUBLIC MEETINGS
BE POSTED ONLINE THE SAME DAY
THEY ARE PROVIDED TO MEMBERS OF
THE STATE BODY OR FORTY EIGHT
HOURS PRIOR TO THE MEETING
WHICHEVER SOONER THIS BILL ALSO
REQUIRES THAT THE PUBLIC HAS
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
COMMENT ON ANY LISTED AGENDA
ITEM DURING A MEETING. THE
COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND
OTHER RECENT EMERGENCIES LIKE
WILD FIRES AND FLOOD HAVE
PUSHED PUBLIC MEETINGS
INCREASINGLY ON ONLINE WE MUST
UPHOLD AND STRENGTHENS STATE
TRANSPARENCY REQUIREMENTS TO
PROVIDE THE PUBLIC WITH
INFORMATION AND THE ABILITY TO
COMMENT I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MS SAGER
CURRY SEEING NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE. QUIRK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. THAT A VOTE ON MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
OF. THE DESIRE TO VOTE. CLERK
WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF A I
SIXTY SEVEN NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
THIS IS FILE
ITEM TWELVE. AB TWENTY FIFTY
TWO BY MISTER O'DONNELL.
CORPORATE SOME LEGAL TWENTY
FIFTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
O'DONNELL ANOTHER SNACK LATER
PEOPLE INSTRUCTION. MR
O'DONNELL THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AB TWENTY FIFTY TWO
PROVIDES FLEXIBILITY FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO MEET MINIMUM
INSTRUCTIONAL DAY REQUIREMENTS
BY ADDING MINUTES TO REMAINING
INSTRUCTIONAL DAYS IN THE
SCHOOL YEAR. EMERGENCY SUCH AS
WILDFIRES FLOODING AND OTHER
CONDITIONS PREVENT SCHOOL
DISTRICTS FOR MEETING MINIMUM
TIME REQUIREMENTS. LOCAL SCHOOL
ADMINISTRATORS NEED FLEXIBILITY
IN ORDER TO MAKE UP LOST TIME
DUE TO ON SCHEDULE SCHOOL
CLOSURES. IT IS CRITICAL THAT A
MINIMUM STANDARD OF
INSTRUCTIONAL TIME CONTINUE TO
BE MET BUT WE MUST OFFER SCHOOL
DISTRICTS THE OPTION TO MAKE UP
THAT LOST TIME IN A WAY THAT
WORKS BEST FOR THE NEEDS OF A
LOCAL SCHOOL COMMUNITY I ASKED
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISTER DAHLE MISTER KILEY IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I'M JOINTLY OFFERING
THIS MEASURE BECAUSE IT MAKES
AN ABUNDANCE OF SENSE THAT IN
THE- DIFFICULT CIRCUMSTANCE OF
HAVING TO MAKE UP. LAW SCHOOL
TIME WE SHOULD IN POWER THE
LEADERS OF THE AFFECTED
DISTRICTS AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE
TO FIGURE OUT THE BEST WAY TO
DO SO. I ENCOURAGE AND I'VE A-
THINGS KILEY. SEE NO ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION DEBATE. CLARK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE.
RESERVE AN ALMOND VOTE ARE TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS VOTER ART OF A.
THE CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE
OF A I SEVENTY NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS THIS IS
FILE ITEM FOURTEEN AB TWENTY
SIXTY. HI MR HOLDEN CORKERY.
SOMEBODY WILL TWENTY SIXTY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER HOLDEN AND
ACKERLEY THE DRINKING WATER MR
HOLDING. THANK YOU ASSIST I
RISE TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SIXTY CURRENT LAW
ESTABLISHES A CONTENT STANDARD
OF POINT 25% LEAD FOR PLUMBING
FIXTURES TO COMPLY WITH THE
LEAD FREE STANDARD. LAST YEAR
THE NSF INTERNATIONAL TESTED
FIVE HUNDRED FAUCETS THAT MET
THE CALIFORNIA LEAD CONTENT
STANDARD AND FOUND THAT 25% OF
THE FAUCETS TESTED. LEAST
NOTICEABLE AMOUNTS OF LEAD. AB
TWENTY SIXTY WOULD ESTABLISH A
LEAD LEACHING PERFORMANCE
STANDARD TO COMPLY AS LEAD
FREE. IT WOULD REQUIRE IN TO
USE FIXTURES TO LEAD TO LESS
THAN ONE MILLIGRAM PER LITER
LED. WE ALL EXPECT THE WATER WE
DRINK WILL KEEP US HEALTHY AND
NOT MAKE A SICK CALIFORNIA HAS
BEEN WORKING TO REDUCE
RESIDENTS EXPOSURE TO LEAD YET
LET IS STILL LEASING INTO OUR
DRINKING WATER THROUGH FAUCETS
AND FIXTURES. THIS BILL REQUIRE
ALL FAUCETS AND FIXTURES LEACH
AS LITTLE AS POSSIBLE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER HOLDEN. SEE
NOTE DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE ADAM. QUIRK LIBERAL. ZERO
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS OF DESIRE TO VOTE.
ALL. CLICK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE
ABOUT I SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS WE ARE
AT FILE ITEM NUMBER FIFTEEN.
THIS IS MISTER BIGELOW SADDAM
FILE ITEM FIFTEEN AB TWENTY
SEVENTY SIX CORPORATE SOME AGO
TWENTY SEVENTY SIX BY SUMMER
BIGELOW AN ACCOLADE PUBLIC
LANDS. MR BIGELOW YOU MAY OPEN
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVENTY
SIX IS A BILL THAT WILL ADDRESS
WILDFIRE MITIGATION IN REGIONS
OF OUR STATE THE COULD BE MOST
IMPACTED BY WILDFIRE THIS
MEASURE WILL ENSURE THAT ALL
STATE PARKS HAVE A WILDFIRE
PREVENTION STRATEGY IN PLACE
WITH THIS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
MISS BIGELOW. C. NOTICE KASHER
DEBATE ON THE ITEM CLICK OVER
THERE ALL. ZARA VOTE ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE.
CLARK WELL CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT I SEVENTY NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES. THIS IS
FILE ITEM NINETEEN. AB. TWENTY
ONE TWENTY SIX. BY MISTER
O'DONNELL. THE CLERK WILL READ.
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY ONE TWENTY
SIX BY SUMMER ROLLED ON ONE
ACCOLADES SCHOOL FACILITIES. MR
O'DONNELL YOU MAIL BUT- THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB TWENTY
ONE TWENTY SIX PROMOTES THE
SAFETY AND WELL BEING OF
STUDENTS AND SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
DURING EMERGENCIES BY REQUIRING
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION TO DEVELOP A WEBSITE
AND APP BASE FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO REPORT THIS
INFORMATION. ESTABLISHING A
STATEWIDE UP TODAY DATABASE
WHICH SCHOOLS OF WHICH SCHOOLS
ARE CLOSED ON HOW STUDENTS ARE
BEING SERVED INCLUDING PLANS
FOR RIGHT PROVIDING MEALS AN
INSTRUCTION. TO STUDENTS DURING
CLOSURES WILL HELP US BETTER
RESPOND TO FUTURE EMERGENCY
CLOSURES I ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
O'DONNELL SAY NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM. LOCAL OF
MORAL. ALL MEMBERS OF. DESIGNED
ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTE IN
THIS ARE VOTE. WE ARE. THE
CLERK WILL. CLOSE ROLL TIDE OF
OUR I SEVENTY NO ZERO. THAT
MEASURE PASSES. FILE ITEM
TWENTY THREE AB TWENTY ONE
NINETY EIGHT BY MISTER TANK
CORKERY. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
ONE NINETY EIGHT BY SIMPLY
REVERTING ACCOLADE UNCLAIMED
PROPERTY. MISTER TECH. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AB TWENTY
ONE NINETY EIGHT STREAMLINES
THE UNCLAIMED PROPERTY PROGRAM
TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
CALIFORNIANS TO GET THEIR MONEY
BACK AT THE TIME WITH GREAT
ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTY WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE CAN GET
THE MONEY THAT THEIR OLD BACK
AS SOON AS POSSIBLE WITHOUT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FIVE. THEY
WERE STAYING SENIOR DISCUSSION
OF IT ON THE ITEM QUIRK LIBERAL.
ALL MEMBERS. DESIRE VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTE. DESIRABLE.
QUIRK
WELL CLOSE ROLE I SEVENTY NO
ZERO THAT MEASURE PASSES.
THIS
IS FILE ITEM NUMBER TWENTY SIX
AB TWENTY TO SEVENTY ONE BY MR
GABRIEL QUICKLY ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY TO SEVENTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GABRIEL ACCOLADE
THE COURTS. THE SHOULD GABRIEL
YOU MAY OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I AM
PLEASED TODAY TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY TO SEVENTY ONE WHICH
WILL STRENGTHEN THESE SARGENT
SHRIVER CIVIL COUNCIL ACT WHICH
PROVIDES LOW LEGAL
REPRESENTATION TO LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS IN HIGH STAKES BUT
CIVIL MATTERS IMPACTING BASIC
HUMAN NEEDS SUCH AS CHILD
CUSTODY DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IN
FICTION PROCEEDINGS. SOME OF
YOU MAY RECALL THAT LAST YEAR
THE GOVERNOR SIGNED INTO LAW A.
B. THREE THIRTY BIPARTISAN
LEGISLATION WHICH IS
SIGNIFICANTLY EXPANDED THE
SHRIVER PROGRAM SO THAT MORE
CALIFORNIANS CAN BE ASSURED OF
MEANINGFUL ACCESS TO JUSTICE
THROUGH OUR LEGAL SYSTEM. THIS
BILL EXPANDS THE STRIVE A
PROGRAM IN TWO IMPORTANT WAYS
FIRST THIS LEGISLATION HELPS TO
ENSURE THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS
REGARDLESS OF THEIR IMMIGRATION
STATUS ARE ELIGIBLE FOR LEGAL
ASSISTANCE PROVIDED UNDER THE
SHRIVER PROGRAM ONE OF THE
FIRST CASES THAT I HANDLED AS A
YOUNG ATTORNEY WAS TO HELP AND
UNDOCUMENTED MOTHER SECURE A
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE RESTRAINING
ORDER. IT WAS A REALLY EYE
OPENING EXPERIENCE FOR ME FOR
HOW VULNERABLE THIS POPULATION
IS AND HOW IMPORTANT IT IS THAT
THEY ARE PROVIDED WITH LEGAL
REPRESENTATION IN THESE HIGH
STAKE MATCH. SO YOU CAN SEE
FULL ACCESS TO THIS. THE SECOND.
IS THAT RIGHT. COURT TO CALL
AND MAKE AVAIL CERTAIN. RELATED
TO FICTION. SEEDINGS INCLUDING
AN AND ON LAW THAT PROCEED.
THIS IS A SO IN FOR THAT ARE A
SERVICE PER IN THE LOCAL GO IN
NY SO THAT THEY CAN WORK
HOMELESS PREVENTION AND TARGET
THEIR INTER INTERVENTIONS WILL
ALLOW FOR DATA DRIVEN POLICY
MAKING. AND TO BARN ANALOGY
FROM ONE OF SUPPORT LETTERS
TRYING TO PREVENT HOMELESSNESS
AND DISPLACEMENT WITHOUT THE
DATA THAT WOULD BE COLLECTED IN
THIS BILL IS SIMILAR TO ASKING
AN EPIDEMIOLOGIST TO DEVELOP A
PLAN TO FIGHT A VIRAL DISEASE
WITHOUT ADEQUATE TESTING AND
MAPPING. THIS IS A TIME OF
TREMENDOUS ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTY
IN THIS BILL WILL HELP TO
EXPAND ACCESS TO JUSTICE TO
PROTECT OUR MOST VULNERABLE AND
ALLOW OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
RESPOND TO HOMELESSNESS
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISS GABRIEL
SAYING NO DISCUSSION DEBATE ON
THE ITEM. OR CALL THE ROLL. IS
THAT ABOUT ALL MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE VOTE. ALL MEMBERS THE.
DESIRE TO VOTE. WELL CLOSE ALL
TIE THE VOTE I CITY SO NO FOR
THE MEASURE PASSES. THIS FILE
ITEM. TWENTY SEVEN. THIS IS
FILE ITEM TWENTY SEVEN AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY TWO BY MISTER
MCCARTY CORKERY SOME LEGAL
TWENTY TWO EIGHTY TWO BY SOME
MCCARTY CONFERENCE MR MCCARTY
THANK YOU THAT MISTER MEMBER
AND SPEAKERS. LOOTING AMONG OUR
CALL TO THE BEEN AT SIGNIFICANT
ESPECIALLY DOWN COVER. HUNDREDS
OF THE OF COLLEGE STUDENTS
BETWEEN THAT COMMUNICABLE AS
YOU SEE AND SEE IF YOU'RE
ELIGIBLE FOR CALPERS BENEFITS
BUT DO NOT KNOW IT. THIS BILL
WOULD CREATE A PROGRAM TO HELP
INCREASE OUT REACH THROUGH TEXT
MESSAGING AND EMAILING STUDENTS
NOTIFYING THEM ABOUT
ELIGIBILITY FOR CALPERS. NO
I'VE NOTE NO VOTES AND ASK YOUR
RIVAL THANK YOU. THERE WAS
RECORD. SENIOR DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM CLERK WILL
OPEN THE ROLE. DESIRE TO VOTE
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS OUT OF A.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
WORK WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT
I SIXTY NINE NO ZERO THAT
MEASURE PASSES.
MEMBERS THIS IS
FILE ITEM THIRTY ONE. AB TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY ONE. COOKERY.
SOME AGO TWENTY THREE SEVENTY
ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN
ANOTHER SNACK LATER CLIMATE
CHANGE THIS FRIEDMAN. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AS WE
ALL KNOW AND HOPEFULLY ALL OF
KNOWLEDGE CLIMATE CHANGE IS
GOING TO LEAD TO VERY DRAMATIC-
FAX HERE IN CALIFORNIA NOW ALL
OF THEM BAD. AND IT'S GONNA
REQUIRE A LOT OF INVESTMENTS IN
RESILIENCY AND IN MITIGATION
AND IN RESPONSE FROM THE
LEGISLATURE AND FROM THE STATE.
BUT THE QUESTION IS WHO'S GOING
TO LEASE THOSE THAT THOSE
EFFORTS WHERE DO WE PUT OUR
DOLLARS WHEN IT COMES TO
CLIMATE CHANGE WHEN IT COMES TO
SHORELINE RETREAT WHEN IT COMES
TO SEA LEVEL RISE TO WILD FIRE.
HOW O WE DECIDE WHAT PROJECTS
TO PRIORITIZE WILL CALIFORNIA
WE HAVE A WEALTH OF RESOURCES
IN TERMS OF OUR NATIONAL LABS
AND OUR UNIVERSITIES. WHAT AB
TWENTY THREE SEVENTY ONE DOES
IS IT CREATES A TASK FORCE MADE
UP OF SCIENTISTS TO MAKE
EXACTLY THOSE KINDS OF
RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND TO THE GOVERNOR
AND TWO OF THE ALL STATE
AGENCIES SO THAT ANY
INVESTMENTS THAT WE MAKE IN
DEALING WITH CLIMATE CHANGE
RESPONSE A RESILIENCY. IS MADE
BY SCIENTISTS TO STUDY THIS
VERY THING SO THAT WE KNOW THAT
WE'RE MAKING INVESTMENTS IN THE
RIGHT PLACE WITH THIS BILL AS
FAR AS WE KNOW HAS NO
OPPOSITION. I THINK IT'S A
COMMON SENSE WAY FOR US TO
PRIORITIZE PROJECTS AND
SPENDING HIM WITH THAT I
REQUEST WE REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MS
FREEMAN. SENIORDISCUSSION-
BAIT FOR CLUB THE ROLE. OUT OF
ALL MEMBERS OF DESIRED OF A.
ALL MEMBERS OF. THE DESIRE TO
VOTE. QUIRK WOOL CLOTHES ROLE
TYLER I FIFTY SEVEN. THOSE TEN
THAT MEASURE PASSES. WE ARE
GOING TO ALLOW US FRIEDMAN TO
TAKE UP HER ADDITIONAL ITEM
THIS IS FILE FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIXTY TWO. FILE ITEM SIXTY TWO
A. B. THIRTY TWO SEVENTY NINE.
CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
TWO SEVENTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN
ACTUALLY ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY.
MS FREEMAN THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS ONCE AGAIN
WE'RE BACK TO TALKING ABOUT
SECRET UNPRECEDENTED HOUSING
CRISIS. IT'S ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT THAT WELL PLANNED
PROJECTS ARE ABLE TO MOVE
QUICKLY THROUGH THE APPROVAL
PROCESS THE SEQUEL PROCESS IS
IMPORTANT AND IT'S SOMETHING
THAT I VERY MUCH RESPECT BUT
SOMETIMES IT CREATES
UNNECESSARY DELAYS TO BREAKING
GROUND ON HOUSING AND OTHER
TYPES OF LAND USE PROJECTS. AB
THIRTY TWO SEVENTY NINE
ADDRESSES COMMON DELAYS IN
LITIGATION OVERSEE C<c.cyan></c>
ACTIONS PROMOTE SWIFTER AND
MORE EFFICIENT RESOLUTION OF
LAWSUITS REGARDING ALL
PROJECTS. THE BILL WILL CREATE
MEANINGFUL CHANGE THE SUPER
PROCESS WILL STILL MAINTAINING
ROBUST ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTIONS IN PEOPLE'S RIGHT
TO FILE LAWSUITS ON BEHALF OF
SEEK WORK. THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS ADDRESS
THE FOLLOWING OPPOSITION
CONCERNS THE DEADLINE FOR
REQUESTING COURT HEARINGS IS
TOO SHORT. THE CURRENT NINETY
DATE- OF DAY DEADLINE HAS BEEN
RESTORED INTO THE BILL. A
REMAND PRIOR TO JUDGMENT MAY
PREVENT THE COURT FROM ENTERING
THE FINAL JUDGMENT AMENDMENT
STATE A REMAND SHALL NOT
PREVENT A FINAL JUDGMENT. A
REMAND MAY AFFECT PARTY'S RATES
TO APPEAL THE JUDGMENT
AMENDMENTS STATE PARTIES APPEAL
RIGHTS ARE PRESERVED. A REMAND
MAY COMPROMISE THE PREVAILING
PARTIES ABILITY TO RECOVER
ATTORNEY FEES AMENDMENT STATE
THAT DETERMINATION OF ATTORNEYS
FEES IS NOT AFFECTED. I
APPRECIATE THE OPPOSITION'S
PERSPECTIVE AND I'VE ATTEMPTED
TO UNDERSTAND AND ADDRESS THE
ISSUES THAT THEY BROUGHT TO OUR
ATTENTION NOW WHEN IT COMES TO
SEE GROWING DOING ANYTHING TO
TRY TO. MAKE A SEQUEL WORK
BETTER IT'S GOING TO BE A LOT
OF PUSH AND PULL THE CERTAINLY
A LOT OF STAKEHOLDERS AND I
BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE GOT TO BE
IN A POSITION OF HAVING
COMPROMISED. AND WHAT THIS BILL
IS TRYING TO DO IS TO TAKE ALL
OF THOSE CONCERNS SERIOUSLY AND
TO. FOSTER AND TO BE A VEHICLE
FOR THAT KIND OF COMPROMISE SO
THAT WE NO LONGER HAVE AS MANY
UNNECESSARY DELAYS- AND
PROJECTS WE'RE REALLY COMING TO
A RESOLUTION AND HAVING
DEVELOPERS ADDRESS COMMUNITIES
CONCERNS SHOULD BE THE PRIMARY
GOAL. I WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
ON THIS BILL AS IT MOVES TO THE
PROCESS- WE HAVE A STILL HAVE
TO GO TO THE SENATE AND I'M
THAT WILL BE TAKING MORE
MOMENTS WE ARE IN CONVERSATION
WITH ALL OF THE STAKEHOLDERS
AND WITH ALL OF THE OPPOSITION.
AND I KNOW THAT THEY BELIEVE
THAT WE ARE SERIOUS TRYING
SERIOUSLY ADDRESSED CONCERNS
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO I
WOULD ASK FOR YOUR IBM TODAY TO
ALLOW THESE VERY IMPORTANT.
DISCUSSIONS TO CONTINUE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ALEX. THANK YOU
MS FREEMAN. SEEING THEIR-
DEBATE. CLUB ALL. SACRAMENTO
MEMBERS WERE ARE TO ALL MEMBERS
THE- RESERVE. FOR TWELVE.
CLOSER ALL TYLER AS FIFTY EIGHT
KNOWS TO. THAT MEASURE PASS.
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER THIRTY
TWO AB TWENTY THREE EIGHTY
EIGHT BY MISTER BERMAN CORKERY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY EIGHT BY SOMEONE OR
BERMAN ACCOLADE PUBLIC POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION. MR BERMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
COLLEAGUES AS CAMPUS IS A
PHYSICALLY CLOSE AND MOVED TO
ONLINE CLASSES DURING THE CO
NINETEEN CRISIS THE EXISTING
BASIC NEEDS CHALLENGES THAT
STUDENTS FACE HAVE BECOME EVEN
MORE PRONOUNCED IN URGENTLY
REQUIRE ACTION UNDER AB TWENTY
THREE EIGHTY EIGHT COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WOULD DEVELOP A
DOCUMENT THAT CLEARLY LISTS ALL
ON AND OFF CAMPUS BASIC NEEDS
SERVICES AND RESOURCES THAT
WILL BE MADE AVAILABLE TO
STUDENTS ONLINE. CAMPUSES WOULD
ALSO BE ENCOURAGED TO DESIGNATE
A BASIC NEEDS COORDINATOR AND
ESTABLISH A BASIC NEEDS CENTER
TO PROVIDE A SINGLE POINT OF
CONTACT DURING THESE
UNPRECEDENTED TIME AND
CHALLENGING TIMES COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS ACROSS ALL
CAMPUSES NEED OUR SUPPORT NOW
MORE THAN EVER I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AND I HAVE A- THANK
YOU. SEE NO RECESSION. THE
CLERK WILL OPEN THE RAW.
RESERVE VOTE ON MEMBERS VOTERS
ARE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS NOTICE
OUT OF A. QUIRK WELL CLOSE ROLL
TIDE OF A I SEVEN ONE NO ZERO
THAT MEASURE PASSES. THIS IS
FILE FORTY AB TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN BY MISTER
RODRIGUEZ. THIS IS AB TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN RODRIGUEZ THE
CORPORATE. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FIVE THIRTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RODRIGUEZ AND ACTUALLY
THE WORKPLACE SAFETY MISTER
RODRIGUEZ. AB TWENTY FIVE
THIRTY SEVEN REQUIRE HOSPITALS
PROVIDE PERSONAL PROTECTIVE
EQUIPMENT TO EMPLOYEES TO
PROVIDE DIRECT PATIENT CARE. IT
WOULD ALSO REQUIRE THESE
EMPLOYERS TO MAINTAIN A SIX
MONTH STOCKPILE OF AN EXPIRED
PP. AND PROVIDE A NUMBER TOWARD
A CAL OSHA UPON REQUEST. FROM
MY HEALTH CARE WORKERS TREATING
PATIENTS WITH INFECTIOUS
DISEASES ARE EXPOSED TO THE
HIGHEST RISK OF INFECTION
BECAUSE OF THE CLOSE FREQUENT
CONTACT WITH PATIENTS. THIS
BILL IS NECESSARY TO PROTECT
THE HEALTH SAFETY AND WELFARE.
OF OUR HEALTHCARE WORKERS THAT
IS LITERALLY A MATTER OF LIFE
AND DEATH. AS OF JUNE THIRD
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENTS OF
REPORTED OVER TEN THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED NINETEEN CONFER POG
POSITIVE CASES AND HEALTHCARE
WORKERS. AND SIXTY FOUR DOES
STATEWIDE. PLEASED YOU MAY IN
PROTECTING CAN SO WORK. ARE
STRUCK OUT FOR OUR GOAL. THANK
RODRIGUEZ DOCTOR YOUR IN REAR
OF THE- MICHAEL RIGHT. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS
I JUST WANT TO SAY I SUPPORT
ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT THE CONCEPT
OF ASSURING OUR HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM IS MORE PREPARE FOR A
PANDEMIC BY HAVING ADEQUATE PP
ON HAND AND I WILL SUPPORT THE
BILL TODAY I DO HAVE SOME
CONCERNS TO RAISE THOUGH NUMBER
ONE HOW WAS THE SIX MONTHS
DETERMINE THAT THAT TIME FOR.
AND WHAT IS THAT GOING TO MEAN
OF GOING FORWARD- I THINK THE
EFFECTIVE DATE OF THE PROPOSAL-
MAY MEAN THAT IT'S THEIR BE
CHALLENGES FOR OTHERS TRYING TO
GET PP I LOOK AT PP AS A
PREVENTATIVE SO IF WE HAVE
NURSING HOMES DENTAL OFFICES
AGRICULTURALWORKERS WHO ARE
DESPERATELY NOW TRYING TO GET
PP TO KEEP PEOPLE OUT OF
HOSPITALS. AND WE'RE ALL
COMPETE EVERYONE'S COMPETING
FOR THAT I JUST WANT TO INSURE
THAT THAT WE CONTINUE TO WORK
ON THIS HAVE AN ADEQUATE HAVE
AN ADEQUATE TIME THAT MAKES
SENSE AND MAKE SURE THAT
EVERYBODY IS PROTECTED BECAUSE
WE WANT TO KEEP PEOPLE OUT OF
HOSPITALS I'M WORRIED THAT IF
WE'RE NOT CAREFUL HOSPITALS
COULD POTENTIALLY I HATE TO USE
THIS WORD HORDE PP. AND WHAT WE
DESPERATELY NEED TO GET INTO
OUR AGRICULTURAL WORKERS AND SO
MANY OTHERS OUT THERE TO
PREVENT THEM FROM GETTING INTO
A HOSPITAL SO I LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR ON THIS
THING. THANK YOU DOCTOR WHAT.
SAY NO ADDITIONAL THE OR DEBATE
MR REID YOU MAKE. ARE
STRUGGLING ARNOLD YOU. OUR CLUB
ROLL. IS THERE A VOTE ON
MEMBERS VOTERS ABOUT. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
CLERK WILL CLOSE ROLE. TITLEIST
FIFTY TWO DOES TEN. THAT
MEASURE PASSES THIS IS FILE
ITEM FORTY TWO AB TWENTY FIVE
NINETY TWO BY MISS GARCIA
CORPORATE ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FIVE NINETY TWO BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CRISTINA GARCIA ACTUALLY
TO HUMAN REMAINS IN MAKING A
PROBATIONER FOR. IS GARCIA
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY
TWO WOULD GIVE CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS ANOTHER OPTION FOR
THE REMAINS. WHEN THEY HAVE
HAVE. IT ALLOWS INDIVIDUALS TO
BE ORGANICALLY BE COMPOSED THE
FAMILY MADE THEN USE THE
REMAINS AT THE SOIL AMENDMENT
TO A PLANT A TREE. IN
REMEMBRANCE OF THEIR LOVED ONES
TREES ARE GOOD COVERS OF THE
AIR THEY HELP ABSORB CARBON AND
OTHER PARTICULAR MATTER. OFTEN
THE ERROR I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MR
GARCIA. SEEING NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM. THE CALL
THE ROLL. DESIRABLE ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS OUT OF A. ALL MEMBERS OF
THE DESIRE TO VOTE. OR CALL.
CLOSE ROLL TIDE BUT I SIXTY
ONE. NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
THIS IS FILE ITEM. FIFTY THREE.
AB TWENTY NINE NINETY CARILLO
SO MIDDLE TWENTY NINE NINETY BY
SOME WE'VE EVER SEEN A GARCIA
AN ACCOLADE A CHARTER SCHOOLS
MS GARCIA THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS AB TWENTY NINE
NINETY WOULD- PROVIDED SOME
ADDITIONAL OVERSIGHT TO HOME
SCHOOL CHARTERS AND INSURE
PROPER USE OF OUR TAX DOLLARS.
I INTRODUCED AB TWENTY NINE
NINETY AND RESPONSE TO
INVESTIGATIVE JOURNALISTS- THAT
I'M COVERED UP ON GOING AND
APPROPRIATE USED BY HOMES WITH
CHARTERS THE PUBLIC SCHOOL FUND
THROUGH THEN CON. LET ME OF
ACTIVITIES OFFERED INFLICT
THROUGH EVENT INCLUDE THIS THE
LAND. LABEL LAD. HORSEBACK
RIDING LEFT. MEDIEVAL TIMES GET.
THE WILL TAKE IT AND TOOK JUST
A- IT'S IMPORTANT TO PROTECT
THE PRINTER TO HOME THEIR- IT'S
ALSO IMPORTANT OUR TAX ACT. ON
PROPER ACTIVE. EDUCATION ACTIVE
FOR OUR- WE BEEN WORKING THE
BILL HAS BEEN A MAY ALONG THE
WAY TO ADDRESS UP. CONCERNS
WORKING TO WORK WITH THEM. AB
TWENTY NINE NINETY REQUIRE
STUDENTS- IT ROLLED IN NON
CLASSROOM BASED HARDER TO HAVE
THEIR SIGN TEACHER REVEAL
GUARANTEE THAT ACTIVITIES
EDUCATION ON THE APPROPRIATE
FOR THE STUDENTS. ADDITIONALLY
AB TWENTY NINE NINETY WOULD
REQUIRE THAT THE CHARTER
SCHOOLS THE MADE ITS POLICY AND
PROCEDURES RELATING TO VENDOR
CONTRACT. APPROVAL TO CHARTER
AUTHORIZES CONSIDERATION TO
THEIR- TO THEIR CHARTER
AUTHORIZES. KEEPING CONTROL
LOCALLY I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MS
GARCIA MR KILEY YOUR RECOGNIZED
IN THE REAR CHAMBER. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I THIS IS A BILL
THAT GENERATED A LOT OF PUBLIC
INTEREST AND EVERY MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC HAS THE RIGHT I TO
COME BEFORE A COMMITTEE OF THIS
BODY AND TO- PRESENT THEIR VIEW
ON A BILL TO LAWMAKERS- WITH
THIS PARTICULAR BILL I'M MANY
PEOPLE WERE DENIED THAT RIGHT
AND IT WASN'T OUT OF ANY ILL
INTENTIONED IT WAS JUST ONE OF
THE FIRST TIMES TRYING THE
REMOTE ACCESS. TECHNOLOGY AND
THERE WAS AN ISSUE WITH THE
VENDOR AND SO A LOT OF FOLKS
WHO WANTED TO SAY THEIR
POSITION ON THE BILL- WE'RE NOT
ABLE TO AND- AFTER THE HEARING
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY FIVE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC ROAD INTO
THE I CAN COMMITTEE I SAID.
THAT THEY WANTED. WE'RE NOT
ABLE TO ANSWER THEY WERE THE
AND TO APPEAR IN POP ON THE BUT
THE EDGE COMMITTEE AND THE
STATE THEIR NAME POSITION I'D
LIKE TO ASK PERMISSION TO TAKE
A COUPLE MINUTES TO READ THE
NAMES RIGHT FROM THE. APARTMENT
THE REID REQUIRES YOU NAY. CAN
MISTER CALDERON PER. OBJECT TO
YOU KNOW CONSENT. MISTER
CROWLEY NEVER UNANIMOUS CONSENT
THERE WAS A OBJECTION FROM THE
FLOOR YOU MAY PROCEED. I WOULD
AT LEAST LIKE PERMISSION TO
HAVE THE NAMES EACH ONE OF THEM
PRINTED INDIVIDUALLY IN THE
JOURNAL. THAT ALSO REQUIRES
UNANIMOUS CONSENT WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE NAMES WILL BE
READ INTO THE JOURNAL THANK YOU
MISTER KILEY THANK YOU AND I
WANT TO THANK ALL THE MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WHO PARTICIPATED
IN TRIED TO PARTICIPATE IN THE
HEARING ON THIS BILL THE REASON
THAT IT'S GENERATED SUCH
INTEREST IS THAT IT'S GOING TO
HURT A LOT OF FAMILIES IN
CALIFORNIA- BY LIMITING ACCESS
TO EDUCATIONAL ENRICHMENT
ACTIVITIES LIKE THE ARTS
THERE'S A FEW EXAMPLES LIKE
DISNEYLAND OR LEGO LAND CITED
THAT'S NOT WHAT THIS IS ABOUT.
THAT'S A VERY ISOLATED CASES
AND WHAT'S WORSE BECAUSE IT'S
GONNA LIMIT OPPORTUNITIES TO
PARTICIPATE AND HE'S OUT OF
SCHOOL IN RICHMOND ACTIVITIES
FOR OUR NEEDIEST STUDENTS
BECAUSE THE BILL SPECIFICALLY
WHAT'S A PROHIBITION ON
FINANCIAL INCENTIVES SO WHAT
DOES THAT MEAN IT MEANS THAT IF
THERE'S A FIELD TRIP TO A
MUSEUM OR MADE INTO WASHINGTON
DC TO WHAT ABOUT GOVERNMENT
YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO HELP KIDS
FROM POOR FAMILIES PAY THE COST
OF THAT. I WOULD HOPE THAT
SUBMITTED EVERY MEMBER OF THIS
BODY SHOULD BE AGAINST ORIGINAL.
THANK YOU MISTER KILEY. I
BELIEVE MISTER GALLAGHER IS
SEEKING RECOGNITION IN THE REAR
OF THE CHAMBER ON THE BILL MR
GALLAGHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
YES THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS AND I REALLY URGE THIS
BODY TO PUSH THE PAUSE BUTTON-
ON THIS LEGISLATION MANY THINGS
HAVE BEEN FAST TRACKED IT THIS
TIME- CERTAINLY THINGS RELATED
TO COPE WITH NINETEEN- VIRUSES
IN RESPONDING AND- AND ALL
THOSE THINGS THIS IS CLEARLY
NOT ONE OF THOSE THINGS NEED TO
BE FAST TRACKED AND AT. THE AS
THE PREVIOUS MY COLLEAGUES IN
ROCKLIN JUST POINTED OUT
THERE'S A LOT OF PROBLEMS HERE-
CERTAINLY THERE THERE MAY HAVE
BEEN ABUSES OUT THERE WITH IN
RICHMOND PROGRAMS BUT LET ME
JUST TELL YOU AS THE PARENT.
OTHER CHILD THAT IS BENEFITING
GREATLY. FROM ONE OF THESE
VENDORS THAT UTILIZES THIS
PROGRAM. HE'S PUT THE PAS BUT
YOU ARE GOING TO PUT ROADBLOCKS
IN THE WAY A REALLY GOOD
PROGRAMS LET ME JUST TELL YOU
QUICKLY A STORY OF. THE MAN
THAT I TALKED TO HEAR RECENTLY
WHO CONVEYED TO ME BECAUSE YOU
KNOW IF SOMEBODY WOULD HAVE
TOLD ME IN SCHOOL THAT HEY YOU
NEED TO LEARN MATH BECAUSE IT
WILL HELP YOU FIGURE OUT HOW
MUCH. HOW MUCH FUEL IS GOING TO
TAKE TO FILL UP THAT TANK. I
HOW MUCH THAT TANK CAN HOLD IF
SOMEBODY WOULD HAVE MADE IT
PRACTICAL FOR ME. I WOULD HAVE
LEARNED SO MUCH MORE IN SCHOOL
WELL THAT'S WHAT MANY OF THESE
PROGRAMS DO LIKE BIKING WOULD
WORKS IN MARYSVILLE CALIFORNIA.
THAT'S A WOODWORKING PROGRAM IN
THAT PROGRAM THESE KIDS LEARN
MATH SKILLS AND OTHER SKILLS
WHILE THEY'RE LEARNING HOW TO.
CRAFT TO MAKE. WOOD PROJECTS.
THEY GET TO SEE THE FRUIT OF
THEIR EDUCATION THEY GET THE
HANDS ON LEARNING. IN THESE
PROGRAMS AND THEIR VENDOR. THAT
IS GONNA BE PROHIBITED IF YOU
MOVE THIS LEGISLATION FORWARD.
AS IT IS TODAY LET ME TELL YOU
ABOUT BUTTE CORE CHARTER. I
WHICH IS AN AMAZING CORE
CHARTER- PROGRAM IN MY
DISTRICT- THAT USES A LOT OF
THE- IT HAS ISN'T. AND SO THEY
HELP KIDS GET THAT PRICE LEARN
EXPERIENCES AS MY CALL POINTED
OUT I MEAN TALKING ABOUT MONEY
THAT COULD BE USED TO HELP A
KID TRAVEL TO WASHINGTON DC OR
MAYBE RIGHT HERE TO THIS
CAPITAL TO LEARN ABOUT
GOVERNMENT- WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
PROGRAMS THAT GIVE THAT
PRACTICAL REAL WORLD EXPERIENCE
YOU'RE GOING TO BE CUTTING
THOSE OFFER YOU'RE GOING TO BE
PUTTING. UNNECESSARY BURDENS IN
THE WAY OF THESE ENRICHMENT
PROGRAM SO I JUST I REALLY URGE
YOU LET'S NOT PASSES THROUGH
TODAY LET'S PUT THE POSITIVES
THERE'S PLENTY OF TIME TO HAVE
FURTHER DISCUSSION. BOTTOM RICH
MAN PROGRAMS IN ASSURING
THERE'S PROPER- OVERSIGHT AND
ALL THOSE THINGS. BUT PUSHING
THIS BILL THROUGH WHEN IS IT IS
NOT CC- AND WHAT IS NOT
URGENT TO ANY CRISIS THAT'S IN
FRONT OF US. PLEASE DON'T DO
THAT TODAY- AND LET'S WORK
TOGETHER TO MAKE SURE THAT GOOD
PROGRAM STAY IN PLACE. THIS
THIS ABILITY TO PROVIDE FOR
THOSE ENRICHMENT PROGRAM STAYS
IN PLACE AND WE DON'T BLOCK
OFF. THINGS ARE HELPING KIDS
LIKE MY KIDS MANY FAMILIES
ACROSS THIS CUTS ACROSS THE
STATE BUT I CAN TELL YOU THE
BENEFIT AND I'VE SEEN IT WITH
MY OWN SON. GETTING THIS
EDUCATION AND LEARNING THINGS
THAT IT HAS BEEN HARDER FOR HIM
TO LEARN IN A CLASSROOM SETTING
SO I REALLY URGE YOU COLLEAGUES
TO DO TO. YOUR NOT PASS THIS
BILL THROUGH TODAY LET'S WORK
ON THIS MORE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND ATTENTION. THANK YOU
MISTER GALLAGHER. MISS SMITH
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE TODAY
BECAUSE- WHILE THE OPPOSITION
HAS EXPRESSED THAT THIS IS AN
URGENT MATTER I THINK WHAT WE
FIND IS NOT BEFORE US IS THAT
THIS IS IN FACT QUITE URGENT WE
ARE FACING A STATE BUDGET WITH
FIFTY FOUR BILLION DOLLARS IN
CUTS. AND FOR US AS A BODY TO
STAND HERE AND JUSTIFY
SOMETHING WHERE WE KNOW THERE
IS RAMPANT WASTE FRAUD AND
ABUSE ON BEHALF OF WELL
INTENTIONED HOME SCHOOL
FAMILIES IN SOME CASES BECAUSE
THEY ARE IN A SYSTEM THAT HAS
ALLOWED THIS TO GO ON FOR SO
LONG IS WRONG WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT SERVING COMMUNITIES OF
KIDS IN AN UPCOMING SCHOOL YEAR
WHERE WE KNOW THAT IF OUT OF
CLASSROOM INSTRUCTION IS
REQUIRED THESE ARE THE CHILDREN
WHO ARE SITTING. IN A BATHROOM
TAKING TURNS ON MOM'S PHONE TO
DO THEIR EDUCATIONAL
REQUIREMENTS AT A MINIMUM WHAT
OTHER CHILDREN HAVE THE BENEFIT
OF EXPLORATORY AN EXTRA
PROGRAMS THAT ARE TIED TO
MINIMUM INSTRUCTIONAL
REQUIREMENTS THIS IS ABOUT
FAIRNESS IN OUR SYSTEM THIS IS
NOT ABOUT PRIVILEGE BASED ON
CHOICES ARE CREATED BY THE THAT
THERE IS A LOOPHOLE IN THAT
SYSTEM. THIS CREATES A KOREAN
IN WHICH THERE IS FAIRNESS IN
WHICH THESE RESOURCES ARE USED
TO DEFINE EDUCATIONAL BENEFITS
BUT I KNOW A LOT OF KIDS IN
TITLE ONE SCHOOLS ACROSS THE
STATE WITH TO HAVE THE PROPERTY
HAVE A WORK TRIP TO WASHINGTON
D. THE LOT BE ABLE TO GO TO
PLAN BUT RIGHT NOW IN THIS UP
BUT YEAR I'M EVERY DAY EVERY
THAT HAVE GOING TO THOSE KID.
BEING ABLE TO BE IF BE COPIED
FREE AND EDUCATED THAT'S WHY
THIS MEASURES ARE. DAVIS WITH
MISTER MCCARTY. HAMMER WHO ARE.
THANK MISTER SPEAKER TO WANNA
CLARIFY IF YOU IN MY COLLEAGUES
STANDARD LEAD CARITA JUST
NAILED IT THE FIRST IS THAT
THERE IS THERE IS CONCERN THAT
THIS BILL DIDN'T HAPPEN AND
DEBATE IN EDGE COMMITTEE I WILL
STAY THAT'S FALSE I CAUSING THE
BILLING OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM
LOS CA. FOR NEARLY FOUR SO WE
HAVE PLANNED OF DID ON THIS
ISSUE I KNOW I WHO IS THERE I
PRESENTED THE BILL ON THERE WAS
A CHECK THE GLITCH AT THE END
SOME PEOPLE DIDN'T HAVE THE
CHANCE TO OPERATE WITH THE
EIGHTEEN T. SYSTEM BUT PLENTY
OF VOICES WERE HEARD THE VOICES
WERE HEARD AND REALLY THIS IS
ABOUT AN ISSUE FAIRNESS ATTACKS
DOLLARS THERE WAS LITERALLY
PEOPLE POSTING ONLINE SAYING
HEY CALIFORNIA FAMILIES IF YOU
DON'T KNOW ABOUT THIS LOOPHOLE.
YOU'RE MISSING OUT YOU'RE
MISSING OUT ON OPPORTUNITIES TO
SEND YOUR KIDS TO DISNEYLAND A
LEGO LAND ALL ACROSS CALIFORNIA
THIS IS ESSENTIALLY FREE MONEY
AND YOU'RE LOSING OUT AND WE'RE
SAYING YOU KNOW WHAT THERE ARE
IN RICHMOND OPPORTUNITIES BUT
THERE SHOULD BE RULES AND
PRACTICES THAT HAVE SAFEGUARDS
TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE
APPROPRIATE SO NONE OF THESE
TRIPS TO DC OR EVEN SACRAMENTO
WOULD BE EXCLUDED ALL WE'RE
SAYING IS YOU MUST GO THROUGH
PROPER CHANNELS TO HAVE YOUR
LOCAL SCHOOL AUTHORITIES-
PROCESS THAT DOCUMENTED
REGULATE TO MAKE SURE THAT WERE
PICKED PROTECTING THE TAXPAYER.
AND THE STUDENTS SO TO SAY THAT
THIS IS GOING TO SHUT DOWN-
THESE PROGRAMS IS UP INACCURATE
AND REPORT IN THIS ERA OF
COMPANY THE GONNA BE MORE OF
THIS ON. AND HOLES AND NOT LAST
WE NEED MORE OVERSIGHT AND
PICTURE TAXPAYER DOLLARS ARE.
THE RIGHT PLACE THANK YOU ASK
YOUR- THANK YOU MISS RECORD
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION
DEBATE THE I IS GUARD YOU MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU I TO THINK OF
I'D THIS BILL HAS NOT FASTER
IT'S BEEN A PRINT SINCE
FEBRUARY ANDERSON AYE LOT OF
THIS. AND WE CAN TO ENGAGE ALL
AND- THIS BILL IS NOT INTENDED
TO TAKE AWAY. EDUCATIONAL
ENRICHMENT ACTIVITIES FOR HOME
SCHOOL STUDENTS I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THEY HAVE THE THAT SUPPORT
I WANNA MAKE SURE THEY'RE
CONNECTED TO A CHARTER SCHOOL
OR TRADITIONAL SCHOOL TO A
TEACHER I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THE PARENTS HAVE THE
SUPPORT FROM THE PROFESSIONALS
OUT THERE. THIS BILL IS
INTENDED TO PROVIDE OVERSIGHT
AND REMOVE SOME OF THE ABUSE
LET ME BE CLEAR ALSO THIS BILL
IS PRETTY SENSIBLE. IT SAYS
THAT. A CHARTER SCHOOL
CLASSROOM BASED HER SCHOOL WITH
THAT LIST POLICIES AND
PROCEDURES. THE OWN CHARTER
SCHOOLS GOING TO DEVELOP THE
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES. OF HOW
THEY'RE GONNA GIVE CONTEXT TO
VENDORS. NUMBER TWO. IT SAYS
THAT THEY WILL SUBMIT THEIR
POLICY AND PROCEDURES TO WHO
EVER GAVE THEM THEIR
AUTHORIZATION. NUMBER THREE IT
SAYS THAT THE TEACHER THAT'S
TIED TO THE STUDENT IS GOING TO
GIVE THE FINAL PROVEN THING
THIS IS EDUCATIONAL AND MY
STUDENT THAT'S NEEDED. IT DOES
NOT BAN ANYTHING IT'S JUST
PROVIDES A BIT OF OVERSIGHT
INTO THE WE WELCOME THAT THE-
WE TO RESPECT THE HOMES PARENTS
AND THE RIGHT AND WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THEY HAVE ACCESS TO
THE EDUCATION OVER WHEN
ACTIVITIES. WE HAVE TAKEN EVERY
ONE OF THOSE CONVERSATIONS HERE
IS THE AND WILL CONTINUE TO DO
THAT AS IT MOVES THROUGH THE
SENATE I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN
I WILL. IN WITH THE CLERK OPEN
THE ROLE. AS ADAM ALL MEMBERS
VOTE OUT OF. ALL MEMBERS OF THE
RESERVE OF.
MS GARCIA MOVES A
CALL. MEMBERS I AM PREPARED TO
LIFT THE CALL ON. FILE ITEM ONE
SEVENTY SIX THAT'S MISTER RIVAS
IS AB. TWENTY NINE FIFTY FOUR
CARPOOL POSTS. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE ALL MEMBERS
VOTE. THE DESIRE TO VOTE.
WORK
WELL CLOSE ROLL TIDE ABOUT ICE
FORTY ONE. NO. SIXTEEN THE
MEASURE PASSES. ENVIRONMENTAL
THIS IS FILE ITEM FIFTY FOUR A.
B. THIRTY THIRTY BY MISTER
KALRA CORKERY ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTY THIRTY BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KALRA OTHERS AN ACCOLADE
RESOURCE CONSERVATION MISTER
KALRA. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. AB THIRTY THIRTY
CREATES A SET OF GOALS AND
PRINCIPLES FOR CALIFORNIA DO
ITS PART IN REVERSING THE
WORLDWIDE BIODIVERSITY IN
CLIMATE CRISES BY ADOPTING THE
GOAL OF PROTECTING 30% OF OUR
LANDS WATERS AND OCEANS FOR
CONSERVATION BY TWENTY THIRTY.
LEADING SCIENTISTS HAVE
CONCLUDED THAT PROTECTING 30%
OF ALL LANDS WATERS AND OCEAN
HABITATS IS THE BARE MINIMUM
NEEDED IN ORDER FOR US TO
SAFEGUARD CLEAN AIR CLEAN
DRINKING WATER AND FOOD CHAINS
THAT SUPPORT ALL LIFE ON EARTH.
THE U. N. MEETS THE
CONVENTIONAL BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY EARLY NEXT YEAR AB
AND WILL CONSIDER WHETHER TO
ADOPT A WORLDWIDE GOAL TO
PROTECT AT LEAST 30% OF THE
PLANET BY TWENTY THIRTY. WITH
AB THIRTY THIRTY CALIFORNIA CAN
PROVIDE INTERNATIONAL
LEADERSHIP IN THE EFFORT
TOWARDS MEETING THIS IMPORTANT
CONSERVATION GOAL AND SET AN
EXAMPLE FOR THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD. THIS BILL
PLACES IN THE STATE POLICY
COMMITMENT TO WORKING WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. LOCAL
COMMUNITIES NATIVE AMERICAN
TRIBES AND PRIVATE LANDOWNERS
TO CONSERVE NATURAL PLACES AND
RESOURCES. PROTECTING 30%
DOESN'T JUST MEAN MAKING MORE
PARKS IN REMOTE CORNERS OF OUR
STATE. IT ALSO MEANS IMPROVING
ACCESS TO NATURE FOR ALL PEOPLE
IN THE STATE. INCLUDING FOR
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND THIS BILL
COMMITS THE STATE TO DO JUST
THAT. BY PURSUING THESE
AMBITIOUS BUT ACHIEVABLE
CONSERVATION GOALS BECAUSE
STILL PREVENT THE MAJORITY OF
ANIMALS AND PLANTS ARE GOING
EXTINCT. AND CUT BIODIVERSITY
LOSS IN HALF WHICH WILL
INCREASE THE LIKELIHOOD THAT WE
CAN PRESERVE THE INTEGRITY OF
EXISTING ECOSYSTEMS. AB THIRTY
THIRTY HAS BEEN DROPPED A
DEBATE WITHIN EXISTING PROGRAMS
AND AUTHORITIES SO THERE IS
MINIMAL OR EVEN NO ADDITIONAL
COST THE STATE. BUILDING ON
PASSED LEADERSHIP A STATUTORY
COMMITMENT FROM CALIFORNIA TO
PROTECT A REPRESENTATIVE 30% OF
OUR LANDS AND WATERS IN THE
NEXT DECADE. WILL HELP ENSURE
THAT WILDLIFE CAN THRIVE. SO
THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS CAN ENJOY
THE BENEFITS THAT NATURE
PROVIDES ABOUT WILD AREAS CAN
CONTINUE TO ENHANCE THE
STRENGTH ANDWELL BEING OF OUR
STATE. AND THE PLANET
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER KALRA.
SEEING NO ADDITIONAL- I'M SORRY
MISTER GALLAGHER MISTER
GALLAGHER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED IN
THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER. YES
SIR THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
MEMBERS HE ON THIS BILL
THERE'S- AGAIN LOT OF. LOT OF
THINGS BEEN MOVING QUICKLY- BUT
YOU'LL NOTICE THAT THERE'S A
LOT OF CONSERVATION GROUPS-
WHO'VE BEEN VERY INVOLVED IN
THE CONSERVATION SPACE
INCLUDING DUCKS UNLIMITED
CALIFORNIA- WATERFOWL
ASSOCIATION- CALIFORNIA DEAR
ASSOCIATION A LOT OF GROUPS WHO
DO. WHO DO A WHOLE LOT AND PUT
A WHOLE LOT OF MONEY INTO.
CONSERVATION THEY'RE REALLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE LANGUAGE
THEY WANT TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR- ON ENSURING THAT THE
LANGUAGE PROPERLY ADDRESSES.
ABOUT CONSERVATION AND ANY ALSO
PUBLIC ACCESS- ENSURING THAT
THOSE ARE ARE ARE PART OF THE
DISCUSSION. SO A LOT OF A- AND
THE I THINK THINGS IN A WOULD
LIKE WORK WITH THE ON. HOW WE
GET SOME OF THAT LANGUAGE RIGHT
SO THEY'RE TRULY TAKES INTO
ACCOUNT THE GREAT CONSERVATION
EFFORTS THAT HAVE ALREADY BEEN
DONE AND SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE THAT WITH- THESE
NONPROFITS WHO ARE ALREADY
DOING A LOT OF THIS WORK- IN
CALIFORNIA AS AS WE SPEAK
TODAY. WE DON'T WANT TO FALL I
THINK A PATH IT. AND YOU KNOW.
THEY DIDN'T REALLY DEFINED THAT
FOR EXAMPLE FOR OCEANS- THAT WE
REALLY WANT TO HAVE THAT.
BETTER DEFINED AND CLEAR PASS
THAT WE'RE WORKING WITH OUR
PARTNERS TO ENSURE THAT. WE ALL
AGREE ON THE PATH OF PROVIDING
FOR GREATER CONSERVATION OF
LANDS- AND PROVIDING THAT
STEWART IN THAT FOR THE NEXT
GENERATION SO THAT ALL CAN
ENJOY- THE SPACES- BUT JUST
WANT TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR ON
ENSURING THAT- WE GET THIS
LANGUAGE REALLY RIGHT. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER. THANK YOU
MISTER. I SEE NO DISCUSSION.
THIS CALL ARE YOU CLOTHES WE
WEAR. THANK YOU MISTER A
PACIFICA FROM FROM THERE ARE A
OF YEARS A THAT PEOPLE CAN OF
COMMITTEE CONTINUE TO WERE WITH
I NOTE THAT THERE'S ON SIXTY
ENVIRONMENT ORGAN THAT ARE A
SIGN ON LETTER IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILLS I THINK ABOUT THE
BALK. OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL AND
CONSERVATION COMMUNITY IS VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THIS EFFORT OF
COURSE ANYONE THAT IS STILL
OUTLYING BUT HAS CONCERNS WILL
ALWAYS MEET WITH THE MAKE AND
ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS THE BEST
BUY ABILITY THANK YOU WITH
BATTERIES BUT THE LAST ONE I
BOUGHT. THANKS CAR WITH THAT
CARPOOL OF THE ROLE. THE DESIRE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
TO VOTE. ALL MEMBER SERVICE ARE
TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS VOTERS ARE
THOUGH.
WORK WILL CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT EYES FOR ONE NO
SEVENTY. THAT MEASURE PASSES
FILE I FIFTH NINE IS AB. TWO
TWENTY SIX. RECOVERY SOME LEGAL
THIRTY TWO TWENTY SIX BY
FAMILIAR MCCARTY ANOTHER PERSON
ACCOLADE FLOOD PROTECTION
MISSION MCCARTY. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER THIS IS A
DISTRICT BILL BENEFITING MY
DISTRICT AS WELL AS THE
DISTRICT OF MY COLLEAGUE FROM
WINTERS BACK THERE THIS BILL
SIMPLY RE AUTHORIZES THE
STATE'S AUTHORITY TO INVEST IN
THAT YOLO BYPASS SACRAMENTO
BYPASS AIKMAN RIVER PROJECTS
CONSISTENT WITH THE WEST
SACRAMENTO. GENERAL REVALUATION
PROJECT TO FOCUS ON FLOOD.
FLOOD CONTROL. THROUGHOUT THIS
REGION NO OPPOSITION ASK THE
RIVAL THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS
MCCARTY SEEING NO DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THE ITEM. QUIRK
LIBERAL. IS THERE A VOTE. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ARE ABOUT. ALL
MEMBERS VOTERS ABOUT. CLARK
CLOSE ROLE OF A I SAID NO ZERO.
THAT MEASURE PASSED. MEMBERS WE
ARE MOVING TO A VOTE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. PLEASE
REMEMBER WHICH REMOVE AN ITEM
FROM THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEEING AND HEARING NINE. FROM
THE CLERK WILL READ THE SECOND
A GETS A COUNTER. SOME LEGAL
TWENTY ONE THIRTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER AN ACCOLADE
CREAM TOWARDS. THE CLERK WILL
THE ROLE IN THE- SEND CALENDAR.
ALL MY VOTERS ARE TO GO IS THE
CAN SO CALENDAR. ALL MEMBERS
VOTERS ARE TO VOTE.
ALL MEMBERS
OF IT IS A TO VOTE ON THE CAN
CALENDAR. CLARK WELL. CLOSER
ROLE. WE WILL DEFER. A READING
OF THE REMAINING ITEMS ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. TO THE END OF
SESSION. ANNOUNCEMENTS SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS TUESDAY
JUNE NINTH CHECK IN SESSION
WEDNESDAY JUNE TENTH CORPS
SESSION AT TEN AM THURSDAY JUNE
ELEVENTH FLOOR SESSION IS A
NINE AM. FRIDAY JUNE TWELFTH NO
FLOOR SESSION AND CHECK IN
SESSION. IN THE ABSENCE OF
OBJECTION WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED A GERMAN
TO MEMORY. MEMBERS PLEASE TAKE
YOUR SEATS. AND GIVE YOU
RESPECTFUL ATTENTION TO YOUR
COLLEAGUES WE ARE AND
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY. PLEASE
TAKE YOUR SEATS MEMBERS.
SPEAKER RENDON HAS A GERMAN IN
MEMORY PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS MEMBERS.
PLEASE GIVE RESPECTFUL
ATTENTION TO YOUR COLLEAGUES
WERE CHURNING IN THE MEMORY.
THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS WERE
GRANTED PERMISSION PERMISSION
TO SPEAK ON A GERMAN IN MEMORY.
MISTER SPEAKER YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS MEMBERS I RISE
TODAY TO REQUEST THAT THE
ASSEMBLY ADJOURNED IN MEMORY OF
DOCTOR BEATRICE SO LEASE DOCTOR
SOLELY SOMEBODY TO COMMITMENT
TO PEOPLE IN NEED. THAT I HOPE
WE CAN ALL EMULATE. THE KEY
PART OF HER COMMITMENT WAS
BATTLING INEQUALITIES IN HEALTH
CARE. THERE ARE SOME PEOPLE WHO
DON'T GET THE ADVANTAGES OF
NUTRITION. WHO DON'T HAVE
ACCESS TO PREVENTIVE CARE. AND
THOSE WHO EVEN ONCE THEY ARRIVE
AT A MEDICAL FACILITY DON'T GET
THE SAME SERVICE SUPPORT TO
OTHERS. THAT IS WHY SHE EARNED
HER DEGREE IS A DOCTOR OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. AND PUT IT TO
GOOD USE. DOCTOR SO LEAST
SERVED AS DIRECTOR OF LANGUAGE
AND CULTURAL SERVICES FOR THE
ALLEY HEALTH CARE PLAN. A
RESEARCHER AT THE UCLA CENTER
FOR HEALTH POLICY RESEARCH.
AUTHOR OF ARTICLES BOOKS ND
TECHNICAL REPORTS. LECTURE ON
HEALTH THE QUALITY ISSUES.
PRESIDENT OF HISPANICS OF
PHILANTHROPY. AND CHAIR OF THE
ADVISORY COMMITTEE FOR THE UCLA
SCHOOL OF PUBLIC HEALTH. WE
ALSO KNOW HER IS A CRITICAL
PART OF THE CALIFORNIA
ENDOWMENT AS DIRECTOR OF HEALTH
TO COMMUNITIES. SHE IS SURVIVED
BY HER HUSBAND MOHAMMED. HER
CHILDREN A FRIEND AT DEAN AND
HER SISTER AND HER SISTER LA
COUNTY SUPERVISOR HILDA SO
LEASE. HER LIFE THOUGH CUT
SHORT BY CANCER AT THE AGE OF
FIFTY EIGHT. WILL BE LONG
REMEMBERED. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
THAT WE DO A DURING TODAY IN
THE MEMORY OF DR BEATRICE SO
HE'S. THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS ARE PREPARED TO LIVE
THE CALL. ON FILE ITEM. FIFTY
THREE TWENTY NINE NINETY. LOCAL
POST. OUR MEMBERS WERE WHICH TO
VOTE ALL MEMBERS WHO WISH TO
VOTE. ALL MEMBERS VOTED WHICH
TO VOTE.
CLARK WILL CLOSE ROLL
TIDE ABOUT I TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS
NINETEEN THAT MEASURE FAILS.
AND MISS GARCIA. NOTICES
RECONSIDERATION MEMBERS WE ARE
AT ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
MEMBERS WITHOUT OBJECTION WILL
BE LIFTING THE FARM CALL WE ARE
STILL IN A GERMAN TO MEMORY BUT
THE QUORUM CALL HAS BEEN LIFTED.
MEMBERS WE ARE THE GERMANS IN
MEMORY PLEASE. TAKE YOUR SEATS.
OR TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF
OF THE FLOOR OF THE ASSEMBLY.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO DO FOR
THE REMAINING ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY. ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WILL BE PASSED RETAIN
ALL MOTION SHALL BE CONTINUE.
SEEING AND HEARING OVER THE
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN. MISTER
CALDERON MOVES AND. BOTH MISTER
CALDERON MOVES AND. MR BONTA
MOVES AND MISTER LACKEY SECONDS
THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL WEDNESDAY JUNE
TENTH AT TEN AM. MEMBERS THESE
ARE THE REMAINING ITEMS.
CHANGES FOR CHANGES. ONE OF THE
LEADING. MY NAME IS UHHUH OKAY.
THREE OF US AB THREE ONE SIX
THREE I TO NOT VOTING. VOTE
CHANGE THREE OF US ASSEMBLY
BILL THIRTY ONE SIXTY THREE I
TO NOT LOADING. KANSEN CHU AB.
ONE EIGHTY THREE I CAN NO.
KANSEN CHU ASSEMBLY BILL ONE
EIGHTY THREE I TO KNOW. LACKEY
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO FORTY
SEVEN I DON'T KNOW. LACKEY
SEVEN I TO KNOW. FREEDMAN
TWENTY ONE NINETY NINE I TO NOT
VOTING AND THIRTY ONE SIX. OKAY
FRIEDMAN ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
ONE NINETY NINE I TO NOT VOTING
FRIEDMAN ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
ONE SIXTY THREE I TO NOT VOTING.
OBERNOLTE FILE ITEM TO A SIX A.
B. TWO ZERO SIX ONE NOTE TO NOT
VOTING. OBERNOLTE ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SIXTY ONE NO TO NOT ONLY.
YEAH RIGHT. LEVINE AB TWENTY
FOUR SEVENTY THREE I TO KNOW.
LEVINE ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FOUR SEVENTY THREE ALL RIGHT TO
KNOW. BROUGH ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY THIRTY SEVEN NOTICE HI.
ROOM SOME LEGAL TWENTY THIRTY
SEVEN NO TIME FOR ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY TWO FORTY SEVEN NO DAI.
BRO ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO
FORTY SEVEN NO TO OUR. IF
KANSEN CHU VOTE CHANGE. THE V.
THIRTY ONE SIXTY THREE I TO
KNOW. RATHER OCCUR KANSEN CHU
ASSEMBLY WILL THIRTY ONE SIXTY
THREE I TO KNOW. BONTA AB
THIRTY ONE SIXTY THREE I TO NOT
VOTING. BONTA ASSEMBLY BILL
VOTING. YEAH YEAH. THE CLERK
WILL READ THE REMAINING ITEMS
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO FIFTY
THREE I SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE SEVENTY THREE I SEVENTY ONE
NO ZERO SOME PEOPLE NINETEEN
TWENTY NINE I SEVENTY ONE NO
ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN
SIXTY THREE I SEVENTY ONE THOSE
ARE OF THE SOME OF THE NINETEEN
SIXTY EIGHT I SEVENTY ONE THOSE
ARE SOME OF A NINETEEN EIGHTY
FOUR I SEVENTY ONE KNOWS HERE
SOME LEGAL TWO THOUSAND SIX I
SEVENTY ONE OH ZERO ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY SEVENTEEN I SEVENTY
ONE THOSE ARE SOME AGO TWENTY
THIRTY EIGHT I SEVENTY ONE NO
ZERO SOME PEOPLE TWENTY FORTY
SIX I SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO SOME
LEGAL TWENTY FORTY NINE I
SEVENTY ONE KNOWS THERE ARE
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY SIXTY EIGHT
SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO. WE WILL
TWENTY NINETY SEVEN I SEVENTY
ONE THOSE ARE SOME LEGAL TWENTY
ONE A ONE SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY ONE OH FOUR
I SEVENTY ONE THOSE ARE SOME
PEOPLE TWENTY ONE FORTY ONE-
SEVENTY ONE THOSE ARE SOME OF
THE TWENTY ONE FIFTY ONE AS
EVERYONE KNOWS YOUR ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY ONE FIFTY SEVEN
FIVE SEVEN ONE ZERO ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY ONE SIXTY FIVE
SEVEN ONE ZERO SOME PEOPLE
TWENTY ONE SEVENTY TWO AS
EVERYONE KNOWS THERE ARE SOME
PEOPLE TWENTY ONE NINETY TWO
SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO SOME PEOPLE
TWENTY TWO TEN- SEVENTY ONE NO
ZERO SOME PEOPLE TWENTY TO
THIRTY TWO FIVE SEVEN ONE. SOME
PEOPLE TWENTY THREE SIXTY FIVE
FIVE SEVEN ONE ZERO ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY TO SEVENTY. NINE
ONE KNOWS ARE SOME PEOPLE
TWENTY TWO A- SEVEN SO. ONE TO.
SUM PEOPLE TWENTY EIGHTY EIGHT
SEVENTY ONE THOSE ARE SOME OF
THE TWENTY THREE ELEVEN. AS ONE
ZERO WOULD GO TO. THREE TO ONE
SO. ONE ARE SOME OF THE TWENTY.
SIXTY SEVENTY ONE THOSE. SUM
TWENTY THREE EIGHTY SO SEVENTY
ONE NO ZERO SOME PEOPLE TWENTY
FOUR FIFTY NINE. SEVENTY ONE.
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY
NINE I SEVENTY ONE KNOWS SOME
PEOPLE TWENTY FOUR NINETY FOUR.
AS EVERYONE KNOWS THERE ARE
SOME PEOPLE TWENTY TWO FIFTY-
SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO SOME PEOPLE
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY EIGHT-
SEVENTY ONE THOSE ARE SOME
PEOPLE TWENTY FIVE FORTY ONE.
PEOPLE TWENTY FIVE FORTY TWO I
SEVENTY ONE THOSE ARE SOME OF
BOTH. TWENTY FIVE FIFTY NINE AS
EVERYONE KNOWS THERE ARE SOME
PEOPLE TWENTY FIVE SIXTY-
SEVENTY ONE THOSE. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY EIGHT.
SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO SOME PEOPLE
TWENTY FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT-
SEVENTY ONE ZERO SO WE WILL
TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTEEN- SEVENTY
ONE NO ZERO SUM WE WILL TWENTY
SEVEN FIFTY NINE- SEVENTY ONE
KNOWS THERE'S SOME LEGAL TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY THREE- SEVENTY ONE
NO ZRO SOME PEOPLE TWENTY
FORTY FOUR. I SEVENTY ONE A
ZERO SUM WE WILL TWENTY FORTY
NINE I SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO SOME
PEOPLE TWENTY FIFTY FOUR. I
SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO SOME PEOPLE
TWENTY NINE TWENTY. I SEVENTY
ONE KNOWS SOME PEOPLE TWENTY
NINE FORTY FOUR. SEVENTY ONE NO
ZERO SOME LEGAL TWENTY NINE
SIXTY SEVEN. SEVENTY ONE NO
ZERO SOME LEGAL THIRTY FORTY
THREE- SEVENTY ONE KNOWS
THERE'S ONLY ONE THIRTY SIXTY
TWO- SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO SOME
WIGGLE THIRTY SEVENTY THREE.
SEVENTY ONE. SOME PEOPLE THIRTY
EIGHTY SEVEN. SEVENTY ONE. SOME
LEGAL THIRTY NINETY SEVEN.
SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO SOME PEOPLE
THIRTY ONE THIRTY SEVEN. I
SEVENTY ONE THOSE ARE SOME OF
BILL THIRTY ONE THIRTY NINE
WITH URGENCY. AS HAVE ANYONE IS
HERE ON THE URGENCY I SEVENTY
WINDOWS THERE ON THE BILL.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY ONE SIXTY
ONE- SEVENTY ONE THOSE ARE SOME
PEOPLE THIRTY ONE SEVENTY FIVE
I SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO SOME
LEGAL THIRTY TO FORTY TWO-
SEVENTY. ZERO MIDDLE THIRTY TO
SIXTY ONE I SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO
SOME LEGAL THIRTY TO SIXTY
SEVEN. I SEVENTY ONE KNOWS IS
ILLEGAL THIRTY TWO SEVENTY
SEVEN AYE AYES HAVE ANYONE
KNOWS THERE ARE SOME OF YOUR
THIRTY THREE SIXTY TWO. I
SEVENTY ONE NO ZERO MODEL
THIRTY THREE SIXTY THREE I
THIRTY THREE SIXTY FOUR. AS
SEVENTY ONE NO. ZERO SIMPLY GO
FORTY THREE SIXTY FIVE I.
SEVENTY ONE. ARE SOME. THIRTY
THREE SIXTEEN. RATHER THAN
SEVENTY. NO ZERO URGENCY. EYES
SO. ONE OF ARE ON THE SYMBOL
FOR. THREE SO ONE. AS ONE OF
ZERO SO IT IS. WIGGLE BUT THREE
SEVENTY. AS SEVEN. KNOWS IN
ASSEMBLY BILL. THREE SO. FOUR
ASKED. ONE ZERO. EXECUTIVE FROM
THANK YOU SIR. YEAH. WHEN THE
TWENTY FIVE THIRTY SEVEN HI TO
KNOW. TO CHANGE IRWIN ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY FIVE THIRTY SEVEN I
TO KNOW. IRWIN WENTY NINE
NINETY FIVE TO NOT VOTING.
IRWIN SOME PEOPLE TWENTY NINE
NINETY NINE TO NOT VOTING. I
DIDN'T SPIT ON IT.